foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
s
for this cozy coastal town the holiday
season isn't over
in fact the most wonderful time of the
year has really just begun there we go
the tournament leader holds Wesley so to
a drive there's a term he has impressed
all of us
once again vikon Zay starts the new year
as the center of the chess Universe this
year as host of the 85th Tata steel
chess tournament
a magnet for the best players in the
game some recognize the Masters field of
2023 as its strongest in recent memory
of course it helps when eight-time Tata
steel chess champion Magnus Carlson is
back Magnus is going baseball if Magnus
plays like this the rest of the way who
knows what can happen the world's number
one looks to further cement his legacy
in this event and the game's history
chasing Magnus will be amongst the best
in chess several have been crowned
Champion here before some have even
shocked the world in doing so
and don't leave out those poised to
capture their first Tata title what a
fight Geary how to give it his all
because he was on the verge of losing
and he managed to survive
although winter Tata steel chess is also
known as the place new stars come to
bloom
Magnus one here is a teenager this
year's event has its fair share of young
players on the rise each hoping to
follow in Carlson's footsteps he
continues to lead this event and he is
just a teenager the Dutch refer to Tata
steel as The Wimbledon of chess for 85
years in running this tournament
continues to be steeped in Prestige and
Legacy and does so again in this
welcoming Little Dutch town by the sea
mind Brendan it's the 85th edition of
the Tata steel chess tournament and it
starts right now
foreign
it is round 13 of the Tata steel Chess
Masters tournament we have one leader at
the top of the standings it is no
dierberg Abdul sitarov the teenager from
Uzbekistan and while we don't know how
today's action will conclude we know the
tournament will conclude today and it
has been a marvelous event and as we see
in the playing Hall photographers taking
their photos it looks like Anish Geary
he's there early but many of the players
have yet to be seated at their board and
while it is going to be a great day 13
of action I'm brandmaster Robert Hess
alongside me my good friend grab Master
Daniel laradinski Donna we're up bright
and early on the East Coast we are here
in the United States but it is worth it
because today will be an epic it is most
certainly worth it it's not very bright
over here in North Carolina but it will
be pretty soon it's going to be bright
because the chessboards are all going to
be set on fire don't cry because it's
over goes a famous quote often
misattributed Dr Seuss smile because it
happened Robert we have been treated to
an incredible display of Chess and very
likely the greatest part is still ahead
oh yes indeed we have had some sparkling
chests thus far and yesterday's action
also included some great games while the
top of the leaderboard did not change
because those people up top they drew
their games Parham maxulu beats Arjun
era geissi Richard report takes down
dingly Ren so we had two fun battles but
at the bottom of the results they were
here but five draws up top and most
importantly for nordirback abusatara he
was able to hold off Wesley so a day
after holding on to nishikiri
both games with the black pieces both
games held from a position of strength
especially his game against Wesley so
where notorbeck was simply slightly
better for the second half of the game
he has been incredible no matter how you
look at it with the white pieces with
the black pieces in the opening in the
end game when he's worse when he's
better he has displayed every possible
skill to lead this tournament but what a
disappointing result yesterday for the
world champion Robert as his hopes to
win this tournament they don't entirely
come to an end but essentially they do
he is unable to convert that big
advantage against pragna Nanda and the
Indian Junior holds him to a draw
and as you see Parham muksulu had a big
win he moves up to eighth place and he
if he finishes the tournament with by
not losing his final round he'll be at
his highest ever rating so the bottom of
the standings and we start there it was
it was a teenagers right some of the
younger generation they've struggled in
this event no surprise but I think what
is most surprising is dingley Ren the
World Chess Championship Challenger is
only five points out of 12 games he's
dropped 12 below 2800 he's now number
three in the world after entering number
two well ahead of his opponent for the
world championship John apomichi so done
as we look at the top of the leaderboard
it's been all about the dierberg Abdul
sitarov the Uzbek teenager the Olympiad
gold medalist the former World rapid
Champion he has been an absolute star
he has indeed and as I just said he has
displayed skill and Acumen and just
incredible play in every stage of the
game Tata steel is arguably the most
prestigious super tournament it's
definitely the most grueling super
tournament both because it's 13 Rounds
long and the time control is vast to be
leading this tournament essentially
wired to wire is going to be if Notre
back can complete the run and make a
solid draw or even win the game today
perhaps the most impressive performance
of notorbeck's of notorbeck Abdus
tariff's career to date and boy has he
had a lot of impressive performances
already not least of which this of
course is win in the world rapid
championship
and he's the lone teenager at the top of
the standings and he can win this
tournament if he just wins his game that
is all that's required of him to take
first in this tournament as simple as
that it's that simple of course beating
your invent for us huh walk in the park
no but in all seriousness he will take
first place if he wins his game
otherwise if he draws his game and needs
to carry wins we'll get a tie break and
if no dearbeck loses and these period
does not win Magnus Carlson and Wesley
so have an outside chance so as we look
forward to today's action we know that
no dearbec abuser tariff he controls his
own destiny but Anish giri and the
others are hoping that no dearbeck loses
today and let's start right there he
gets the white pieces against Jordan Von
Forest Daniel what do you make of that
matchup
man oh man Jordan men Forest had perhaps
the most topsy-turvy game of anybody
yesterday was a seven hour Affair
against Anish giri where Jordan was off
to a flaming start he had what seemed to
be a surely decisive attack but then a
couple of mistakes later things got
complicated Jordan he must be feeling
tremendously fatigued and now he's got
the black pieces against the tournament
leader I think for Notre back it'll be
crucial not to take too many risks a
draw is satisfactory Anish giri as we
will discuss has a very tall task in
front of him this as we can see there is
their first classical meeting so I'm not
expecting anything crazy by Notre back
Robert I'm expecting very solid play now
obviously if Jordan gives him chances if
Jordan plays something sharp I think
norterbeck is going to embrace the fight
but I think we're gonna see solid
consistent play and uh a draw is
definitely a fine result in the final
round well for somebody with four
victories to his name only one coming
with the white pieces that is surprising
but Jordan front forest does bring the
heat and he has more losses than draws
with black so if this game is going to
be a draw it probably will not be just a
solid one so as we talk about the other
matchup the really key matchup in this
final round if no deerback abducator is
unable to win Anish giri steps in with a
chance and yesterday's game was
topsy-turvy as you described it today he
doesn't have an easier opponent at all
Richard report has been on fire in
recent rounds and he always brings fire
to the board you do not know what to
expect when you play the Romanian
Hungarian player he's from Hungary he
grew up competing for the Hungarian
Federation now he switched over to
Romania but his chest style has not
switched he still brings it every single
game
there are pluses and minuses to facing
Richard report in the final round the
plus side is that you know report as you
have been saying is going to bring the
fight he is not just going to play a
quiet Berlin he is going to play for the
win with the black pieces especially
given how well he's been playing in the
second part of the tournament but Robert
that is simultaneously a good thing
because anishagiri realistically he
needs a win and he's going to be going
for the win it's also a negative because
Richard report has the capacity to blow
anyone off the board with either caller
just think about how close he came uh to
doing that to the world champion Magnus
ended up winning that game but his King
was on a hunt Richard report applauding
there
this is not going to be an easy trial
for a fatigued Anish Gary coming off
that incredibly long gaming and spent
Forest
and Richard report played a Stella game
with black against Argent era Garcia
speaking of Arjun has not been his
tournament he gets the white pieces
against Magnus Carlson Magnus he needs a
win he needs to know dierberg loss he
needs anishagiri not to win himself so
the chances are slim for him to take
first same is true for Wesley so he gets
the black pieces against pragananda a
resilient Prague who drew Magnus
yesterday dingley Wren fabulous carwana
that could be a world championship match
in another parallel lifetime but
unfortunately for these two players they
do not have a shot of first place
dingley runs struggling with the white
pieces I'm expecting to be solid levada
that is a heavyweight matchup these two
players have great Fighting Chess Styles
and I think they will fight today and
it's not they're not going to take it a
day off just because they're out of
contention for first Vincent kymer and
good cash the teenagers they will
compete visit cameras played the longest
games of the events and gukesh would
like to end his tournament on the right
foot but all eyes all cameras are on
this match up here Dania it's no dear
Becca Bruce atarov it's Jordan Von
Forest will the Dutch husband do is
complete your favor and take down the
Uzbek player or will we see no deerback
abusot sail to tournament Victory he has
seemed Unstoppable to this point
buckle your seat belts ladies and
gentlemen and make sure that they are
buckled tight because this is going to
be a grueling Affair this ain't gonna be
a quick draw quick draws are frowned
upon and Tata steel and we haven't seen
many of them we've barely seen any at
all in the time control it really caters
to some of these long topsy-turvy
Affairs as the players receive 100
minutes for the first 40 moves and then
another 50 minutes and then another 15
minutes on move 60 and there's a 30
second increment but more importantly
the clocks have been started the first
move has been made and Notre break up to
satorov is going to try to complete his
greatest tournament performance of his
career today with a dazzling display in
the Final Round Here We Go and you see
that Jordan front Forest plays the
Sicilian uh that doesn't necessarily
mean we'll get a very sharp opening but
he's indicating he is willing to fight
he's not just playing a symmetrical
position and we see E6 on move two so
not the night orph not anishkiri's
course on chessable but we have yet to
see what Jordan Von Force has in store
for Abdus Atari and that can be scary
right when you're playing this final
round game the pressure is on you but
you can see some people taking photos
right nearby but for abusotaro we know
he's a cool customer he has a world
rapid Championship to his name he also
won Olympiad team gold medal and
performs Super well on the top board for
his country so he has what it takes but
will the nerves get to him that's a big
question
and Jordan trying to make sure that the
nerves get to him through his opening
choice that first move one C5 it means
so many things but most importantly it
means Jordan is going to play
uncompromising chess he is not
interested in allowing some sort of
quick liquidation we know that Jordan is
a tremendously versatile player in the
opening we've seen him play 1e5 we've
seen him play the Karo Khan very
successfully but both of these openings
allow white to liquidate the game in
most variations if he desires a drop
against the Sicilian there are more
positional variations white could play
the allopin white could Dodge the open
Sicilian those crazy lines with opposite
side castling but Robert you are almost
always going to get some sort of an
imbalance and black is almost always
going to get winning chances that is why
the Sicilian essentially stands alone as
the opening that you want to play if you
want to guarantee a fighting game and
normally no deerbeck looks at his
opponent he stares at him but I think he
looked over him and I'm wondering where
in the playing Hall and each Geary is
because that's what notary book has to
avoid it's going to be difficult but he
can't just be looking at a niche's game
oh is he not going to win so if he
doesn't win all I need is a draw but if
he's winning maybe I should also play
for a win you can't get distracted by
anything besides your own game that is
where your focus has to be and but
you're back despite being a teenager he
is very experienced he knows just that
he does not need any advice from little
old me over here but it is a sicilian
that means we probably will have a sharp
battle and from the very first move
that's the big question Dania if you're
a half Point ahead a draw guarantees you
at minimum a tie for first do you play
Super solid but maybe don't give
yourself witty chances or you take a bit
of risk and play in like you would if
around one
well the common wisdom is that you the
best way to secure a draw is of course
to play for a win but my coach a couple
of years ago also shared what I think
are very wise words if a draw satisfies
you one E4 all things held equal is
actually a wiser move to play than one
D4 that may seem paradoxical D4 is known
as the more positional the quieter line
but the thing is variations after one E4
are incredibly forcing so if you're well
prepared In the Sicilian Forest then you
want to go for those sharp positions if
Notre back knows what he's doing they're
also likely to go down a long
theoretical line and if notabreg emerges
out of that line with a good position
then the Lion's Share of the work has
already been done so I love the fact
that you that Notre back is not shying
away from his main preparation he took
there a little bit of time after E6 to
steal himself maybe he thought about
playing a nice little alapin or a move
like G3 but no no no that's not what he
prepared before the tournament and he
decides to stick to his guns that's what
he's done all tournament long there's no
reason to shy away from that in the
final round
you know you missed an opportunity for a
pun you said the Sicilian Forest I
thought you said the Sicilian Vodafone
yeah it's 6 20 a.m you know my brain
isn't what it used to be and I haven't
had coffee yet I forgive you and for
nadir Becca Abdus atarv and Jordan Von
Forest I mean you can just tell because
typically players they get through the
opening phase the first five ten moves
extremely quickly but abdusitor of is
taking his time on every turn and you
can see the photographers they're making
sure that they can catch him on camera
but
he has tuned out the world he is focused
on his game here and he is just playing
standard opening moves but I don't know
I just get this feeling that it's such a
tense moment and when you don't have a
wealth of experience just because you're
very young that can be nerve-wracking on
the other hand Jordan front Force has
nothing to lose we've seen that in
recent rounds with the black pieces
against dingly red he took up the mantle
from the very first move sacrificed upon
and everything got chaotic then against
Denise Geary he sacrificed in exchange
he gave him a rook for just a bishop and
then that was a tactical melee so Jordan
has proven throughout his career thus
far and that includes a victory in the
2021 Todd steel Chess Masters that he is
willing to fight no matter the
tournament situation indeed and a case
in point in that very same game that you
mentioned against anishikiri yes he
messed up his big Advantage but even in
that end game he declined something like
six or seven move repetitions you could
easily imagine a scenario where you
admit you've messed up an advantage you
take a quick draw you go eat some dinner
Jordan is not interested in that he did
everything he could he pressed all of
the buttons available to him he
exhausted every resource yesterday no
matter how long it took Anish Gary with
some incredible defensive skills to hold
the draw in that game but Jordan
signifying that he really isn't all that
interested in three or four extra rating
points he wants to make his imprint on
the final Tournament standings and he is
displaying that once again here with the
black pieces against Notre back and we
see now the queen coming out to C7
Robert that can only mean one thing that
means Jordan is essaying the taimanov
variation of the Sicilian which is along
with the Knight ORF and the
sebastianakov one of the hottest and
most popular Sicilian variations in
recent years
for sure and there is a lot of opening
Theory and the good news if you're a fan
of any skier it is is that in many of
these positions there's no way to just
force a draw sometimes in some openings
it's like if you don't make a draw
immediately the game is over uh in the
sense that you get yourself in trouble
so this type of opening and we can bring
up the board here uh is one that it's
far away there's no forced liquidation
there's no way to say let's move back
and forth and if you don't copy those
moves and make that three-time
repetition then you're in trouble so
let's just talk about the Contours here
the dark squares do look compromised in
Black's position because your pawns on
A6 and on E6 and no C Pawn so that means
a knight would love to land on some of
those dark squares that you're
highlighting but the black pawns take
care of F5 and D5 and B5 so that Knights
do not have forward access just yet and
one of the most popular moves here for
white I believe the queen F3 to G3 is
played in these types of positions to
trade the Queens off on favorable terms
for white so that if that Queen is
captured there the H Pawn comes the G3
the H file opens up so The Rook develops
in its starting place and wait the queen
of three just happened what a timely
call by you I mean and look look at that
move H5
we are in for a fight
oh my God this is crazy on so many
levels now Queen to F3 Robert this
became incredibly popular oh about six
or seven years ago and before that Queen
to D2 followed by the English attack
setup with F3 and Castle's King side uh
queenside was almost automatic then
Queen F3 arrived on the scene now
everybody is playing it so obviously
Jordan men Forest must have expected it
and I know that H5 is actually not such
an atypical move in this variation but I
have never seen it played this early
yesterday Jordan Ben first goes H4 I
think on move seven today he plays H5
with the black pieces also on move seven
what is the idea of that move well I
could point out a couple of things
Robert and this is on a very superficial
level first of all you're getting
control of the G4 Square you are
preventing the progress or at least
taking the sting out of the move G4 and
you can use the G4 Square as a
stronghold for black snide Knight F6 to
G4 can create massive pressure on
White's Bishop on E3 which in turn is
supporting the Knight on D4 and in
addition the pawn could Advance down to
H4 and cover the G3 Square preventing uh
The crucial idea that you just outlined
is this a novelty I don't know I'm going
to check but I love what we're seeing
thus far and I just want to show a quick
line because Queen G3 that was the idea
we're talking about and the point is
that if black does take on G3 then the H
Pawn takes back for White and The Rook
is very happy to be on the H file
because the H5 Pawn is a target G3 to G4
can be played in the near future take
advantage of the pin along the H file
and there's immediate pressure against
Black's position but instead of taking
the queen on G3 I believe black has the
resource Bishop D6 and if you try to
take this Pawn on G7 then black has to
move Bishop E5 and The Rook on h8 is
defended and the Knight on D4 is loose
so black would steal some material and
this is getting very sharp early on and
no dearbeck abduced atarov I don't
believe he has prepped this we see him
thinking and that's what Jordan Von
forest does best maybe the engine says
this is the fifth best move but it's not
not a losing decision to make with H5 he
just challenges his opponent from the
very early stage of the game puts them
deep in the think tank and then uses a
clock as a weapon in addition to his
brain
he is always on the Vanguard of modern
opening preparation and the Hallmark of
modern opening preparation is that the
world has been discovered you're not
going to find any new islands off the
coast of the Atlantic you're not going
to find any refutations uh to the
openings that are now played commonly so
what you need to do is actually
essentially the opposite you need to
find moves that the computer initially
disapproves of but the more you analyze
them the more the engine understands
their value and they can also be
valuable from a human standpoint there
are plenty of positions where the engine
assigns a big advantage to White and yet
Black's position is much easier to play
from a practical standpoint we've seen
that many times in this tournament heck
we've seen that several times in Jordan
and Forest games yesterday against
anishikiri the computer assigned an edge
to Black after that Brazen looking H4
move guess what Anish giri was dead lost
10 moves later
yes it was a shark battle that was going
Jordan's way until he faltered a bit uh
but he is showing that he is still
determined and I saw the chat uh someone
saying credit to Jordan respect for
playing Fighting Chess not just trying
to make a quick draw that's not Jordan
Vaughn Forest he's invited to this event
each and every year yes in part because
he's Dutch but he is a former champion
of this tournament and that doesn't
happen by accident you have to be well
prepared you have to be ready for a
fight in every single game and uh just
to go back to the game position uh with
the queen on F3 and Bishop on f8 uh that
just goes to show that he is just trying
to make this tactical at an early stage
so Queen G3 has not been played I'm not
sure it will be played just because of
this response Bishop D6 and if you don't
play the Queen over to G3 what's the
other thing you can do is Castle
queenside because you did bring your
queen out of your King's path so casting
queenside does look like an option for
white but then black quickly strikes
with Pawn to B5 and the same exact ideas
hold true that if and when white plays
Queen G3 don't be surprised when move
like Bishop D6 is the response and
actually another think about it can we
just show that because I think I found
another yeah
Castle's Queen side so B5 after Castle's
Queen side very standard play
and then if you play Queen G3 I think
Bishop D6 is still the idea because if
you take on G7
Bishop E5 is the response
and if you play Queen G5 the only safe
Square Knight takes D4 and there's a big
problem
because Bishop F4 check wins the queen
on the spot someone did his puzzle Rush
at 5am this morning Bishop F4 check
white has to take back with the Rook
Robert but that just devolves into
complete pandemonium that's exactly what
Jordan benforest wants yes the G7 Pawn
may not be the most important piece on
this board and it would no longer be on
the board in this continuation and this
is what Jordan is aiming for this is
maximum chaos and if you're a niche
Geary you are thrilled if you're able to
get up for your board because of course
he's busy calculating wondering his own
options in his position but you see this
and you have to be happy because Jordan
Von Forest is showing that he is ready
to Duke it out and foreign
it's a bit of a worrisome moment because
you don't know what the engine say you
don't know exactly what the best moves
are he's done nothing wrong he's playing
just good chess on solid fundamentals
but H5 is just throwing a wrench to this
planet
and as you were making those great
points I did a little bit of research
now my database doesn't have the very
latest update with games from the last
couple of months so take what I'm about
to say with a tiny grain of salt so H5
is not a novelty but to give you context
on how rare that move is I am seeing 10
games in the database after H5 10 games
may sound like a lot but in the main
move which is seven Knight to F6 there
are 1
124 games in terms of popularity H5 is
one two three four five six seven eight
ninth move uh by popularity so that is
what your inventforce does these are the
kinds of obscure moves that he sees
essentially guaranteeing that this did
not come across notary's radar and even
if it did Notre back was likely to cast
only a superficial glance at H5 guess
what Robert in those 10 games black has
scored over 50 percent black has won six
of those 10 games and several of them
featured Grandmasters handling the white
pieces I am loving this already and no
matter how this game ends I think we are
being set up for a photo finish in this
game and in this tournament
well can I ask your questions do you
have the the database open please do
what what has those Grant Masters who
are the white pieces what has been their
move after H5
so in the original game from 2016 uh as
well as in a seven other game so eight
total games continued Castle's Queen
side and then black actually responded
with several different options four
different moves were made in that
position one of them was indeed uh the
move B5 and that was played by Costa
kavutsky a name that should be familiar
to a lot of players in the chat Costa is
a sicilian expert he wrote a book from
the white side of the Sicilian so he is
definitely someone uh to be trusted on
the black side he ended up losing that
game and after B5 white traded on C6 but
I looked through that game and he
actually got a very decent position out
of the opening one game continued Queen
G3 the movie originally indicated black
did not respond to Bishop D6 but that
may be Jordan's Innovation and the final
game uh continued Knight D4 takes C6
something tells me that Notre back isn't
going to release the tension this early
and Knight takes E6 Robert is a move
that you need to play with tremendous
caution because black could take back
with the B Pawn and not only will d75 be
easier to carry out but the B file opens
up and that essentially gives black an
attack on a golden platter if White
Castles to the queen side yeah I mean
that does not look appealing in the
slightest because bringing another black
pawn towards the center uh reinforcing
that D5 push as you're talking about
that is not appealing for Abdus Atari so
he's going to sit and think so why don't
we look at what's happening in our
second place uh in the leaderboard's
position because in each Geary if no
dear abdusitarov does not win this game
he has a chance to at the very least tie
for first so Anish we see him on camera
right here he is it looks like his eyes
are closed almost and now they're back
open he's stunning the position but it's
already a sharp battle in that game too
because we do not have symmetry we do
not just have simple peace Richard
report no surprise he is playing an
opening that is a bit challenging kind
of uh provocative if you will
oh my land's in another incredibly rare
opening variation this is the Richard
report of old we used to play the move
C4 followed by G4 and with black you
could fill a volume with the Obscure
crazy openings that he played against
the strongest players in the world
oftentimes successfully he returns to
his old self here let's rewind and
update everybody on the type of Sicilian
that Richard report has decided to trot
out it starts out completely normally
Robert in fact it starts out as one of
the most reputable Sicilian variation
this is called the Rouser or the
classical variation uh of course in the
nidorf you play the move A6 and the
classical you bring your other Knight
out white plays the main move Bishop G5
and this is where report turns off the
beaten path he plays the move G6 and you
might say well isn't this the dragon not
quite it's kind of a mixture between the
Rouser and the dragon and the downside
of this move the reason that it is as
rare as it is consists in Gary's next
move he snaps the the night off on F6
completely Robert ruining Black's Pawn
structure in the center but giving up
the bishop pair and the bishop pair is
what black really banks on in this line
Gary follows up with the bishop B5 and
Richard report defends the Knight on C6
what do you make of this well the bot
structure clearly is not very pleasant
to look at from Black's perspective you
have an isolated D6 Pawn you have double
pawns on the f-file and where is that
dark Square Bishop going to go that is
the advantage in Black's position is he
is the only player with a dark Square
Bishop so if he can play Bishop G7 and
pawn to F5 maybe he can wreak havoc on
the long diagonal but that's not easy to
accomplish because right now it's
White's turn I believe the queen can
slide up to a square like D2 then white
can Castle Queen side and already you're
seeing pressure on black center if you
bring that Bishop to G7 the D6 Pawn at
any moment will be targeted and that
seems to be an issue for Rich report to
do it now he did just stumble into this
position he chose it this was voluntary
so he must have some tactical ideas in
store for Geary and I think they revolve
around as you're pointing out Bishop G7
and pawn to F5 so at the right moment
the board opens up and that can be good
news for a pair of Bishops
and I've got an emotional connection to
this variation because I played this
with black only once but in a game that
was very important to me uh this was in
uh an open tournament in Denmark I was
facing a strong I am and I just felt a
hankering to guarantee uh winning
Chances with the black pieces I don't
remember exactly how this get how that
game went but I do think that we had
this exact position on the board and the
big decision that Anish giri has to make
is of course between castle and King
side and Castle link Queen side the
principled approach in almost any
Sicilian variation is in fact a castle
queenside and so we could expect a move
like Queen to D2 but given the fact that
he knows Richard's report is well
prepared perhaps a quieter approach
gasoline King side maybe dropping the
Knight back to B3 to open up a line of
communication between the queen and the
D6 spawn I think a serious case is to be
made uh for this idea as well and I
would just finish Robert by saying that
anishkiri is obviously aware of the
existence of this variation but it's a
similar thing as in abducator of Van
Forest Richard Deport has chosen an
obscure line that is of course
relatively speaking well known it's been
played for many many years it still has
hundreds of games in the database but
compared to the other Sicilians it's so
unpopular that it is unlikely that Anish
Gary has reviewed this line
perhaps even in the last couple of years
great opening Choice from Richard port
and you look at his scores six and a
half into 12 and he did not get off to a
good start he lost in the first round
with the white pieces to know dear Becca
Abdul satara he'd later lost to Magnus
Carlson so he was looking at a bleak
outcome from the start of this event and
suddenly he's found his form he has won
three of his recent games he beat
dingley run yesterday he would love to
end this tournament with another Victory
that's the good thing about Richard
report and as we look at their
head-to-head stats he has never beaten
and he's Gary In classical chess you
know he wants to put an L in that column
for a niche he would like to get his
first Victory and for Anish Geary this
is a huge moment he needs to defeat
Richard report because he'll find
himself either in clear first if Norbert
loses in order to make draws he'll find
himself in the tie for first and if
Nordic happens to win it doesn't matter
what anisha's result is because then
you're back wins the tournament
and what adds a little bit of sriracha
to this narrative is of course the fact
that Gary I believe has been runner-up
five separate times at Tata steel the
most painful one of those was in 2021
when he went into a tiebreaker against
Jordan men forest and lost that
incredibly top speed survey game so
Geary has had a chip on his shoulder all
tournament long and you could not ask
for a better opportunity you're facing
someone whom you know is going to give
you an unbalanced game you've got the
white pieces and I think any scary is
probably happy with the kind of
physician that he has got but right now
he needs to make several more moves he
has a very important decision to make as
to where which side he castles and he
just doesn't seem all that comfortable
he knows that Richard report is probably
better prepared than he is in this line
and I always point this out Robert these
situations
there is always a choice between making
the obvious move which your opponent was
likely to prepare or trying to deviate
from the trodden path with some sort of
move that you think your opponent was
unlikely to analyze but that is an
incredibly dangerous game because you
could stumble yourself into a pretty bad
position
I think the plans for black are just
very straightforward and that's one of
the biggest issues for a niche security
Bishop G7 castles kingside and pawn to
F5 and I want to show a sample variation
if we can bring up an analysis board to
talk about what that may look like then
if white plays Queen D2 which to my eyes
is the most natural move of playing
bullet Bishop G7 and you castle
queenside for white so you have maximum
pressure along the D file and black says
have fun with that Castle's King side
that D6 Pawn is isolated and weak go
ahead Knight takes C6 and black actually
should take with the bishop on C6
because if you take with the pawn on C6
instead uh then you go Queen takes D6
and this is really really bad news for
black the D7 Bishop is hanging and then
white will have a great knight is able
to hop around so I think Bishop takes C6
is possible for black and if we get the
swap of Bishops on C6 and the queen
comes and takes the point it looks great
white is just up a pawn but that Queen
trait is avoided with Queen to B6
putting pressure on the B2 Pawn putting
pressure on the F2 Pawn and F6 to F5 is
next automatic trying to open up that
bishop and go after the Knight on C3 and
the pawn on B2 behind it so I just look
at a position like this you know exactly
what Rich report's plan is and for a
knee she's like I I get material but at
what cost
Black's position holds tremendous
potential energy the weaknesses in
Black's position are more readily
apparent than the strings but I think
this line very nicely illustrates the
strengths and before we close that
analysis board if I may quickly show
another sample variation that furthers
this point let's say that white chooses
to go the other way that white chooses
to go kingside that does not diminish
the effectiveness of the move F5 I have
actually found a game between Magnus
Carlson and Daniel dubov in a blitz
batch from 2021 in which Daniel dubov
who played this line six or seven times
scored a crushing Victory the game
proceeded as follows White Castle
kingside black developed the bishop to
G7 Magnus dropped the Knight back to uh
E2 opening up an attack on D6 duboff
plays the important move Bishop to E6
defending the pawn to this queen Magnus
swings the Knight over to F4 duboff
castles and guess what after Magnus
plays Queen D2 dubuff already struck in
the center with F5 opening up his dark
squid bishop and then he added insult to
injury at after Rook a to D1
he stuck a knight on D4 and just look at
how active Black's minor pieces now are
he's completely masking the weakness of
the D6 spawn and dubov went on to score
a pretty convincing Victory yes this was
a Blitz game but anytime Magnus Carlson
loses anywhere Robert I think you'll
co-sign this point that line needs to be
taken very seriously
for sure and I'm just looking at the
position with a knight on D4 that Bishop
opened on G7 the queen on d8 can go to
the queen set or even to the king side
at this point to square like H4 G5 so
Anisha has made his move I'm very
curious what it is and he gets up from
the board so wow speaking of making a
move that is unexpected he blocks his
Bishop back to C4 and done I think we
understand his point the B5 square is
better for a knight so by bringing the
bishop to C4 you fully control the D5
Square which will be an outpost for a
Knight Warrior Bishop but also gives the
B5 Square to your D4 Knight and once
that Knight gets out the way the D6 Pawn
is in big trouble
Bishop C4 is far from the most common
move that honor belongs to short Castle
but it has been played by a couple of
very strong players Peter svidler
managed to defeat Daniel duboff in a
rapid game with this move recently
vaishali who is playing in the
Challenger section pregnant on the
sister has also successfully essayed
this move and white will actually have a
choice after blackfian cattle's Bishop
which I think is very likely you can
play Knight DB5 and go directly for the
D6 Pawn but more likely and more
consistent with anisha's style I think
would be in fact a trade on C6 castle
kingside and as you're suggesting
establish either a knight or perhaps
even a bishop on D5 and one of the
benefits of the trade on C6 is that
you're largely taking the sting out of
the move F5 because then white can
simply recapture on F5 and the last
thing black wants to do is take back
with the g-pawn and permanently ruin his
King Side Pawn structure a very
interesting choice by a niche I think
it's a very good decision because you
might be able to take Rich report out of
deep preparation and now he it looks
like he's on his own and Anish this is a
big moment for him we know that this
tournament means so much he is an
ambassador and media spoke to Anish
yesterday asked him how he felt about
his upcoming match with Rich report and
he didn't want to say much but let's
take a listen
no I'm not going to say anything
and the Richard has the right to watch
this interview so I'm not going to say
anything about this the upcoming game I
can tell you that I had a certain plan
for it uh
um but we'll see
he certainly does have the right to
remain silent even if he uses Twitter as
his uh you know fertile grounds for
speaking but I it's interesting because
the chess players they want to hide all
information that is not already
accessible you do not want to tell
anybody who you're working with because
if they know that that they're working
if the world knows that they're working
with Daniel noraditski they'll start
googling and researching go in the
database for dania's openings and that
gives them a hint at what that player
might be looking at they'll be pretty
horrified at what they'd find okay
maybe but still it gives them
information so Anish is saying I'm not
going to tell you my game plan I might
you know I'm not going to say I'm going
all in because that may give a hint to
Richard about a specific opening choice
so I think and he did the right thing in
the interview he's playful as ever but
Richard he said I don't mind I am going
to choose a fighting variation I'm not
going to sit passively and defend the
slightly worse position no Richard
report is not that type of player and
the person was standing next to a niche
in that interview Jordan van Forest he's
not that type player either so we have
two fighting games on the top boards
we do indeed and for the first time this
bright and early morning let's take a
look at the bird's eye view obviously we
have more games to cover and we will
keep an eye on the games that do not
directly impact the top of the
tournament cross table but obviously the
trifecta that we will spend by far the
most time on is abducator of Van Forest
where we have seen the Queens come off
the board you called it that Queen from
F3 it swung over to G3 Jordan actually
accepted the trade and has just brought
his dark short Bishop out to C5 it still
appears that he is in his preparation
and Notre back I mean maybe you should
fly to Amsterdam right now I know
there's a couple direct flights from New
York City because you are predicting
every idea in that game G3 to G4
striking where it hurts hitting that H5
pawn and exploiting The undefended Rook
on h8 Notre back he looks like he's in
control he looks like he's confident but
Jordan might very well be in his
preparation and Robert of course Magnus
Carlson I'm looking for him he is on the
bottom top bottom left it took me a
while bottom left of your screen again
third generic icy just from the fact
that he's got both of his Bishops fan
ghetto you know that the world champion
is trying to mix it up and score a
victory in the final round he certainly
is and other players are fighting look
at the games right next to that Prague
Nanda this is second from the left and
the bottom against Wesley so Wesley up a
pawn with the black pieces uh but well
actually he's not of a pawns even
material looks like he's up with Parks
A2 is gone uh but even material but
there's a knight there's hopping with
the D6 square with check so Wesley so he
needs a win he needs no deerback to lose
and then he would have a shot at first
place so why don't we dive into Wesley
sews game uh because Mattis Carlson's
game has all the pieces on the board
this is Fighting Chess all around no
Player is taking the day off look at
this position Donya what is that Queen
doing on A2 why are both Kings still in
the center why is there a lack of
development and the black king doesn't
check
be still my beating heart is all I have
to say I don't think anybody is going to
begrudge us a closer look at the
pandemonium that we have on the board
after only 17 moves and only is probably
the wrong word because we're only 30
minutes or so into the round and we're
already 17 moves deep the most
disturbing thing for Wesley is that
Prague has all of his time left on the
clock we've talked about this a lot that
is a clear sign that he is still in his
preparation and this is not the kind of
position that you want to be on your own
you want to have that stockfish GPS
readily available and it looks like
Prague has turn by turn directions he's
got a knight on D6 Robert I could rewind
and quickly show how this crazy position
occurred you think that's a wise uh
thing to do I think it is
let's go all the way back from the start
you could be forgiven for thinking this
is some sort of Sicilian uh that the
first move was E4 but no the first move
was actually D2 D4 this started out
pretty peacefully as a queen's gamma
declined things got crazy on move four
C7 C5 by Wesley so the semitarash after
C takes D5 rather than the conventional
Knight takes D5 he takes the pawn on D4
this is a well-known line and recently
white has been mostly recapturing the
pawn on T4 Prague plays the old move
Queen to A4 check forcing the bishop
onto D7 cutting the contact between
Black's queen and the D5 pawn and white
accepts what is called I think The
Shining Hara Gambit by taking on T4
a trade on D5 Black's pieces start
coming out one after the other check on
A5 the Knight comes out with Tempo
Prague drops back the Knight comes out
to E4 attacking the Knight on C3 Prague
defends with Bishop D2 We have a trade
Wesley grabs the bishop air and brings
his Bishop out man this is only playable
with preparation Rook to C1 Prague gives
the pawn back Wesley accepts it he takes
the Knight giving back his Bishop pair
but taking on A2 Prague develops his
Knight to C4 preventing black from
castling Queen side the bishop will hang
after Bishop E6 E4 suddenly he is
threatening Rook to A3 trapping the
queen Wesley addresses that actively by
counter-attacking whites Queen and after
Knight to D6 tracking f8 we've got more
craziness Queen D1 to C1 is prague's
Choice reinforcing the threat of Rook A3
you still can't take the Knight because
you lose the queen and Wesley has just
evacuated his Queen from A2 I have
talked enough Robert you take over
please
18 moves into this game both players
playing quickly you have to assume this
is preparation and I wouldn't be
surprised if prognanda has 10 more moves
up his sleeve and I also wouldn't be
surprised if this just Fizzles out into
a draw I don't like talking in those
terms but I think Wesley he said the
onus is now on me I have the black
pieces I can't just allow a solid game
where I'm slightly worse let me try for
a forcing variation the problem with
forcing variations at this highest level
is that they are studied and they're
playing instantly at this point and we
see that a Pawn on B7 was captured The
Rook on d8 is loose the Knight C6 is
loose Queen E3 you can't play Queen B1
check because if you give that check the
Rook slides back to C1 and white is
going to steal material with the Rook on
d8 being loose so Queen trade
this could be a position where white is
ever so slightly better I can barely get
words out and the moves are happening
and the point is that now if you take on
C6 the Knight of B7 is hanging and very
importantly the bishop on E6 covers the
C8 Square there is no back rank check to
win that Rook on h8 and the pawn
structure is clearly at the moment
better for black so the status quo is
good for black but with that lasting
Knight C5 you're going to be able to
take on E6 that's the hope and then
you're going to also compromise Black's
Pawn structure or have a bishop against
a knight position so this is deep
opening prep Donya it looks to my eyes
like both players know exactly what
they're doing and there's not much to
commentate on in a way because they're
playing the best moves well prague's
opening file might actually start here I
mean if he seriously dug deep the real
question is you know whose preparation
extends to move 40 and listen I stand
corrected I thought for a second that
Wesley was out of his prep I looked at
his clock time I think it was just a
case of Wesley remembering his opening
file you saw how incredibly complex that
line was if you confuse even a single
move if you play even a single move out
of order you could literally lose the
game instantly that is not an
exaggeration we saw that Black's Queen
was on the verge of getting trapped so
Wesley very wisely taking a little bit
longer than his confident opponent to
make sure that he's got all of the moves
right and he did he's got himself into
an end game and what counter balances
White's deficient Pawn structure is of
course the ultra active Knight on C5
which is currently threatening to take
on E6 the Knight on C6 is going to hang
and that's why Rook takes B2 is
impossible
White's bishop and White's Rook also
have tremendous potential energy look at
that semi-openf file the bishop could
come out to C4 white could actually
Castle kingside I do not believe that
white has moved his King took me a
second to remember that and the King on
f8 could get caught in the crossfire of
the F1 Rook so I think the position is
equal I think the game should end in a
draw with accurate play by Wesley but
the big question is going to be does
this opening file extend a couple more
moves because if he's on his own here it
is far from easy to find the way to
neutralize White's initiative a good
choice by Prague he's basically playing
risk free
yes it's a risk-free position that's a
good way of framing it and that means
you can play for two results so he feels
but it is an end game Wesley so being
one of the most precise players in chess
history uh if he gets a little bit of
wiggle room he may try to even outclass
his younger opponent experience does pay
off and these two players they don't
have an extensive history against one
another they played at the Olympiad back
in Chennai that game was a draw it was
great preparation by Wesley he did Air
at some point and then prognanda had the
upper hand but didn't maximize the
potential of his position in an end game
Wesley was able to make that draw and
Wesley he needs to win this game if he
has any chance at first place if he wins
no dear Beck loses and Geary does not
win then Wesley will find himself at
minimum in a tie for first place
actually it's maximum he has a full
point behind nerdy records ataro so he
needs all of those results to go his way
and he is undefeated he has performed
well he's gained ready points but he
just has drawn a few too many games if
he's hoping to secure first place
and I think that last bullet point is
actually quite important you mentioned
yesterday that Wesley isn't always
willing uh to take tremendous risks when
he needs to win a game and I think he
basically decided that listen my chances
to win this tournament let's be real are
vanishingly small all of the cards have
to fall a certain way and they are very
unlikely to all fall in that way and so
each player chooses the amount of risk
that they're comfortable with Wesley did
play an incredibly sharp and
enterprising variation that he had
obviously studied carefully what he
would be unwilling to do is you know
play D4 A6 or play something just to
tell chess fans that he unbalanced the
position and played for a win Prague is
more than capable of punishing an
unsound opening so I think Wesley's
Choice was entirely reasonable I think
he was probably aware that there is a
response to this opening that forces the
game into an end game but if a 2700
player is well prepared armed to the
teeth and is determined to make a draw
as my friend Sam shankland would always
say you really can only do so much to
stop them
it's true if Prague wants to draw what
are you going to do about it you're
Wesley so you're a fantastic player but
you have the second move and you have to
sort of React to what prognada is
bringing to the table and Prague he did
draw Magnus yesterday that was a heroic
defensive effort on his part he was able
to withstand the pressure for so many
hours and make the draw so let's head
away from this game we do expect the
action to continue here but it seems to
be fizzling out somewhat and in the top
left we have our leader your back
abdusitarov he has traded the Queens off
the board and there's pressure down the
H file in that game I'm looking as well
to the bottom right of our scene screen
Vincent Heimer gukesh that board is
opening up the top right of course is
Anish giri against Richard report and I
think that Anish is going to be focusing
on his game he needs to win but he's
also looking on over to the top left and
saying hey nobody back come on don't do
it don't do this to me give me a chance
if I win please don't win your your game
so I can play for first place
and I think Anish Gary must be
encouraged by the clock situation on uh
Notre backup zeusitoro's board perhaps
we can take a a closer look at that end
game of course we have magnus's game on
the lower left which we want to update
you on as well but I really think that
we need to take stock of what has
happened in the tournament leaders game
because the Queens have come off the
board the pawn on H5 is hanging and I
think that could be a point of confusion
for a lot of people why can't another
backup disturb just snag the pawn on H5
what does Jordan have up his sleeve well
I don't know for a fact Robert but I can
make an educated guess I think that in
this position if we could bring up an
analysis board first of all I'll point
out that Knight takes C6 does not win a
piece because black can of course first
capture on E3 and then take back on C6
this is out of the question white will
have to completely ruin his Pawn
structure if white plays G takes H5 or
Rook takes H5 I think black's response
is similar I think Jordan in this case
is going to trade Rooks and simply bring
his Knight out to F6 and if white
develops the bishop to E2 then there is
sort of a quiet move that the engine was
suggesting Rook a to C8 the more human
move the move that appealed to me is B5
B4 dislodging the knight from its
defense of the E4 pawn and this would
not be a fair trade for white if Jordan
can stag this very important Pawn in E4
but the story is not as simple as it
appears white can drive the Knight over
to A4 suddenly hitting the bishop black
has to spend a Tempo moving it back and
now white can use this Tempo to try to
secure the E4 Pawn but Robert with your
knight sitting on the rim with a lot of
pressure against White's Central peace
construction I think Yoda wreck might be
your Rebecca
I think Jordan might be aiming precisely
for a position like this where there's
just a lot of practical pressure even if
objectively your position yeah might be
slightly worse and just to add one more
uh move to this line if white reinforces
the pawn E4 with F3 that Bishop on E2 no
longer in contact with the H5 Pawn so
that would be upon the blackened capture
and the work on the aid is protected so
Rook H1 Rook h8 that's not a threat not
to mention the Knight on D4 is loose so
this is great opening preparation by
Jordan Von Forest no deer Rebecca Bruce
Atari he's reacting well but it could be
sharp despite the absence of queens that
doesn't mean that we're just in a
drawish position there's plenty of life
left both sides have all four minor
pieces both Rooks are on the board for
each side so this does seem like a
battle and for dear back he has to think
do I want to you know keep my options
open and play for a win or will he be
satisfied with the draw I do think a
draw is satisfactory for him he's not
afraid of a blitz playoff or rapid
playoff I should say if it gets to that
point against nishikiri um a niche super
strong but each first has to beat
Richard support and that is a tall order
but for now I think we are going to let
the players focus on their games we are
going to step aside for just a few
moments and when we return the action
continues here in the final round of the
2023 Tata steel Chess Masters
looking for a new way to learn chess
meet Dr Wolf the ideal chess coach and
companion
play against Dr Wolf as he explains
everything step by step points out
strategic ideas and alerts you to your
mistakes
train with him and go over your past
mistakes until you master them
choose from over 35 lessons created for
all skill levels no matter your level
everyone could use a coach download
Learn chess with Dr Wolf for Android or
iOS devices today
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
ER Gracie having a tough event in
Vikings a and today he plays Magnus
Carlson the last round for him is the
most challenging round at least on paper
Magnus Carlsen being the world champion
in classical rapid and Blitz with Arjun
Eric icy such a strong player such a
bright future he'll be back in Vikings a
and he wants to end his tournament with
his biggest success because so far it's
been four losses for him and the rest of
his games have been drawn so if he can
beat the world champion that would be an
awesome conclusion
it would indeed and I really think our
generic icy he's embracing it I think he
appreciates the chance to perhaps not
turn his tournament around even with a
win in this game he will lose a good
deal of raiding you will finish with uh
a serious minus score but what a mood
improver that would be to defeat the
world champion in the last game and dash
his off chances for first place Arjun
aragaisi is not shying away from The
Challenge they have a very complex
position on the board it's a sort of
King's Indian type of structure where
white has just contributed to a central
control by pushing the pawn up to E4 but
the main difference Robert is that
fiancarriage Bishop on B7 and the King's
Indian that Bishop usually remains on
the C8 H3 diagonal I'm not sure exactly
who the queen side structure favors but
I can tell you that there are a lot of
similarities structure wise to the
king's Indian in terms of the king side
situation and now in terms of the
placement of the bishop which Magnus
says moved back to C8 you would think
that this is a loss of a couple Tempe
because it does feel like King's Indian
where Blackwood B6 Bishop B7 then back
to C8 but when white played the move E4
he is allowing for tension between pawns
to be created so when that F7 Pawn comes
up to F5 suddenly we're gonna see some
trades being offered and it's the
question becomes where is that Knight on
F6 going is it going back to E8 to allow
for Pawn to F5 will it hop forward to G4
will it go back to D7 I don't really
think D7 is the movie you want to play
because you just put your Bishop back on
C8 he could have played Knight f27 right
away if you were going to go for that so
this is going to be a slow maneuvering
game Donya it's all about playing F5 and
white does not have F4 that would be a
huge mistake because that Bishop on G7
would be opened up whereas that pawn on
D5 for white means that even if black
plays F5 the bishop rg2 doesn't have
full scope of the diagonal so white
cannot control that pawn break why
typically place on the queen side maybe
A3 maybe B4 maybe trying to advance
those pawns on that flank but it's going
to be a bit of a long story for both
sides as they jockey for position on
opposite sides of the board
and that's exactly what we're going to
get I could talk about this type of
physician for ages I'm very passionate
about King's Indian structures but I
will limit myself to just a couple of
brief remarks I co-signed your point
entirely about White's main plan in fact
I think that is White's only plan I
could bet a horse and a cow that Arjun
is going to play Rook to be won in this
position and as cumbersome as it is
white needs to prepare before this
Knight has to be pushed off of C5 if
white is to generate serious play on The
Queen side and just as I say that it
does appear to me that Arjun has made a
move
and it's not Rook to P1 I can't quite
say what it is it is Knight C2 to A3 may
I be forgiven we're not predicting this
move I suppose Arjun is going to be five
eventually he kicks the can down the
road he's gonna have to prepare B4 but
one way or the other white needs to whip
up serious play on The Queen side if he
wants to counterbalance uh what maybe
the rather nasty effect of the pawn
advance to F5 I think Magnus Carlson's
path is clear he's gonna drop the Knight
back to E8 most likely and shove that
pawn down as far as its legs will carry
it perhaps all the way to F3 where it
will hit the bishop on G2 and put it out
of commission plan is very clear for
Magnus Carlsen and something to that has
clear to me excuse me is that the game
between 500 caruana and dingley ren uh
we're getting the sense we are being
informed that uh this game that could
end in a repetition because dingley
Ren's last moves or Knight F3 to H4 and
and back and black went Nike seven 7 and
then back to C6 so just go back a couple
moves here Donya yeah so we can we can
show trade
uh his thing
yep
and then the knights are repeating oh
here the game's gonna be a joke you can
see it they're just repeating moves here
it's the end of a long tournament and a
draw will undoubtedly be agreed upon
they are done Fabiano caruana obviously
has had the better tournament ding Loren
he wants to get rid of this event he
wants to get on a plane fly back home
and start preparing for a world champion
and put this tournament out of his mind
I don't think you can blame him even for
a second for accepting this draw he
wants to cut the bleeding avoid a loss
in the final round he's gonna lose a ton
of rating he's gonna have a lot of
analyzing to do and a lot of problems to
diagnose and a lot of confidence that
he's gonna have to build back up as he
goes into the most important trial of
his life in just a couple of months well
if there's anybody who understands that
it's fabulous because when you're
playing a world championship match as
carwana did back in 2018 that where is
where your attention is fully focused on
so with that result with the Half Point
given to each player Fabiano caruana
finishes with 7 out of 13. a dingley
wren did not have a great Tournament of
course his standards are to be amongst
the top players he fits with 5 five and
a half out of 13 a disappointing
performance for him he won just a single
game and lost three along the way but
now our focus is going to be on these
top boards we have no deerback Abdus
atar from the top left the tension
between the H and G pawns is still there
but on the top right looking at each
Gary's game against Richard report a
niche is the first to jump forward the
Knight heading into D5 let's zoom into
that game because I feel like Anish is
making some progress
I'm very glad you made that call because
I am itching to share a cool little
anecdote about the position that we have
in front of us so Knight C3 to D5 is
actually the first new move you might
assume that this position that comes
already from a rare line of the Sicilian
has never occurred not true the position
after Rook C8 has occurred once it was
in a game between two very strong Grand
Masters Alexander motolov and Vladimir
putkin who by the way is one of Yana Pam
nashi's second Robert guess where that
tournament was played all the way back
in 2012 of all the places okay so
continent Sisk is gonna be high up on my
list just because so many chess
tournaments randomly were there not that
the population of this place might be
similar to that of hansimon says it's a
small town
um it's known for its chess
is it if I can say yes it is
a challenger section in 2012 and 95 is
the deviating move that is technically
the novelty Alexander matildoff he
dropped his Bishop back to B3 and that
actually allowed Vladimir putkin to
carry out a very pretty maneuver fully
neutralizing White's Edge he played the
immediate F5 I pointed out that this
move is unlikely as long as the bishop
sits on C6 not so here because all of a
sudden black can grab this Knight on C3
and if you nonchalantly take back with
the Queen Bishop takes G2 that's a
discovery and that's a lost Rook on F1
White had to accept the ruining of his
Queen Side Pawn structure the queen came
out to G5 threatening Checkmate forcing
yet another major weakness on the king
side and with all of these weaknesses
induced black can accept uh his own
share of weakness the G file is also
opened this position is approximately
equal according to the engine and the
game ended in a draw I just think it's
so cool that there is only one game in
the database and of all the places it
happened specifically here in tata steel
what a tournament what a tradition and
what a crazy story love that inclusion
to show everybody that this position it
had happened before and in Vikings day
but in this game the Knight hops forward
to D5 F5 no longer as good of an option
because if you play F5 then white simply
takes on F5 and there's no more Bishop
takes Knight on C3 that Knight is gone
and you do not want to allow white to
just make progress on the king side and
something that's extremely important
because I think people in the audience
are often told Bishops have opposite
color means the game is Just equal end
games are drawn we are so far away from
an end game so if black were to take on
D5 with his Bishop to get rid of that
really pesky Knight the white Bishop
takes back on D5 and Look whose Bishop
is better the one on D5 hitting both the
B7 part just to just put the position on
the board for a second so we can really
show what it's like the F7 and B7 pawns
are targets the bishop on G7 it stares
into its own pawn and so white is
clearly better in such a position a rook
lift is in the future of maybe F4
followed by F5 for white just uh
slamming that pawn forward to shut in
that Bishop this would be a great
position with excellent winning chances
for nishikiri and the file final nail in
the coffin really uh is that black can
try to play F5 but there's an additional
tactic that black has to keep tabs on
and that's the idea of taking twice on
G6 the bishop on D5 you mentioned pins
the F7 Pawn so even if like does squeeze
through F5 his entire King side is at
risk of being pulverized by White's
bishop and white screen I think what we
are getting at here as we dial it back
to the lifeboard is that not only is
Bishop takes D5 on wise black I think
has to prepare F5 at all costs and he
has to do it ASAP because white has
several easy ways that he can improve
his position and take the sting out of
the F pawns Advance the move that comes
to mind is C3 creating a punching you
could bring the Rook to D1 White's play
is easy I think it's likely that Richard
drops this bishop back to D7 and
essentially pre-moves F5 even if it
means sacrificing D6 he needs to find a
way to open up the G7 Bishop because
that is essentially the entire point of
playing this line the longer the bishop
is hammed in by its own Pawn the higher
the likelihood that Anish giri is able
to tighten the screws in the center and
ultimately win the D6 pawn and crash
through
and the problem for black in some of
these positions is like even if you get
F5 which might not be easy because white
can Retreat the Knight to E3 stopping
you from playing F5 and hitting the D6
Pawn at the same time I was going to say
that the bishop for white can establish
herself on D5 that is an outpost Square
we typically put our Knights on outpost
squares but here the bishop on D5 is
just so frustrating for black to do with
hitting the B7 Pawn nicely centralized
protecting the E4 pawns the queen is
free to run hitting F7 so if the queen
slides over to B3 you could put
increased pressure over there and white
has some simple options Rook a to D1 uh
just putting your pieces in the center
maybe bring that Knight to C4 at some
moment and the D6 Pawn does remain a
weakness it's an eyesore and it's not
going anywhere
no that's a great insight and I think
Anisha has made such an astute opening
Choice he took his time and he chose a
line that's easy to play that's unlikely
to be extensively analyzed by Richard
report because it's relatively
positional and I can guarantee you that
report probably spent the Lion's Share
of his time preparing for scenarios in
which White Castles Queen side because
you have to know those positions this is
a situation in which White's game is
practically much easier and even though
the engine does not assign an extensive
Edge to White I would ignore that
entirely and I would argue uh vehemently
that the difficulty is squarely in
Black's Court Richard report is the one
who has to play accurately for the next
couple of moves and I think the first
step toward neutralizing White's
positional Advantage is still to try to
get F5 in I'm voting for Bishop D7 but
Hungarian Grandmaster you can see his
head in his hands he understands the
gravity of this situation and the
importance of this game and he is not
ready just just to hand the win over to
anishkiri
no he is not but Anish has a good start
to this game and you need to be able to
keep it going you don't want to see an
end game oh that is just pretty level
where maybe you're slightly better none
of that forcing stuff so I believe that
for the time being it'll be easier for a
niche to find ideas and moves and that
should give him good winning chances not
that his position is that much better
right now I just like the direction this
game is heading and so why don't we zoom
out for a second from this game look at
our other games in progress because no
game is more important than no dearbeck
Abdul sitarov against Jordan Forest and
we see a similar Dynamic to where we
left it the players are thinking trying
to work through the complications and as
soon as I say they're thinking it looks
like Jordan
G6 you just that's the top left of our
screens there is protecting his Pawn on
H5 but while we have a moment while the
players are thinking there uh Donna
which of our other games do you want to
dive into briefly
well I'll just point out that Prague
Wesley has settled down as we were
discussing the light squirt Bishop comes
out to D3 I think things are going to
continue calming down on that board as
both sides essentially get their pieces
out especially black Wesley's got to get
that other Rook out of h8 and prepare
for what could be a long grinded out end
game we have a fascinating battle
between Vincent kymer and gukesh now I
appreciate the importance of keeping
tabs on the games that impact the final
Tournament standings but I really think
that that position merits a closer look
if only very briefly let's go right to
that because I think the last move that
Google has played in the bottom right uh
Queen sliding from d8 to C8 and that
move allows white to shatter Black's
kingside Pawn structure there's a knight
in E4 a bishop on G5 there was a maximum
tension against this Knight and F6 and
that still exists so I think that if I'm
looking at this correctly white can lead
with say Bishop takes F6 it doesn't
really matter the move order I don't
imagine but after Bishop takes Knight
Knight Knight takes back Knight takes F6
we're gonna get a position where Black's
King side is just going to be open it's
exposed and after this I think white can
establish a bishop on e4 then move the
queen out the way and this looks
terrible for Blackie at the eval bar
saying huh not a big deal
well I guess the email bar must be
banking on the fact that black has the
bishop pair and uh black also has the G
file there is the typical idea of King
h8 followed by Rook G and that Queen on
C8 it appears very awkward but one
redeeming factor is that it will be
making contact with the H3 Pawn upon
that it can capture in the event of The
Rook on G8 pinning the G2 Pawn Vincent
kymer has made a decision he has
followed the sage advice of Robert
hessen he has captured the Knight on F6
can you blame him for not being able to
resist the temptation to ruin Black's
kingside pawns which is even more
tempting by the fact made even more
tempting by the fact that Black's King
sits on G8 and can definitely be
attacked by some of White's minor pieces
once the queen moves out of D1 there is
also the idea of swinging the Knight
around to F5
this looks really bad for black I'm not
sure at all how the Evo bar is
suggesting that black isn't not too
terrible of shape but I mean it just
looks like a clear Plus for white I
think from a practical perspective If
This Were A Blitz game white would win
this position a large percentage of the
time but it's classical chess uh gukesh
has plenty of time to evaluate the
position uh Vincent kymer has played
more quickly than his opponent and
Vincent would like nothing more than to
get this Victory because he's had his
opportunities to score wins he has zero
wins to this point he has three losses
and all the rest of his games have been
draws if he could end with a win his
tournament won't feel that bad after all
five and a half out of 13 in your maiden
tons of steel Masters is a good result
and he wouldn't even lose many rating
points so this is a big opportunity for
Vincent kymer
we expect so much from these players we
take it for granted that they
demonstrate Poise resilience
cold-bloodedness let's take a step back
and just assert the fact that for many
of them from Vince this is uh not only
their first or one of their first Super
tournaments but it's perhaps the first
13 round event that they've ever played
it's the first time that they faced a
lot of these super Grand Masters there
are some Growing Pains there will be a
couple of rough experiences but they're
going to come back home and you know
Vincent timer in his case he's going to
analyze each and every game very
carefully with Peter lecko he's going to
analyze those end games exhaustively
he's going to figure out what went wrong
and he's going to come back stronger
that is called Improvement and that is a
process that is normal it's part of
every player's journey and our
expectations they are Sky High because
we're spoiled we're so used to
Excellence from these young players our
generic icy has been writing an endless
streak of good tournaments but
eventually each of those streaks is
going to come to an end and really
players their Verve their grit it's
defined not by how they act when they're
playing well but how they react after a
tournament like this
well said and for Vincent kymer I think
he does have the upper hand right now uh
still a position that gukesh is going to
be able to play and hear some clear
ideas the bishop will draw the be driven
back to G6 couldn't even say it because
the pawn structure looks so bad over
there but Bishop G6 uh the queen would
get off the back rank the Rooks will be
connected and I think we may see some
major pieces swapped on the e-file so I
do think that while good the Aesthetics
are not there he does have a clear plan
that he can execute so why don't we uh
hop away from this one Vincent kymer
does have a chance in this game I think
his many fans from Germany will be
rooting for him to get his first turn uh
Victory or victory in the tournament I
should say and well let's go back to the
nerdy back I'm just tariff game against
Jordan Von Forest because in that one we
last saw Jordan play the move G6 Abdul
sitarov has been thinking
and well the position
what do you make of it down here because
H5 is defended for now that's the good
news uh but what's what are the actual
plans for each side
well I feel like the the fulcrum of
tension has shifted from the King side
uh where it lays squarely after white
played G4 black has managed to patch
things up and uh that last move G6 it
secures uh the pawn on H5 even when that
pawn is hanging as we were discussing it
was not very wise for Notre back to rush
into the pawn capture now I think the
tension lies in the center and the
question is who benefits from this
tension between these two sets of minor
pieces the bishop and the knight uh for
black and of course there are
counterparts on E3 and D4 I will point
out concretely that black isn't really
threatening the move E5 it may seem like
he is but the Knight can still jump into
F5 just because that score is defended
doesn't mean anything because the bishop
on C5 is undefended as a result so the
point of G6 isn't to set a superficial
tactical trap it is to solidify the king
side my question to Jordan would be
first of all what is he planning if
Notre back just plays a neutral move
such as Bishop to E too or King to B1 or
maybe A3 to to prevent the pesky idea of
before what is your invent Force
follow-up going to be if norterbeck can
figure that out then perhaps he can find
a more load-bearing move in this
position maybe the immediate Knight F5
deserves considerations you called it
the dark squares you mentioned this as
early as move 4 they're still weak and
if the dark squared Bishops are gotten
off the board he might pay the
positional price well I just wanted you
just put that move on the board night to
F5 because that looks like it's a crazy
move you're giving away your knight but
if the pawn takes the Knight then the
bishop takes the bishop on C5 and the
dark squares are completely under
White's control you have the bishop pair
it's an open position evaluation is
Justified it is a great position for
white so Knight F5 is available and I
think it's a good move because if you
played Bishop E2 first instead of Knight
to F5 and as you're showing the Knight
would capture the bishop backup E3 black
plays D6 and now you don't have Knight
F5 anymore and if you make a careless
move like Pawn to A3
now Blacklist E5 oh and you're losing a
piece because Knight F5 I just take you
and the bishop on C5 is defended by the
pawn so that's very important so I think
black's move actually is D6 and that
creates some tactical problems for white
to solve so that's why I like to move
Knight F5 initially as you were
indicating because instead of Bishop to
E2 you start with Knight F5 and then
that d-pawn that's at the end of a line
with a rook staring down at it I feel
like black could be in some danger here
as this game progresses
and Knight F5 is Good from a tournament
standing uh perspective as well white
essentially forces the Bishops off the
board and I just do I mean I'm I'm
speaking too soon I'm jumping the gun
here I get it but I really don't see
notabeck losing an end game like this
given his form of the tournament and I'm
not trying to jinx him obviously there's
plenty of fight left but he has no
weaknesses he's got pressure on H5 he's
got a clear set of follow-up moves so
you can develop his Bishop he's got
plenty of ways to improve his position
and he can also go for more you can play
a move like A4 in order to carve out a
direct Pathway to that juicy outpost on
D6 the Knight would like nothing more
than to jump into C4 and then move its
way to D6 and that pawn on B5 it always
sticks out like a sore thumb in Sicilian
positions it's a double-edged sword it's
a strength with Queens on the board but
it can be a serious liability with the
Queen's swap so A4 the bishop
development to E2 all of that uh I feel
like the arrows are pointing one way and
that's in the direction of knights F5
I I think it simplifies the position in
order to avoid tactics and we know what
nordirback Abdus needs to win this
tournament if he wins this game he wins
first place that's it the tournament is
done in the sense that we know who the
champion will be but if he draws the
game then Anish giri needs to win to
force a tie break so that puts the
burden squarely underneath curious
shoulders and I think that's what no
direct would like because if he loses
this game if it gets sharp and he goes
wrong somewhere then that gives Magnus
Carlson Wesley so a chance to tie him
and it would give Anish gear a chance to
LeapFrog him altogether so I think no
dear back he wants to make sure this
heads towards a position with two
results I think Knight F5 accomplishes
that either Jordan makes a draw if he
plays very well or if notary back can
out clasp him down the stretch it could
be a win and thus another tournament
belt for a learning record of and the
importance of not making decisions based
on someone else's game uh is I think
well illustrated by a case study the
London candidates tournament in 2013 uh
which I was watching live on vacation uh
from Philadelphia before playing a
tournament of my own going to the final
round Magnus Carlson and Vladimir
kramnik both stood tied for first place
with eight and a half but as far as I
remember Magnus Carlson had the better
tie breaks so Vladimir kramnik decided
on a radical approach in his game
against Vasily vonchuk he decided to
play a pierce which he had almost never
played in his chess career to try to
guarantee winning chances Magnus Carlson
had the white pieces against Peter
Fiddler a game that kramnik assumed
Magnus would not lose in a million years
Fiddler had been doing well that
tournament but it's Magnus he's playing
white and Magnus Carlson knows how to
draw on demand guess what happens as a
result Peter svidler wipes Magnus
Carlson off the board with the black
pieces but because kramnik played
appearance he himself was wiped off the
board in one-sided fashion and as a
consequence Magnus Carlson maintained
his lead in the event had Vladimir
kramnik played one of his trusty opening
weapons such as the Berlin or even some
variations of the Sicilian he would have
gotten himself a much better chance at
first place and thereby a qualification
to the world championship title so I
think Notre back he's telling himself
listen I'm going to play this game the
same way that I've played every game
this tournament and I'm going to limit
my glances at uh Anish Gary's own Affair
I'm going to let the cards fall as they
may I'm going to focus on what I can
control
yeah what he can control is the move
that he bakes and well he just took
control over the dark squares because he
made the move Knight to F5 and very
quickly you already took on E2 that was
a forcing sequence so uh that there was
no choice there for Jordan and well
you're saying that everybody actually
can't focus on anything else he needs to
just look at the moves the position in
front of him and that makes perfect
sense in fact the media caught up with
yesterday to ask him about his thoughts
about how he can keep his emotions in
check
nothing special I just want to play a
good chess
uh I think it's my character is
is calm and yeah I don't
express my emotions uh so yeah it's it's
known that I am very calm and
without emotions
I really like the interview because he
says I don't have emotions you know
that's my board but a huge smile on his
face and he is such a nice and humble
person I told this story earlier in one
of the previous rounds that after the
Olympiad gold medal the Uzbek team was
the airport and many other uh chess
teams were taking similar flights and
they took photos with everybody
sometimes people after such a
performance they're just I just want to
be left alone but Abdul sitar of the
entire Uzbek team they were taking
photos they were letting people look at
the trophy uh they were so proud to have
won that event for the country of
Uzbekistan and I got to catch up with
literally break off to the side and
congratulate him on his many successes
and he's incredibly humble he was just
appreciative that he was there who he's
able to play he was thankful for all the
online events that helped sharpen him as
a player he's honed his skills online
he's been known for many years as a
great Blitz and Rapid player and now
he's showing the world that he is not a
player to be trifled with In classical
he is into the top 20 if he wins today's
game I believe he goes into the top 15
and I think he's there to stay
and he's showing us that alireza farusia
as I said earlier isn't the only one
that we should be putting on our radar
we should be watching notable he's so
exciting to watch not only because of
his tournament performances but also
because of his playing style he's so
versatile he can essentially play any
opening he's demonstrated phenomenal
opening preparation well beyond his
years case in point look at the last two
games look at how he held Anish giri and
Wesley so in a row with the black beast
is something that you know even for
Magnus Carlson would be a tall task and
Notre Beck he does it in style he
doesn't even bat an eye and he's left
himself with plenty in the tank I think
to finish off the tournament in style
Knight F5 has been played he is sitting
very pretty with I think a slight
advantage in the end game a slight but
stable Advantage but more importantly
his position is solid as a rock this is
exactly what he wanted out of the
opening
no complaints whatsoever the only one
complaining likely is Jordan Von Forest
he was the one who chose H5 an early
Pawn push as his opening weapon but now
that we're in this position it feels
like white has firm control because you
can't touch the H5 Pawn The Rook on H1
stares through it at The Rook on h8 so
you can't trade over there and if you
try to bring your knight out to F6 as
soon as you make that move white
immediately will push the pawn to G5
releasing some of the tension on the H
file but gaining important space the F3
Pawn will go up to F4 the E4 Pawn will
likely go up to E5 and those dark
squares will be completely under White's
control
now that's a great point you know
sometimes you have to transform the
nature of your advantage as tempting as
it is to keep the pressure on H5 you
have to know when to shift uh the nature
of your advantage to to something else
in the case of that line uh to a firm
control over the D6 and F6 squares in
the event of h5h4 which I think is very
unlikely white could accentuate the
pressure with G3 that is actually one of
the benefits of having doubled pawns you
can use them kind of like spikes no
matter how far the H Pawn goes there's
always going to be a G3 Pawn to meet it
at the top so H4 is not possible Knight
F6 is dubious and Forest has a very
unenviable defensive task ahead of him
yeah so I think he should refrain for
the moment from bringing his night out
uh I think he can Castle Queen side but
this is a position without queens of the
board so King E7 is more likely just
because those dark squares are what we
keep complaining about in Black's
position uh they are vulnerable so King
E7 at least at least takes care of some
of them and you have some time it sounds
like white is threatened to win material
but one thing that I do want to point
out that if and when white takes on H5
with the pawn black will take back with
the Rook you do not want a panel on the
H file to continue and they often say
the threat is strong in the execution
here the tension plays to White's favor
so white will not be taking on H5 unless
it is concretely a good decision
and to piggyback off of that point
another reason you don't want to rush
GTX H5 optically the king side situation
may seem to favor white that pawn on H5
is isolated but first of all it's very
very hard to get to it can be safely
defended by a knight on F6 and should
the G6 spawn move out to H5 black will
have the G file for his disposal and
later down the line black might get a
rook on G8 and actually put serious
pressure on that second Pawn which is
presumably still going to sit on G2
we're talking about things that could
happen seven even 10 moves around but
that's exactly what you have to do in an
end game like this there is some
calculation to be done concrete
decisions to be made but there's a lot
of structural changes that could take
place and you have to have in your mind
a very clear road map for what you want
and what you don't want when it comes to
transformations of Pawn structure and
different types of Peace placements
for sure and so capturing on H5 if it
were white CERN likely not going to be
played do think that Jordan should bring
his King up to E7 I just believe that
Cass and queen side there's no real
benefit of bringing your king to C8 it's
not going to be attacked on E7 so keep
it in the center of the board and then
decide where to develop your pieces but
I think we should we can zoom out from
this one for a moment here just because
Jordan front Forest is on the clock and
maybe that gives us time to check in on
one of the games we haven't really
looked at and that would be the one
between levonne aronian and Parham
maxirlou
I am game for that especially because we
have a rich nidorf and that is one of
the most fun openings to look at Parham
aksulu has shown a predilection for the
night or Sicilian which she has
fearlessly essayed several times this
tournament lebronian has opted for a
relatively quiet line uh why do I how do
I know that well he has castled kingside
and in the sharpest lines of the night
off Bishop G5 some lines of the English
attack White Castles Queen side and we
get our patented attacks on opposite
sides here Lavon is aiming for a
positional Advantage he has established
control over the D5 square and in many
night of positions that is exactly what
the battle revolves around can white
ultimately stick a knight on D5 and
support it with enough pieces black on
the other hand has positioned his Rook
on C6 is Queen on C8 he's putting
pressure on the Knight on C3 and you
know anybody worth any night or flare
worth their salt knows that an exchange
sacrifice on C3 is one of the most
typical and sometimes one of the most
positionally powerful ideas available to
Black I love it I would play Rook TC3
right now and I know this isn't a rapid
time virtual game and Parham Maxwell
excels in that format but Rook takes C3
looks very powerful and the reason why
is that Knight on C3 is the so stable it
is keeping White's position together
it's also preventing the move D6 to D5
and if you're in the night orb you can
play D6 to D5 you're very happy so I
think you could almost force it through
after Rook takes Knight on C3 if we can
bring up an analysis board black is
going to give up some material for the
time being and then by Knight H4 not
even take this Pawn on C3 which can be
captured but let's go Knight H4 and
Bishop takes H3 suddenly if the bishop
moves away from F3 you want to keep your
Bishop of course and you go to E2 then
black strikes very quickly with D5 and
the position opens up so The Rook on D2
The Rook on A1 there's an extra one of
those but black has an extra Knight
compared to that rook and the position
is about to be blue alone open and that
will be good for the minor pieces and
the side that's trying to attack
this line so nicely illustrates one of
the most appealing factors about playing
the night Earth and that is how Black's
position can go from seemingly passive
to unbelievably active in the span of
like three or four moves it uncoils like
an angry snake as black strikes on all
three sides of the board first taking on
C3 then striking in the king side and
capping it off with a Central Pawn
strike this is the type of position
where I would take the Eva bar and throw
it into a trash can on the opposite side
of the world because I would take black
any day here we could continue this line
he takes D5 Knight takes D5 the C3 Pawn
is hanging the bishop is under pressure
and there we see it the evil bar
immediately drops apparently white has
to find a move in this position that
keeps the tension how hard is it to play
F2 F3 making even more weaknesses than
you already have on the king side and
giving up the C3 Pawn with tempo as the
bishop is hanging so Rook takes C3 I
think would be a very wise call and it
would be very much congruent with Parham
style he has shown just just a
willingness to fight for the win in
every game he's taking a long long think
here Lavon is up 35 minutes or so at
this point Parham has sunk so much time
into this move Robert that it would be a
real shame if he didn't take on C3 and
there is something struck about this
though if you're playing your own game
and you've spent a lot of time that
doesn't mean you have to make the move
and actually parm did bring his Knight
to H4 that doesn't take Rook takes E3
out of the equation but he started with
Knight H4 I believe he will sacrifice
after the bishop retreats to E2 but a
story for everybody is I was playing
John fedorowitz the legendary American
Grandmaster many years ago at this point
and I had invested so much time and I
calculated and calculated it's been
about 45 minutes or an hour I don't
remember the exact amount at this point
but I was like it doesn't work I don't
think it works but I spent so much time
I should do it and I played a sacrifice
I lost the game and afterwards John's
like why would you do that I'm like well
I spent so much time calculating you and
I figured I have to and he goes what are
you talking about this is chess it's an
objective game like you make the best
move even if you spent 45 minutes
considering an option that doesn't pan
out so that was a lesson learned I was a
teenager at the time and it is very
helpful that even if you are trying to
make something work if you're spending
all this time it doesn't mean you have
to do it you still have freedom of
choice there and so for Parham he is
considering for takes C3 I think it is
objectively a good decision and that's
why he should make that move
I think you bring up a great point that
is a very instructive story and you're
absolutely right each player's
Allegiance especially at the very
highest level should be to the objective
Truth The Players should try to look for
the move that gives them the most
practical and of course objective
chances uh but there's a psychological
and emotional component to this and
sometimes even the best players in the
world they fall victim to this idea that
if you've spent 30 40 minutes
calculating a sacrifice well you really
really want to make it work and
sometimes you start looking at the board
through Rose Colored Glasses but in this
case I think Rook takes C3 as you've
been saying is actually Justified Arham
has set it up by kicking the bishop off
of F3 and I thought he was about to make
a move he's going to take a little bit
longer now he's got Alternatives he can
try to prepare D5 by shifting his Rook
to d8 he can probably just bring his
Knight back to G6 his position remains
very solid but I for one just wouldn't
be able to resist the temptation
it looks very strong for him and I think
what you mentioned is the big point it's
also parham's style he doesn't like to
sit and be passive even if if there are
two options and both objectively have
the same evaluation he is going to
choose the active one they sacrifice and
it could come back to bite him in some
games or in some positions but I do
think it's a good decision right now
Rook takes C3 and pawn to D5 and the
action just gets underway uh there will
be tension in the position I just think
it's a little bit more fun to play from
the black side for the time being but
we'll leave Parham to it if and when he
does sacrifice on C3 we'll make note of
it but if we return to our view where we
can see all of the remaining games one
game in the books that was an early draw
between five and karwana and dingley ren
uh the game between Prague Nanda and
Wesley so second from the left on the
bottom not too many pieces remaining in
that one I think Wesley so is stable he
is likely to be able to hold a half
point but the top right that was a big
moment just now by Anish Geary so Donna
Anish needs to win this game to have a
chance at first place I like what he's
doing here this was a really good last
move by Gary
and it's a multi-purpose move because
you can look at that move from several
levels you can look at it from the
broadest level in order to win this game
he needs to introduce some sort of
imbalance and that's exactly what he is
doing he's trying to get a situation
where white has a monster Knight on D5
that faces off against a pathetic Bishop
on G7 Bishop rendered even more pathetic
by the fact that Gary has indeed
positioned his Pawn on C3 so even if
black does manage to push F5 that
doesn't necessarily give that Bishop
amazing Prospect Down The Long diagonal
the more concrete level is uh just that
Bishop B5 is a good move positionally it
doesn't forget the imbalances forget
what Anish Geary needs it's a good move
from an objective standpoint and Richard
report is not just going to cooperate by
trading that Bishop I'll just point out
Robert that if he had traded and taken
on e4 Anish would have helped himself to
Black's entire Queen side with uh Queen
takes B7 that would have actually
threatened a discover check on top of
everything else so Richard report says
you want to trade Bishops fine I'll let
you trade Bishops but you're going to
have to pay a very steep price namely
not only are you gonna have to move the
Knight away from D5 but you're going to
have to relinquish your control over
that Outpost potentially for the rest of
the game because that pawn on C6 is
going absolutely nowhere
you do not want to take on C6 right now
that would be a very bad decision for
Niche Curie because your knight
immediately gets kicked out of its
stronghold of the D5 square and then the
E4 Pawn does get targeted and really
it's quick pressure against White's
position so I think Anish is much more
likely to make a move like Rook A1 to D1
and you're not afraid of a bishops of
opposite color position we're talking
about that before just because uh in
many end games there are draws
Tendencies when there is an attack the
side with a safer King in this case the
white king will be safer because the F7
Pawn is tender the white king is tucked
at home on G1 and the black Bishop on G7
not a very good piece just to put that
on the board quickly if we can I I just
want to show that position Rook a to D1
yep and Bishop takes D5 just to really
drive this point home for our audience
Queen takes D5
that it's a position where white has a
bit more freedom if black can somehow uh
get I don't even realize that rook in
the eight was hanging by the way so when
Bishop 65 just to make a point but
rookie you've got Bishop C4 there
yeah so black somehow would come out on
top in that variation but yeah I was
gonna say in a position like this if
white can get that Bishop quickly back
to D5 it's a clear Advantage but black
will get F5 in we'll be able to get rid
of this Pawn on e4 and that's good news
it's a good start for black in his
defensive task
yeah there's no question that even here
Richard report is on the defensive but I
agree he would be well on his way uh if
he could get that move through F5 is I
not necessarily as effective as it was
earlier uh in the game under different
circumstances but it's still a movie you
would rather play uh than than not and
keep that Bishop hemmed in uh but the
sort of semi-unrelated point that I
wanted to make is that Bishops uh to C6
is a type of move that actually has a
name I learned this pretty recently it's
called a collinear move col followed by
the word linear collinear and a
collinear move refers uh to a move in a
situation where two pieces are staring
at each other let's say two Rooks
staring at each other down the file two
queens two Bishops uh the only time it's
not possible is in the case of two
nights that are staring at each other
collinear move refers to a move along
that same diagonal or file but that does
not capture the opponent's piece I don't
know if that makes sense so if Rooks are
on E1 and E8 and in exchange is possible
a collinear move would be any move along
the e-file other than capturing The Rook
on E1 and the reason that designation is
important is because collinear moves are
just very hard to spot just like
retreating Night Moves there are certain
chess moves that your brain just doesn't
necessarily go to because you're often
assuming that either you have to accept
the trade or you you have to move a
piece away you forget that there's a
third option you can move along that
very same diagonal but not trade and try
to trade on your own terms Bishop C6 is
a nice move and I think Richard report
is handling his defensive task quite
well at the outset here
I feel like you're a glossary you're
just giving me terms that I didn't know
but it's one of my favorite things in
chess and I've always said it in the way
that I love moves did I explain that
definition clearly by the way and if not
I just want to make sure right you're
good for us and people also can Google
co-linear move it's not that hard to
type into the search okay but what I
what I really like is I've always called
that you know a move that stops one
square short of expectation like so many
people would look at a bishop being
picked up and the bishop takes B5 was
going to be played but you stop on C6
instead those type of moves are hard to
spot because there's still tension
between the pieces they can capture one
another but I do like the bishop C6 it's
a great choice by which report and I
wouldn't be totally surprised based on
the analysis we just did if Anish
Retreats his Bishop back to C4 because
if the Knight is captured on D5 he would
much prefer to capture with his Bishop
back on D5 keeping some of his
initiative alive against the B7 and F7
Pawn so don't be surprised if and when
and each plays Bishop C4 he is not
playing for a draw he is just trying to
re-establish his control troll over the
D5 Square so this is an each carry
leaning in he's hovering over the board
and he understands that this is a big
moment
he does indeed the gravity of this game
is not lost on him you can just sense
the concentration the effort that he is
putting in in order to avoid yet another
tournament in which he is the runner-up
but obviously he's also not
catastrophizing this has been a very
successful event from him from every
perspective and being runner up inside
of Steel well that ain't too shabby
either the rating gain that's not too
bad so Anish Gary isn't going to take
any wild risks he is going to play
objectively he's going to try to
generate winning chances But ultimately
if someone like Richard report plays a
good game sometimes you need to tip your
hat agree to withdraw get a nice dinner
and celebrate your excellent performance
it's not All or Nothing Even though it
may seem that way when you just think of
a tournament in terms of whether you win
it or you don't there are other factors
at Play
that is definitely true and the T-shirt
wearing Richard report underneath his
Blazer I stepped away from the board so
we'll do the same but before we do I
just want to make mention of a special
event that is happening uh the
Collegiate chess League spring season
has begun this season is shaping out to
be incredibly exciting with the best
players in college chess and future
Global Superstars competing for an
impressive thirty thousand dollar prize
fund if you missed yesterday's action
make sure to catch the week three
matches on Saturday February 11th
twitch.tv Collegiate chess league has
all the coverage use the command CCL and
chat for more yeah Donnie and I will be
right back this is the Tata steel chest
Masters 2023 my return is more from
these games that will decide who the
tournament champion is
foreign
unreal no first try eight in a row nine
in a row baby let's go
let's go let's go
I gotta oh cool I got a little
achievement thing I honestly really
enjoyed that that was really cool
become a chess.com Community streamer at
go.chess.com start streaming
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
s
for this cozy coastal town the holiday
season isn't over
in fact the most wonderful time of the
year has really just begun there we go
the tournament leader holds Wesley so to
a drug he has impressed all of us
once again vikon Zay starts the new year
as the center of the chess Universe this
year as host of the 85th Tata steel
chess tournament
a magnet for the best players in the
game some recognize the Masters field of
2023 as its strongest in recent memory
of course it helps when eight time Tata
steel chess champion Magnus Carlson is
back Magnus is going baseball if Magnus
plays like this the rest of the way who
knows what can happen the world's number
one looks to further cement his legacy
in this event and the game's history
chasing Magnus will be amongst the best
in chess several have been crowned
Champion here before some have even
shocked the world in doing so
don't leave out those poised to capture
their first Tata title what a fight
Geary had to give it his all because he
was on the verge of losing and he
managed to survive
although winter Tata steel chess is also
known as the place new stars come to
bloom
Magnus one here is a teenager this
year's event has its fair share of young
players on the rise each hoping to
follow in Carlson's footsteps he
continues to lead this event and he is
just a teenager
the Dutch refer to Tata steel as The
Wimbledon of chess for 85 years in
running this tournament continues to be
steeped in Prestige and Legacy and does
so again in this welcoming Little Dutch
town by the sea
mind Brendan it's the 85th edition of
the Tata steel chess tournament and it
starts right now
foreign
Magnus Carlson away from the board right
now as he takes on Arjun aragaisi
entering the round Carlson a full point
behind the leader no direbec Abdus
atarov and in this game Arjuna garci
would like to keep the world champion as
far behind the leader as he entered
because Arjun putting up sturdy
resistance he has the white pieces and
for Magnus he needs to win this game
he's abusot to lose and also needs
anishagiri to not win his game in order
to tie for first
yeah he controls about two percent of
his Destiny but you know I could bet a
silver dollar that Magnus e isn't
thinking about the tournament Victory
right now he is thinking about
minimizing his rating loss ending strong
and even if he does not succeed in
claiming the top spot even if he makes
it to the top three that will still
constitute an absolutely incredible
comeback I feel like it was a decade ago
that we were talking about Magnus
Carlson sitting on minus one having one
of the most disastrous tournaments of
his life no this is this very same
taught us deal that was just this past
week
it's amazing what he's capable of when
he finds his form in this event it might
be a little bit too late because he lost
two games to Abdul sitarov and Geary no
surprise they're ahead of him in the
standings and yesterday the media caught
up with Magnus Carlson after he was
unable to convert his game against
pragananda and they asked him how he was
feeling coming into the final round
I don't know
um I feel like this was a bit of a um
bit of a back record to be honest so I
mean tournament's Victory is obviously
always click on
and you know
we'll see if I can sort of
uh you find some motivation to
to try it tomorrow but yeah for now
you know
yeah disappointing
you heard it from Magnus himself very
disappointed that he was unable to win
yesterday's game against prognananda and
he actually spoke about some of the
tactics that he overlooked under the
Knight takes F7 move in particular he
said that he had seen it and then he
forgot about it so when the moment came
for him to execute that move he just
forgot about that option and then
probably put up amazing defense and was
able to hold a draw so we have the world
champion on the screen in front of you
you see prognanda his opponent of
yesterday walking behind him and also
many people in the tournament Hall they
are watching their favorite players
compete for the top prizes and also just
playing entertaining games
and even just casting a glance at the
world champion no matter what kind of
tournament he is having is an
unforgettable experience for a lot of
these chess fans many of whom are
watching their first ever over the board
tournament many of whom drove one two or
even more hours out of their way
sometimes across several countries to
steal a glance at these incredible
players and partake in this magical
atmosphere of vike on Zay but you could
just sense the dejection the
disappointment in Magnus Carlson's tone
I would argue that the two draws that
he's made with the white pieces against
kukesh and yesterday against I might
actually eat at him even more than the
two losses that he suffered
consecutively those losses they were
fighting games there were a lot of
mistakes but Magnus definitely is
tipping his hat to his Victors
anishikiri and norbreck of do satorov
both of whomplates honestly probably the
best games of their lives against Magnus
Carlson he just wasn't very lucky in
terms of the form that is his opponents
were in but those two draws were games
that he was fully expecting to and we
are accustomed to him winning games in
those types of situations but once again
you've got a tip your hat to his
opponents yesterday prognananda he was
so impressive in the way that he
maintained his composure made the world
champions task as difficult as possible
and the chess Gods decided to reward him
well people are accustomed to losing to
Magnus Carlson because when you play a
number of games against him he tends to
score some victories but one player who
is not at all used to losing to Magnus
Carlson is Arjun aragaisy this is their
first meeting in classical chess so
imagine he gets his first over-the-board
experience with the longest time patrols
taking on Magnus for hours that's going
to be a great experience for him but for
on Madden's behalf right he has finished
with less than eight points only three
times at Vikings a since 2007. that is
crazy 8 out of 13 minimum score are you
kidding me
Magnus carlsen's like statistics are off
the chart doesn't matter how you
approach them how you approach his
percentages his opponents I mean he's
always off the charts he's through the
roof and uh this just speaks to the
consistency that the world champion has
displayed now for well over a decade we
mentioned a by now famous statistic that
the last time he had lost two games in a
row was all the way back in 2015 and the
last time he had lost two games in a row
in tata steel it was 2007 the iPhone had
only just come out Robert that is how
consistent Magnus Carlson has been and
he has still managed to turn this into a
respectable showing obviously one that
he's going to be disappointed by but one
that will definitely uh get a little
push if he can win this final game with
the black pieces let's check to see how
he's doing well Magnus Carlson he has
had several wins in recent games he won
his last two games with black and event
in his double White against Wesley so
and prognanda and before against gukesh
he drew all of them so with the white
pieces somehow he has not been able to
secure the full point but with black he
has done quite well and in this game I
think you are going to be the happiest
person of all this is the style of a
king's Indian the bishop on G7 not a
very good piece it's behind a wall of
PODS the bishop on G2 for white even
worse behind all of White's pawns so the
question in this position is where is
the Breakthrough going to come from
there's tension on both sides the H5
Pawn can take on G4 the A5 probably
could take on B4 and white on the other
hand does not want to capture either
Pawn if you capture an H5 that would be
a terrible decision before white in fact
maybe a losing position on the spot if
we show that uh just to play GTX H5 the
problem is that once you make the move
the Knight comes out to F6 takes on H5
hops into G3 the H3 pod will become an
immediate Target this would be a
terrible terrible strategic a mistake
from White's perspective so you're going
to keep your pawns on G4 and on B4 and
Donya the big question and I'm really
asking you sincerely because you're such
an experienced King's Indian player is
where's the Breakthrough going to come
from from magnuson's point of view
that's a great question and of course
she takes H5 as well as B takes A5 would
get you immediately kicked out of a
Soviet chess Camp it would make you the
laughing stock of the grand Masters
we're not going to see that Arjun
aragaisi is going to keep the status quo
on the king side in fact he actually
does have the idea of evacuating his
King and traveling toward the center
that is why it's important for Magnus
Carlson to keep the idea of a takes
before in his pocket play that move
prematurely and white wrestles control
of the a file from black and
orchestrates peace trades down that file
every piece trade especially the heavy
pieces is in White's favor because it
diminishes the likelihood the black
crashes through on the king side so
black should reserve a takes before for
the moment when White's King in the
event I should say that White's King has
made its way to the queen side uh and
white and black needs to reopen that
side of the board as for your question
how is black going to break through I
think it's not a question of if Magnus
will take on G4 it's a question of when
and I think his last move is part of a
long and laborious process by which he
prepares uh to find the right moment to
capture that pawn there are many ways to
reshuffle restructure your kingside
pieces one common idea is to bring the
bishop back to f8 drag The Rook over to
H7 you also would love for your queen to
join the party somewhere from H6 or H4
it's very hard to get it they're not
impossible you could play Queen F6 to H6
for example and once all of those pieces
are in place only then do you capture on
G4 but there are so many complex
complicating factors one of them is that
white could recapture with the F Pawn
and keep the pawn on H3 for defensive
purposes so you would also love to be
able to sacrifice on G4 but all of what
I just said uh is right about to go out
of the window because Arjun aragaisy
does not procrastinate he says I want
nothing to do with the King side I am
dragging myself on my own two feet to
greener pastures in the center King F2
is on the board and I think think that
is a fantastic practical decision by the
Indian Grandmaster he's doing the
petrogen King march the King goes up to
F2 it's going to walk all the way over
towards the queen side and the center
and if H6 G4 ever happens uh if black
decides to break the tension with that
pawn capture and white takes back with
the H Pawn it's really good that the
king is on F2 because the Rook for white
can slide on over to H1 so the tension
is going to remain neither side wants to
budge over there and on the queen side
it's the same deal you don't want to
take on B4 until you're good and ready
because you released the tension and in
doing so you open the file for the white
Rook so no matter which Pawn black
thinks about taking the white Rooks will
be happy to see those files open
and it's very important to indicate that
when you talk about open files it's not
just about whose Rook is on that open
file first you have to think deeper than
that it would be very myopic to say well
black should play a takes before because
he controls the a file let me show a
line that disproves that idea Bishop f8
is on the board really quickly bring up
an analysis report If instead black at
first captured on before and let's say
only then play the move Bishop of eight
this is how quickly white could wrestle
control of the a file from black and
capitalize on his nomination Bishop to
B2 let's say Magnus plays Rook H7 white
slides The Rook over to A1 let's say
that black continues operating on the
king side with you know random move like
Knight F6 already you're blundering the
C7 Pawn but more importantly after the
trade on eight white could replace the
Rook with a queen a queen trade is
disastrous for black because the Rook
will infiltrate into the seventh rank
but if you move your queen the queen is
very passive on C8 widescreen can
infiltrate to A6 and white is already
winding his tentacles around Black's
pieces on the queen side now the evil
bar is dropping I get it black probably
has a sack on G4 I'm trying to
illustrate the conceptual danger of
taking on before prematurely there are a
lot of concrete considerations here that
are more important but um Magnus Carlson
wants to keep the tension on both sides
of the board until he is good and ready
as you said to release it
yeah it is an instructor position to
look at the eval bar is a bit
distracting if we just pretend that it
wasn't there your point is well taken
that white gets to make progress up the
queen side whereas in the current
position black is unafraid of either B
takes A5 because black gets to take back
with a piece and then the C5 Square
becomes Knights for the taking the A3
Pawn is a permanent weakness and taking
on the H5 Square makes the H3 Pawn
weakness and as we saw the Knight on E8
can hop right back out to F6 take on H5
go into G3 so white is not looking to
capture those pawns and black is going
to try to time it perfectly so Rook H7
it looks like a good choice for black
and what is arjun's plan is he just go
to shuffle do you think that's the best
he can do
well I'm surprised by the move rookie
when I was expecting to move Rook F1 to
H1
obvious for obvious reasons preparing
for the scenario in which black takes on
G4 he's put the Rook one square to the
left of that Rook to G1 Magnus responds
immediately with Rook to H7 is Arjun
contemplating GTX H5 I really don't
think so I think that move is associated
with way too steep of a price so Robert
he could continue his King march and
maybe what he's saying is that I'll give
you that open Age file but if you bring
your Rook to H2 you will no longer
attack the bishop no he's gone Bishop to
F1
and I'm just trying to make heads or
tails of his reshuffling what if Magnus
takes on G4
I think he'll take back with the h-spawn
and he'll just
be saddled with the worst place rook and
Magnus plays Knight and Max is going to
keep the tension h64 can happen at any
moment because black white excuse me is
not going to take on H5 uh but I think
origen is just going to play Bishop E2
Bishop D2 and then ask Magnus how he's
going to make progress there's something
that we should really point out here is
that at some moment black could make the
move C7 to C6 the problem with Black's
position is well he's better so it's not
really a problem but he can't find
inroads he has he can open the h f file
you can open the a file but all of the
squares are covered by White's pieces so
you're not actually creating a concrete
thread but if you can open up more lines
more Avenues of attack that's how black
can turn in aesthetically pleasing
position chances to be better to
actually becoming better because you
create more spaces for your pieces yeah
if I had to choose a side I would take
black because C 4 C5 which is the only
Pawn breakthrough available to White is
really going to be very hard to imagine
black is defending that square 8 000
different ways of the bishop and both
pawns and that's the only thing the
Knight on B7 is good for it's a
defensive piece right now it could turn
into an offensive piece if it is brought
back to d8 and then toward the king side
there is the classic idea of actually
sacking on G4 uh thereby creating a very
powerful Pawn Phalanx that idea could be
effective even if the king is evacuated
to the other side of the of the board
those pawns uh could potentially become
deadly Arjun knows all about those types
of sacrifices because he was the victim
of one earlier in the tournament in a
similar type of position against Jordan
van uh Forest so he definitely does not
want deja vu I like what you're saying
about Queen C8 Knight d8 and that
actually sort of reinforces the idea
behind C7 to C6 uh because the C4 Pawn
can become a Target the Knight capturing
back on C6 what's immediate pressure on
the B4 pawn and the Knight would love to
reroute into the D4 Square so the
position opening up is bad news for a
king in the center especially because
after HG for hd4 the King on G8 is
perfectly safe not in any danger
whatsoever The Rook on G1 is passive so
I think Arjun believes that with the
closed position that he will be able to
just Shuffle and hold but this is a
miserable position to have right it is
not pleasant in the slightest black has
a free hand at all to play
and the last thing I would do is trust
the evil bar here it's giving an
incredibly ambiguous minus Point 19 What
on earth does that mean in this position
it's impossible to calculate this
position concretely and these are still
the types of closed board positions
where engines can be ineffective because
you've mentioned it before the Horizon
effect they're not able to visualize the
long-term Concepts
humans are still able to do that and we
are able to see that black holds all of
the pawn breakthroughs as one wise man
said he who holds the pawn breakthroughs
holds the advantage there's the IDF C6
there's the idea of H takes G4 there's
the psac on G4 white has no equivalency
five is not possible B takes A5 is
ineffective and as long as black keeps
the pawn on A5 the a-file is shut and
white has no inroads to make on The
Queen side
this looks like very fun position for
Magnus as he's going to calculate and he
controls the pawn breaks and another
player who previously controlled all the
pawn breaks but now his opponent is
striking back that is our top game of
the round between norderbeck Abdul
sitarov and Jordan Von Forest Jordan was
tired of sitting and doing nothing and
he finally is able to strike as we see
in the top left with the move F7 to F6
so done I think we should dive right
back into that game because the last few
moves that have been played have been a
bit of shuffling some pod pushes but now
there is tension in the position and so
Black's pieces are feeling a bit more
free
yeah I think this is a rather
encouraging development for your bed
Forest who has maintained his lead on
the clock he is up 20 minutes and you
know in order back down to 40 minutes
where only 16 moves in there's been a
lot of action in this game but we are
still an eternity away from the first
time control and Notre break is still
faced with a lot of very important
decisions so let's rewind a couple of
moves and see how this happened we were
just singing the Praises of White's
position after night to F5 Jordan traded
on A7 he followed your advice with King
to E7 notorbeck got his Bishop out
Jordan solved the problem of the D6
Square by putting a Pawn on that square
and this very very committal move by
notorbeck is what led to the current
position he decided to release the
tension on the king side with the move
G5 immediately walking into F6 by Ben
Forrest the idea of F6 primarily I think
is to get this Knight out of G8 because
before it was completely restricted been
Paralyzed by The Pawn on G5 I really
like the move F6 and intuitively I feel
like motorbike might have underestimated
it but no he's going Full Tilt f4 on the
board oh my goodness this is now
becoming a double-edged position before
it looked like no deerback had no risk
he was controlling everything but now I
feel like it's a less stable position
he's trying to keep that Knight on G8
stuck in place if white ever captures on
F6 the Knight would have captured back
and headed towards D7 and up to C5 so
here I think that F takes G5 that's the
first idea that comes to mind for black
the Knight on Jade is not happy but at
Pawn on G5 will be doubled and isolated
Pawn not so much E4 will mean I said
Pawn as well the E5 Square carved out
for the Black Knight so if fg5 and white
takes back with the pawn then the Knight
comes to E5 and maybe it goes to F7
where it attacks G5 protects D6 and will
allow the Knight NJ some some Freedom
some relief and they will be able to go
up to F6 eventually
and let's not forget about one of
notrebrecht's old foes the move B5 B4 is
once again in the mix you cannot afford
to lose this E4 Pawn without clear
compensation so in this situation
motorbike would probably have to spend a
move preventing before he could do that
actively by bringing his Rook up to D4
but I agree with you I think in this
scenario the Knight would drop back to
F7 white actually cannot defend the G5
Pawn he has to try to do it indirectly
by counter-attacking one of Black's
weaknesses several moves come to mind
you could double Rooks on the D file but
black and respond in kind with Rook to
d8 I think this well perhaps Saving
Grace is a slight exaggeration I think
the idea that gives motorbeck enough
chances to balance out the position is a
to A4 forcing weaknesses on the queen
side and you could actually sacrifice
the g-pawn and try to whip something up
on that side of the board maybe using
the rook and sliding it to B4 harassing
the bishop on B7 going after the A6
spawn but Robert all of that is water
under the bridge it is clear from a
broad outer standpoint that the position
has become a lot more double-edged and
three results are very much possible now
I like what you're pointing out with the
move A4 for white it's very easy to
overlook that it seems like all of the
action has been taking place on the king
side and suddenly you're hit with move
A4 so if you are not careful white would
get the upper hand and not in this
particular position but the idea holds
true that if A4 you crack open the queen
side and black does not have many pieces
over there so if black said instead for
like The Rook on d8 and you know Knight
to F7 and then Pawn A4 happens your
queen side could collapse and that's not
good news for black to handle actually
A4 is very strong here it's much
stronger uh in this position as you're
saying B takes A4 Rook takes A4 and that
this is why uh The Rook on A8 was so
important it was guarding the A6 spawn
now Knight takes G5 Bishop takes A6 is a
very favorable trade for white white
gets a passer on B2 and black is not
completed is kingside developing the
king 97 could get caught in the
crossfire now something interesting has
happened Jordan has taken on G5 and he
has gotten up from his chair I try to
avoid getting up when I believe that my
opponent's response is forced because I
know that I will just have to sit right
back down unless I have to go to the
bathroom but Notre back has not
immediately recaptured on G5 is he
seriously contemplating a Brazen
alternative such as E5 Robert what do
you think
hard to imagine especially in a game he
only really wants to you know he needs a
draw because the niche Geary still needs
to win to catch up so uh E5 looks so
risky here done he's gonna he's gonna
take back on G5 I don't know exactly
what he's considering but he is for sure
taking on G5
yeah well we talked about that in in the
context of the Parham game the sunk cost
effect sometimes you take so long
calculating a move you want it to work
so bad that you subconsciously ignore uh
potential reasons that it doesn't work
so I really think Notre back I was gonna
say I think he should limit his thinking
time and he does he takes on G5 cooler
heads prevail and Jordan's play here is
really easy 95 is kind of a low hanging
fruit pick that Apple off the tree and
with an hour on the clock I really feel
like Jordan is in the best shape that he
has been since they entered this end
game
he has a nice square at E5 for his
Knight while his second Knight is stuck
at home that G5 Pawn can be targeted so
Jordan he's handling this well uh it
remains to be seen from nordirex
perspective what he is planning here I
think A4 is in the cards that's what
he's going to look for but he's also
gonna be looking now he's away from his
board in each Geary's game so while this
one will look to see how it continues
let's take a step back and go toward the
game of Anish giri and Rich report
because F6 to F5 was finally played by
report
it took him a while but he got it done
the the position keeps changing in very
subtle ways but these subtle peace
Maneuvers taken together represent major
shifts in the way that we should
understand the position F5 is on the
board you called it Anish giri decided
that he wanted nothing to do with that
Bishop tension he brought his Bishop
back to C4 and has tucked it away on a
very well protected Square on B3 the
pawn on F5 is making contact with the E4
pawn it is black to move here it's a
Richard report he could trade on e4 he
could trade a pair of Rooks but who's to
say that he is the one to benefit in
fact I think he doesn't because once a
queen lands on e4 there is the
devastating threat of a knight Fork on
E7 you can't really play Bishop F5 for
that reason so maybe you take on e4 and
then play Bishop F5 immediately he has
in fact traded pawns what do you think
is going to be Richard's follow-up here
I like White's position I feel like
there's zero risk but in a must-win game
that's really where the stress is for a
niche so I think he will probably put
his Bishop on F5 I mean it seems like a
very reasonable Choice it forces white
to take on E8
um but what is very stable here right
like you you're gonna get the e-file
it's true but black can also bring that
Bishop back to E6 measure so just to
kind of put the line on uh the board
sure
that if we put Bishop F5 you forced Rook
takes E8 is check so you can't take the
queen on D3 uh the queen takes back
Queen D2 that looks like a good choice
and then Bishop E6 I preemptively close
the e-file at some moment I very well
may take your 9d5 I'll play Queen how
about now Robert you don't want to take
1995 no no make an offer you can't
refuse I'm going to refuse anyway but
Queen D7 it looks like a good reply and
the question becomes Dania at what point
will trades happen now the capture on D5
will leave white with a pleasant plus no
matter what but if that Knight moves
away from D5 and the light Square
bishops get traded that could also be
good for white as the Knight will go
right back to the D5 Square
yeah it opens up a line of communication
forces the bishop trade and as you're
saying the gate closes when the Knight
moves on to D5 and it will be completely
unassailable in the absence of the light
skirt Bishops now again I get that the
Evo bar concretely doesn't like Knight
F4 it might have something to do with
the possibility of Bishop to H6 pinning
the Knight and picking the Knight off
the board black will definitely uh like
to have a queen and Rook vs Queen and
Rook position where yes the pawn on D6
is a bit of a weakness and white will
have a symbolic plus but black should be
able to hold that position pretty easily
so just because we have a positional
type of situation does it mean that you
you can ignore concrete factors and that
you can set your calculation uh aside I
would be really curious to see how Anish
Gary tightens the screws this type of
position to move it is style would be
something like h2a H4 just continuing to
improve creating some tension on the
king side trying to induce some more
weaknesses Robert I think it's safe to
say if he wins this game it is going to
take him a while to break down down
Black's defenses so he has to steal
himself for a very long Magnus type
grinded out effort where he's going to
have to chip away and Chip Away
mercilessly at Black's position until he
induces enough weaknesses to transform
his positional Advantage into something
more tangible historically anishikiri
has done well against Richard's report
now this position uh you know we are
seeing the Contours take shape is one
where white has a better position
because black has an isolated pawn and
white has Outpost a good picture of the
light squares but in their history
Richard Port has never beaten Anish giri
and each has three wins to his name the
other six games were drawn and
specifically in Viking Zay Anish does
have a win there against Richard so
um I think that with that lifetime score
in anisha's favor that gives him some
confidence but he'll need to win this
game and that's the hardest part is when
you have to play for for a result from
the first move it's uncomfortable chess
is an objective game you just want to
play the position but now you have to
play the leaderboard
and for every Grand Master there is at
least one usually more opponents that
they just find very inconvenient Robert
I'm sure you can come up with some names
not just super Grand Masters regular
Grandmasters as well several names come
to my mind I used to struggle mightily
against varajan akobion one of the top
uh American Grand Masters I would lose
to him regularly at the U.S championship
and when you talk about a player like
that whom you struggle against it's not
necessarily for obvious reasons it's not
necessarily they have a particular style
or that they play a particular opening
that you find Annoying It's usually a
combination of smaller subtler factors
taken together the fact that they are
particularly effective against your
style the fact that they are somehow
constantly able to disarm your finest
ideas they're able to steer the game in
a direction that you find uncomfortable
and maybe that has been the case with
Anish giri against Richard deportanish
is such a sound objective player and he
is often able to douse the Flames of
Richard reports Ultra Korea creative
play kind of like Magnus Carlson was
able to do earlier in the tournament
when he just accepted a report's double
psac Consolidated his position and won
his game this is kind of what Anish Gary
is looking to do in this Ultra important
final round affair
and he's just risking nothing in his
position and I think that while Anish
really wants to win this tournament as
the Ambassador for it as a Dutch player
playing on Dutch soil I do think that he
doesn't want to lose this game he's not
going to go all in he's played a very
good game he is clearly the side that is
for a choice but it's also a very
measured approach so I like what he's
doing here I believe that his chances
are good to get the full point but I
also think that when I say good it means
non-zero not that they're over 50
Richard report very solid thus far and I
will continue to be so so let's uh we
know that
a niche will likely put his roof on E1
or on D1 the control of the D5 Square
dictates the advantage but making
progress from there that's the hard part
done this so I think that for Richard he
kind of needs to just keep his Bishop on
E6 threaten either to take on D5 or uh
just to not give white any access to any
of his squares so what is anisha's plan
like how does he actually turn it from
now aesthetically pleasing position to
one that is giving him a substantial
Edge
well I think right now there's no sense
for Anish to decide anything you have to
wait for Richard report's next move once
the placement of Black's light squared
Bishop is clarified white can start
thinking about subsequent moves right
now I think you can essentially pre-move
rookie one
I think we can expect Bishop E6 with a
high degree of certainty if those moves
occur on the board I pointed out the
idea of pushing the pawn up if black
allows it you obviously want to push it
all the way up to H6 and create mating
squares on the king side if black
responds with H7 H5 well that weakens
the G5 Square y can occupy that with a
queen and White's Advantage is
positional in nature but that does not
mean that an attack against Black's King
is out of the question it is far from
out of the question when you have a
monster Knight like this in the center
of the boards that's one line of
thinking that Anish could adopt we also
pointed out the idea of trading light
skirt Bishops conceptually that would be
an ideal scenario because he would reach
a good night against Bad Bishop there
were logistical problems with it namely
Knight F4 always seems to run in the
bishop H6 so maybe you find a chance to
move your queen out of the way and then
drop your knight back to F4 so Robert I
think Anish could take this in tactical
directions positional directions but
first and foremost I think he's got to
play rookie one settle himself down and
sort of psychologically prepare himself
for a very long road ahead
it's going to be a long road and even if
he does win the game he's going to need
a little help from his friend as we all
do but Anish actually didn't interview
with his good friend of patriot Jordan
Von Forrest after their game and they
were showing their camaraderie to the
media during an interview let's have a
listen
no it's fine it's hard I'll just let
Anish deal talk yeah
[Laughter]
looks around for the chest
no I mean he was too handsome I couldn't
concentrate
oh these two They Know Each Other Well
that's uh very funny to hear from them
especially after that long game that
must have been taxing for them and yet
they're just still laughing it up
there's probably many people there I
heard a bunch of voices joining in the
cacophony of laughter and Dania I mean
all laughs are in the past because right
now it's serious business and each Kira
needs to win
and Anish will not be laughing if he
manages to squeeze a win out of this
position and then Jordan benforest
messes up what by now seems like a
pretty promising end game against Abdus
Torah but as I said earlier while
anisha's game is going he's not holding
his breath he might steal a glance here
and there at his compatriots game but at
the end of the day you have to focus on
what you can control once this game ends
if Jordan map Forest is still playing at
that point he will stand over the board
together with the Litany of Spectators
who make their way to waikansei he will
do that with baited breath because the
prospect of winning a tournament like
this is definitely enough to get your
heart beating it will not be enough for
him to win and for another back to draw
he will then have to win a tiebreaker
and unfortunately he's failed to do that
on two separate occasions but obviously
he's never faced Notre back in a
tiebreaker he lost the Jordan he lost
the Magnus will the third time be the
charm you'll have to cross that bridge
if he manages to get there yeah that's
far away just based on this position
it's going to be a long battle between
these two here so why don't we zoom out
while Richard report thinks about how to
respond to this move Queen D2 when a
rook coming to the e-file we still have
six games in the session the one between
dingley Wren and Fabiano caruana was
drawn that was an early repetition and
as I look at the boards here the one in
the middle the bottom row levonne
aronian and part of muksulu not playing
for first place but they are still
playing they're giving it their all it
was a Sacrifice by maksudu the game
remains fascinating Wesley so in the
game next to that to the left ragananda
is better he is making uh active moves
and keeping blacks pieces stuck in place
but there aren't many pieces remaining
so I do feel like Wesley will be able to
hold with proper play and then all the
way in the left and the bottom row
Daniel
Magnus Carlson Arjun continues running
with his King whereas the queen side but
Magnus is trying to crash through over
on the king side the board is on the
left side the white king is about to
make its way to the left side of the
left most board it doesn't want to go
all the way to the a file because then
you will run in to a well-timed capture
on B4 you want to be able to recapture
with a pawn so the king might get all
the way uh as far as B1 but it'll stay
there there is a balance to be found as
far uh as the king's evacuation route
and just because the King has left the
king side does not mean that black
doesn't want to open that King side up
and infiltrate with his pieces Magnus
through some very laborious Maneuvers
has prepared himself for the capture on
G-Force you could follow that up with
some sort of infiltration unfortunately
that Rook on B2 is so well placed to
preventing blackstroke from penetrating
to the H2 Square Magnus he continues to
shuffle prepare and prepare when will he
take the plunge and take on G4 will he
ever take the plunge or will the game
continue at this kind of standstill
Robert I've seen a fair share of draws
in these positions that occur because
neither player is willing to make too
drastic of a commitment and we could see
that here I don't think we're going to
see that here because Magnus Carlson he
doesn't have much to lose and in his
mind he has to take at least a serious
stab at winning this game and giving
himself vanishingly unlikely but still a
chance to win this tournament
so you're saying there's a chance and
that's all Magnus Carlson needs usually
makes the most of his chances and well
that position is locked up so I just saw
Jordan Forest make a move uh while
Magnus position remains locked up we can
get back to that one in a bit what about
what about abusot and Von Forest because
we were talking about lines just like
this and now it seems the eval bar is
creeping up in oh who's that teenager's
favor
I think Jordan has just made a very
superficial move a move that looks
appealing on the surface but walks right
into notorbeck's main Queen side Eddie
yes I will admit I am fully influenced
by the eval bar but in our defense we
pointed out this idea a long time ago
long before the evil bar even came into
existence this idea was being played by
top players and that is the idea of
striking at Black's Pawn chain with a2a4
the common wisdom holds that you want to
strike at the base of the pawn chain
unfortunately there's no file to the
left of the a file so you have to make
do here by attacking the tip of the pawn
chain that actually leaves the base
vulnerable because the bishop on E2 is
going to x-ray the A6 Pawn a2a4 in this
position Robert poses black with very
serious problems on the queen side what
is Jordan's idea because he definitely
saw A4 I have no doubt about that
is he relying on something concrete such
as Knight C6 and B4 or has he
hallucinated and overlooked that idea
entirely
he's I believe for sure gonna bring his
Knight back to C6 because in the event
of A4 white is striking immediately at
Black's pawns we talked about B takes A4
not being a movie you want to play
Because The Rook will take and the A6
Pawn is immediately targeted and loose
so Knight C6 is the retreating move I
think that would be necessary The Rook
slides back to D2 because it's under
attack and then B4 is played by black
the Knight has to move backwards where
do you go to D1 and now people I feel
like black has a turn to do something
what that something is is a very
difficult question to answer maybe it's
the night back to E5 again opening the
bishop up to the E4 Pawn the Knight can
slide back to F7 but the Evo bar is
saying no no no that's not good
well black is just saddled with with
tremendous long-term weaknesses on the
Queen's side just because white isn't
attacking anything at the present moment
doesn't mean that there aren't long-term
problems both of the queen side pawns
are now weak there is a juicy Square on
C4 that can be occupied by white knight
in the event the Black Knight drops back
to F7 but you can all understand why
noterbeck was skeptical about this
continuation this is a hard position to
evaluate it's made plus 1.4 yeah once
you see that evaluation you start to
understand why but you know things don't
go the other way around so Notre back
he's already made a move it's not A4 he
decides to keep the tension and leave
his options open by stacking his Rooks
on the default let's go back to the live
board Rook htt1 obviously disapproved it
by the eval bar and Robert after the
move Knight F7 we could actually
transpose into a position we thought we
would have through a different order we
thought Jordan would drop his Knight
back immediately Notre Beck would
respond with Rook D1 and then black
would bring the Rook to d8 so they could
actually get a position we've already
discussed and in that position I think
A4 is more than likely we can also see a
repetition here wouldn't you be that
surprised if black plays Knight C6 The
Rook goes back to D2 it's the only
reasonable square and then that goes
back to E5 I'm not saying that white has
to go Rook to D4 in that position but if
we just show that quickly with the
Knight going back and forth that
um I feel like
if Rook goes back 95 yep and if you put
A4 because the rook's not on D4 then
black still has B4 here and if you play
Knight A2 going after the pawn E4 is
loose black can of course reinforce it
with A5 H4 H3 is not out of the question
for black to try to free up The Rook on
h8 develop it by pushing the pawn
forward so I I just feel like there are
some opportunities here for Jordan but
would nobody back repeat what does he
have another idea in mind you think he'd
repeat
I'm quite confident that he would repeat
by the way the funny line here is if
white plays C3 trying to Chip Away uh at
the pawn chain well uh you pay a pretty
steep price for that after P3 the Knight
is literally trapped on A2 so in light
of these and other variations I think
Notre back would take the draw here I
think he would say listen I guarantee
myself at least to type for first
Richard report is holding strong for the
time being no need to do anything
outlandish but all of that goes out the
window because your invent force is not
interested in begging for a repetition
he has gone for your idea and played the
pawn down to H4 straight away right to
open up that H file and ultimately
harass the Knight on E3 unsettle the
situation in the center but once again
A4 is very much on the menu for Notre
back wow huge decision there by Jordan
Von forest and he's showing that maybe
he's also fighting for a win I don't
think he's really results oriented but
look at this position he wants to push
that pawn to H3 get his Rook active
maybe The Rook can slide over to g3 at
some point to get that G5 pawn and white
needs to strike with A4 if you don't
strike with A4 you give black all the
Time in the World to start creating
active threats so done I believe A4 is a
really promising move the Knight will go
back to C6 we'll see some of those
variations we're looking at earlier with
black push it upon the B4 uh but it's a
true fight in this one I would not be
looking at the eval bar for guidance I
think that both sides have their chances
it's not like white is slightly better
and it's symmetrical no no no no it is a
position where both sides really do have
their pluses so Dania
um I mean what do you think
now I agree completely I just wanted to
throw in one more point and uh we have I
think earn ourselves another break but
just to tie off uh what I hope has been
a productive discussion about this game
one of the most important and least
talked about skills in chess is the art
of evaluating positions right it's
incredibly important it's like the the
Cog behind the scenes that allows your
position to run it's not enough to see
something you also have to understand
whether it's good or bad and one of the
sub skills that stands behind successful
evaluation is understanding the relative
hierarchy of importance between certain
factors and this is also what often
contributes to mis-evaluation it's when
you think something is more important
than another thing but in reality that
other thing is the more important factor
and I think this might be one of the
reasons or perhaps the main reason why
noterbeck is so hesitant to play the
move A4 we see the evil bar and we know
that after A4 Knight C6 Rook D2 B4 1982
we know that the most important factor
in this position is that incredibly weak
Square on C4 and the relative weakness
of black skiing side pawns but in
notorbeck's mind he might be saying
listen I get that but look at my knight
on A2 it's worse placed than the Knight
on G8 and after A5 I'm basically playing
down a piece and I don't have that
second night to deal with the prospect
of the king side opening so I don't
think this is a case of notrebrecht not
seeing A4 I think this might be a case
of Notre back having the wrong
evaluational hierarchy in mind and in
order to play A4 he is going to have to
fully appreciate the importance of
Knight C4 which in this precise position
actually wins the game because black has
no way to defend the D6 Pawn let's see
he's able to come up with that he is
taking his time and just a big big
moment a half step back there but like
let's say black didn't play A5 there's
just so many different variations where
Blacklist B3
and once white takes on B3 black plays
Knight A5 with a double attack against
the B3 pawn and the E4 Pawn so I think
this is where the fear comes in it's not
that he's scared of Jordan but he's
looking at this position saying this is
getting wildly double-edged and White's
Pawn structure in shambles why is
temporarily up a pawn but if you lose
one Pawn back G5 can be gone after the C
file is open the B file is open for the
black rook and now it is just chaotic
with both sides having their chances so
I understand why no dear Beck he's
thinking he might not play A4 and we'll
leave him to that and you know while we
are well on our way to a break I just
want to give a shout out to an event
that is coming back very soon because
the pro chess League one of the favorite
events in the chess calendar begins
February and that is just a few days
away so with elite players like Magnus
Carl headlining this season and a prize
pool of 150 000 2023 season will be won
for the history books wildfires begin
February 1st and the main event starts
on February 14th use the command PCL in
chat for all the details with many
players in the field taking part in the
Protestant you will not want to miss it
we will not want to miss the action so
we'll take a quick break and we're in
return the final round of the Tata steel
Chess Masters 2023 continues
struggling to improve your game
chessable is the home for chess
improvers with hundreds of courses by
incredible authors like world champion
Magnus Carlson Christoph selecki andras
Toth everyone's favorite social media
troll known as Anish Geary and so many
more chessable can help you raise your
game to the next level
you're getting started on the
fundamentals you should check out
everyone's first chess workbook
maybe you want to stop letting all those
points slip away in the end game 100 end
games you must know is the course for
you did you not notice your king was in
check and still can't figure out why the
pieces won't move
actually uh chessable can't help you
with that maybe try refreshing your tab
check out chessable today and get 30
days of pro for free go to chessable.com
begin
[Music]
foreign
January and Vicon say the Netherlands
for this cozy coastal town the holiday
season isn't over
in fact the most wonderful time of the
year has really just begun there we go
the tournament leader holds Wesley so to
a drug he has impressed all of us
once again Vicon Zay starts the new year
as the center of the chess Universe this
year as host of the 85th taught to steal
chess tournament
a magnet for the best players in the
game some recognize the Masters field of
2023 as its strongest in recent memory
of course it helps when eight-time Tata
steel chess champion Magnus Carlson is
back Magnus is going baseball if Magnus
plays like this the rest of the way who
knows what can happen
the world's number one looks to further
cement his legacy in this event and the
game's history
chasing Magnus will be amongst the best
in chess several have been crowned
Champion here before some have even
shocked the world in doing so
and don't leave out those poised to
capture their first Tata title what a
fight Gary had to give it his all
because he was on the verge of losing
and he managed to survive
although winter Tata steel chess is also
known as the place new stars come to
bloom Magnus one here is a teenager this
year's event has its fair share of young
players on the rise each hoping to
follow in Carlson's footsteps he
continues to lead this event and he is
just a teenager
the Dutch referred to Tata steel as The
Wimbledon of chess for 85 years and
running this tournament continues to be
steeped in Prestige and Legacy and does
so again in this welcoming Little Dutch
town by the sea
mine brynden it's the 85th edition of
the Tata steel chess tournament let's
make chess history together
Magnus Carlsen focused at his board he's
taking an Arjun eragisi he needs to win
his game and now they're back up to
start to lose his in order to tie for
first place there's been only one result
in the books thus far in the 13th and
Final Round daily Ren 500 Carolina an
uneventful draw by repetition they end
their tournaments but six games remain
and done it the one between Magnus
Carlson and Arjun aragaisi it has been
one with a lot of tension that tension
has been released so we'll see can
Magnus Carlson win this game and try to
catch Abdul sitarov
this game has resembled a video uh that
one of those Troll videos that went
around Facebook a couple of years back
and I think my mom sent it to me it was
a 10 minute long video and it involved a
high jumper kind of lightly hopping on a
trampoline and he was lightly hopping
and hopping and the video was set up in
such a way that it was obvious he was
trying to complete a jump of impossible
distance onto a ledge and you keep
watching because you think how on Earth
is he going to make up that distance and
of course Patrol part that he never ends
up doing anything just waste 10 minutes
seeing him hop lightly on uh that
trampoline surface this game well it's
gone a different path he has Magnus has
finally shot his shot he has attempted
to reach the ledge but has he succeeded
I do not think so although the next
couple of moves are going to tell us a
lot he has finally decided to to open up
the a file he has opened up the age file
and he has infiltrated along both files
with both of his Rooks the position may
seem totally overwhelming but Robert
first impressions are often deceiving
and I think Arjun is so fundamentally
solid here that if he can ward off
Black's Rooks he might use that a file
to infiltrate with his queen and the
tables might very well turn in this game
maybe a timely sacrifice on G4 is what
appeals to Magnus about this position
what do you think of Carlson's attempt
to jump onto the ledge I think you're
correct that if black just trades out
pieces it'll be worse in the end game
and that peace sacrifice on G4 is going
to happen I think white will play Rook
G2 to stop the check and trade off that
really you know strong Rook on the H
file and I think that we will see a swap
of all the Rooks let's analyze this
because Rook takes two
check
Bishop takes G2 Rook takes B1
probably King takes B1 because you you
want to keep your knight on C3 and then
Knight takes G4 I think this is the
direction we're heading where Magnus is
and the Evo Bar says it's Justified so
Madness Carlson is about to sacrifice a
piece and I think from a practical
perspective Dania this is extremely
difficult for white to play yes because
there are two passers coming right for
the other side of the board to promote
and if you make a move like Bishop F3
like let me trade off that Bishop model
G4 it's bothering me a pawn will replace
the bishop you can probably take on F3
and then push Upon A G4 and I know white
is up a minor piece but those pawns are
menacing
and those pawns can turn into something
other than pawns pretty shortly I
mentioned your uh Jordan's game against
Arjun aragaisy I have no doubt in my
mind that Arch and aragaisy is looking
at this position and thinking not again
I'm gonna get another sack on G4 and
another situation in which black has
connected pastors of course Jordan won
that game with the white pieces but
there are so many similarities the pawns
have an easy path forward supported by
the pieces that are very nicely
positioned on the king side Magnus had
this in mind when he put the bishop on
E7 and the 997 they're not there by by
accident he put them there the bishop
could swing out to H4 the Knight can
jump into G5 and the queen from C8 has
direct access to the G4 Square which
could be a very important post from
which it could supervise the further
progress of the pawns now that's a lot
of ifs and I don't think that line is
entirely forced one spot where Arjun
could deviate slightly uh is after Rook
takes B1 he could actually decide to
take back with the Knight and the
rationale behind this move and hear me
out for a second into the evil bar is
already starting to cackle evenly after
a knight takes G4 fg4 Bishop G4 the
Knight could move out to D2 and white
could establish a sort of stronghold on
the F3 Square white could say come at me
brah and the moment black reaches F3
white sacrifices a piece back on F3 and
at the very least eliminates the pawns
so I think objectively the position
might actually be balanced with both
sides having excellent chances but I'm
on the totally I'm totally on the same
page practically as well as on the clock
I think Magnus Carlson is making a very
astute call and he has chosen a great
moment to take that plunge he might make
it to the ledge after all
this is not going to be pleasant for our
generic icy he's having a rough
tournament and the world champion is
ready to sacrifice a piece for two pawns
and with limited material there will be
Queens on the board but no Rooks those
past pawns feel like they have uh the
opportunity to reach the promised land
so I am very nervous for Arjun here I
think he has some big choices ahead of
him whereas Magnus Carlson's his plan is
clear he is going to trade he's going to
sacrifice a piece and then his pawns are
going to threaten to go to the other
side and that is going to keep White's
extra piece at Bay
now we should also point out on the
subject of moves that are not forced
Rook G2 is incredibly natural but also
not for us there are alternatives you
could bring your king up to B3 you could
also block the check with the bishop and
that has the additional benefit of
reinforcing the G4 Pawn of course Bishop
B2 is a very hard move to play because
it involves keeping the Rook alive on H2
moreover you actually step into a pin
which is always hard to do margin has
not done that he has indeed played Rook
G2 and we are going to get a fascinating
denumont in this game as the world
champion is going to fearlessly
sacrifice a piece on G4 in the finest
Spirit of the king's Indian that he
hasn't played this wasn't a king's
Indian but let's call it a king's Indian
emeritus
yes well uh Magnus he played the king's
Indian type of position with great
success and now is the critical moment
because Magnus doesn't have to take on
G4 I just think given the tournament
standings and really just give him the
position that Knight does he didn't even
spend any time he just didn't allow me
to finish my sentence and he plays
Knight takes G4 Argentina no choice but
to take and Bishop takes G4 I really
feel that this position is so difficult
for white to play there are two pass
pawns that are easy to push you can move
your Bishop right away from the G4
square and put a pawn to G4 and continue
with the pawn to F3 and then the
question is what is White's plan I think
for white you would think about the C4
to C5 at some moment but it's not easy
to accomplish that because black has
this bishop on E7 has both the pawns
staring at the C5 square and white just
doesn't have enough Defenders to justify
it and I feel like black has a free hand
just complete control on the only part
of the board where action is taking
place
you're absolutely right white could
perform a lot of Maneuvers on the queen
side but all of them are like pinching a
dinosaur you're not actually going to
stop the process from unfolding on the
other side of the board one way to pinch
the dinosaurs to get your knight around
to C6 big whoop big deal Black's just
gonna Slide the bishop over to F6
congratulate white on getting the Knight
to an outpost and then proceed with the
inexorable March of his kingside pawns I
again I don't want to overstate the case
here I I can exaggerate in these
situations Magnus is not winning the
game is not over the evil bar is still
showing zeros but Arch and aragaisi has
struggled all throughout this tournament
he struggled in this exact type of
position against the Arden van forest
and the added psychological pressure of
facing the world champion I think puts
him in an incredibly top spot from a
practical standpoint but the next couple
of moves for Arjun are going to be
critical yeah and I see a future for
this black queen if Arjun is not careful
that Queen may find itself in the H file
and going down to the H2 Square I feel
like white just doesn't have a plan here
and I don't think that's exaggerating I
don't think that it is being too
critical of White's play White hasn't
played poorly I think the position as we
see it in front of us objectively there
should be a way out for white I just
don't think it's easy and for Magnus his
plan is much easier he's just going to
try to push his pods to the other side
so Bishop F3 either now or in the near
future that's the vital question for me
is white going to be able to trade some
pieces or does that actually help Black
start pushing the pawns forward and will
white be able to withstand that as the
pawn marches from G4 up to G3 and you
get connect five C7 all the way through
to G3
and as a follow-up question can you
potentially orchestrate counter play
against Black's King using primarily
White's Queen Bishop F3 might help you
do that it clears some of the Shrubbery
on the king side and maybe the queen in
some roundabout way can make its way to
H5 and threaten to deliver a series of
nasty checks starting with Queen G6 that
would also enable white to limit the
mobility of black screens so you're
absolutely right a crucial question to
answer for Arjun aragaisy do you play
Bishop F3 do you focus instead on
improving your queen side situation or
the move like Bishop to A3 is it worth
spending some Tempe to play C5 I don't
know there's a lot of questions he's got
24 minutes to answer them and uh the
wrong answer could mean another zero in
the tournament across table I'm hoping
all your questions are rhetorical
because I'm not going to answer them too
difficult for me it's going to be
difficult for Arjun and I've really see
this as a struggle for him but if
somebody is capable of holding this
position it is Arjun eragisi he is super
strong he is having a rough event but
that does not take away his class his
form is temporary his class is permanent
that's so they say and I think that for
Arjun this is a learning experience and
he will be back and he will improve on
this year's score and in this game I do
think he has his chances but it's not an
easy position so let's zoom out of this
one just because the to my eye something
huge is happening in the Abdul sitar of
game against Jordan Von Force look at
this done in the top left
my Lions girl you have crazy action in
the center a pawn has appeared on E5
forget 8284 that is old news the new
update is that we have craziness on the
king side in the center we've got an
x-ray Against The Rook that has just
appeared on H5
this is not a position for eight o'clock
in the morning this is not a position
for midnight this is not a position I
would like to have at any hour of the
day but certainly not on a Sunday that's
the final day of a tournament that I am
going to win if I avoid losing the game
who's better who has the initiative I'm
gonna ask a series of rhetorical
questions Robert but one question that's
not rhetorical is Robert has a good
commentator the answer is yes I think he
is uniquely equipped to help me
understand the secrets of this position
oh my gosh I mean this is ridiculous
this position it's getting tactical
before it was one where we said there
was some positional uh pros and cons
that white could strike on the queen
side instead he makes let's go back a
few moves let's see how we got here I
think that will help us explain the
current dynamic because we left off when
black made this Pawn to H4 trying to
bring the pawn to H3 so abdusitara
brings his Knight to G4 and in doing so
he offers a trade of knights if black
took the Knight on G4 after Bishop takes
G4 Black's entire plan of pushing this
Pawn to H3 is stop instructions look at
that how high the evaluation just went
black is playing without two pieces The
Rook on h8 is not active the Knight on
G8 can't get out and white can play on
the queen side and this is just a
terrible situation for Jordan so instead
of trading nights he brings his Knight
back to C6 The Rook retreats to D2 and
he brings his Rook up to H5 attacking
the loose G5 Pawn so that pawn can't be
defended if the Knight moves away from
G4 The Rook on H5 is under attack
because the bishop money too but the
Rook will gladly steal that pawn on G5
so E5 is just a tactical shot the pawn
cannot safely be captured
uh G5 and E5 excuse me because look at
this line Daniel if Pawn is captured
after Rook takes d8 the Knight will take
on d8 Knight takes E5 I believe
that and there's Rook takes G5 there's
Rook D7 check the King goes back to E8
and there is Rook takes d8 check and
there's a knight four kind of F7 and
then the Rook on G5 is picked up at the
end of this long variation and that
would leave white a piece ahead for a
couple pods still chances for black to
survive this game but of course white
would be in the driver's seat
but in this position white has
Alternatives I think Knight F6 might
also do the trick because the Knight on
G8 actually hangs with check white will
put it out of its misery or when The
Rook on H5 so Notre back is going to
sorry benforest is going to avoid the
capture on E5 like the plague similarly
I don't think he can take on G5 because
white takes on D6 with Chuck I think
there's only one door that is open for
him he will have to lock up the center
with the move d65 yes he's taking his
time he's adjusting his eyes to the
chaos that's now on the board but I have
no doubt that he's going to play this
move what might his reservations be well
after I had that after the move D5 I'm
already looking at F6 Square it's
looking like a vulnerability and they're
I think are more tactics here what if
whoa Knight E4 does that work
that's what I'm thinking Knight to E4
you can take that Knight the point isn't
that you lose the Rook under and you
don't
if I understand you correctly Robert you
want to stake a knight on F6 at the end
of the line right I want to take on d8
and after the Knight takes back on d8
play Knight F6 which means your Rook on
H5 is under attack the Knight on G8 is
loose if you take on F6 the pawn
captures back with check and that's
really bad news because I'm going to
take it yes because I have two passers
now that are storming up the board this
is just completely winning it's a la
Magnus Carlson but instead of being down
material you're
yeah material Sequel and you've got two
pass Bonds on the sixth rank that are
totally Unstoppable so that's out of the
question as well in this position after
Knight F6 I I would avoid this with a
ten foot pull uh in an OTB game just
because of how terrifying it looks for
black but this this might be necessary
for Jordan the question is well does he
have Alternatives after a 94 because
white has a very clear thread he wants
to stick one of the knights on F6 the
other night has plenty of real estate to
choose from it's got you know a mansion
on D6 and a beach house on C5 both of
those squares are equally juicy so for
black you know D takes E4 might be a sad
necessity Jordan might have to delve
into the weeds there and try to make
that move work do you see any
alternatives in this position Robert to
D take C4 is there anything black can do
to extricate this night maybe move the
king back and King E8 walks into a fork
I I really feel that
yeah he has to play D takes E4 maybe
maybe back but I don't know what
that does well Bishop C threatens Pawn
takes E4 so that's the benefit of
bringing the bishop to see you ah
preemptively cover the D7 Square so I'm
with you I think that what everything
you said is true that there are a lot of
luxuries in White's position and that
Knight is imprisoned on G8 I think that
the G5 Pawn being Tender Is what's
keeping black in this game with that
Knight on e4 ever moves The Rook steals
the pawn on G5 and the E5 Pawn is loose
it's another G4 ever moves so there are
a tremendous amount of risks associated
with this position I think that Abdul
sitarov I mean he is going for it he
could win this tournament outright if he
takes down Ron Forest but he is risking
a ton here and while Jordan sits and
thinks I'm getting word that the game
between Vincent kymer and gukesh that
one looks like it is nearing its
conclusion uh this game looks very level
earlier it looks good for uh Vincent
kymer with the white pieces now we see
it's a position with Bishops of opposite
color so would not be surprised if that
one ends and very soon so let's dive
into that game just very quickly here
before we return to our leaders because
Dania at this stage here I think the
queen was on H3 at some point and
somehow it's back on C8 so
oh we're getting a repetition of swords
well even if we don't get a repetition
we could get a Liquidation in an
immediate drop
if I plays Rook to E8 somehow black has
you know blacks kingside pawns have
visited the orthodontist and magically
uh corrected their alignment that
essentially means that black is totally
fine here kukesh it's kind of looking up
a draw for might have been issued with
Vincent's last move Queen F1 to E2 there
is a repetition on the docket here with
Queen H3 Queen F1 Queen back to C8
that's possible black trade Queens as
well there's no doubt in my mind Robert
that the game will end in a draw and
we're reading the body language here a
result might be imminent in the next
couple of seconds actually sorry good
final result for gukesh if he draws this
game I mean he's looking up that looks
like a player who's ready to make a draw
uh but he would finish at five and a
half out of 13 and he makes the move on
to F5 okay I thought for a second he
played Pawn g5s like that looks really
rich why would you do that
okay but this is the draw for because
Vincent's gonna go rookie eight and
offer a draw yes all the heavy pieces
get traded on E8 and that is just equal
and you can see it on googesh's face
he's like all right I held with black no
problem here and as you said those pawns
on the king side for black they are
fixed and with that being the case it's
just completely level now with the
opposite color Bishops
it is indeed and the only question is
how many moves is this game going to
last there goes Vincent as he brings the
Rook up to E8 gukesh is going to take it
and we'll stay on this game it's a funny
way to capture I think there might have
been a draw for sandwiched in between uh
h8 and E8 and since he's holding his pen
when a player holds his pen that means
he's expecting things to happen really
quickly
Queen takes queen queen takes Queen
I draw this offered there is the
handshake did you see he didn't even
recapture but did you see gukash like he
made the move Queen takes E8 and he
didn't really offer a draw so much as
told Vincent this is a draw right like
he he offered it but was ready to shake
hands immediately there was no life left
in the position a fair result between
these two Bishops of opposite color in
the end game leaves no chances for
either side so gukash finishes with a
draw against Vincent kymer the Arbiter
resetting the pieces and that means
their tournament has come to a close
Vincent kymer he was able to get some
great positions in the last bunch of
rounds he couldn't converted them so he
drew 10 games and lost three whereas
gukesh was more down and up and I used
down first because he was down bad at
the start of the event he lost it three
games early it looked like he was just
going to plummet out of the top of the
rankings and then he won a couple games
late to keep himself afloat keep himself
well above 2700 so a decent final result
for him
very decent results and great resilience
on display you called it at the start of
the tournament it appeared that he was
going to lose all the games he was
losing in very one-sided fashion he had
that horrible loss to Wesley so with the
white pieces and then he flipped the
switch he got himself together he
started playing better he managed his
time better he did get very lucky
against Parham maxulu but he rode that
win to a very impressive finish to the
tournament I think he lost a little bit
of rating but not a lot and even Vincent
kymer
is one of the lower rated participants
in the tournament he made a lot of draws
including a draw in the previous round
with Fabiana car one with the black
pieces he gains a little bit of rating
with each of those draws so definitely
not a disastrous event the tournament
cross table doesn't always tell the
whole story and what a phenomenal
experience for Vincent kymer Yes a
tournament of missed opportunities
Robert but one that he's going to
cherish one that he's going to learn
from and one that he's going to come
back stronger from next year you can be
sure of that
yes and we briefly had the challengers
leaderboard up and uh peshock the
Slovakian Grandmaster he's had a
tournament to forget um he's had some
exciting games but uh just to note
yeah has lost many many rating points so
for him you know you know it's better
luck next time but in the Masters
tournament uh we have five games still
going here and a chance for four
different players to reach first place
uh Wesley so I think his chances to
reach first are out the window because
if we see second from the left uh down
on the bottom row he is down upon in an
ending the Evo bars is completely even
the Knight on F6 along with the Rook on
D6 keep that extra Pawn at Bay but
prognanda will likely continue this game
and try to
squeak out of Victory
yeah he will he's got just the ideal
type of situation you got Wesley so uh
on the defending side of an end game
that you cannot lose it's the last round
that's a great feeling when you know
you're not going to lose it it's just
you feel all warm and fuzzy inside at
the same time I don't think that White's
winning chances here are realistic that
pawn and E3 is not going to get very far
black is positioned his Knight on F6
very nicely obviously guards uh the E4
Square The Rook on the sixth rank is
active as well it is Wilding over there
attacking the bishop and then it's going
to harass the pawn I don't see a great
Square for that Bishop so Robert I think
Prague is going to continue torturing
Wesley he's gonna milk this moment but I
would be shocked if the American
Grandmaster squanders uh this position
the defensive effort is so much more
straightforward than uh some of the
defensive displays that he's put
together in this very tournament
completely agreed so that position is
looking level uh the game between
aronian and maksudu middle bottom row
there I think that both players can lose
this game both players can win this game
but Hara maksu the credit to him he has
been fighting each and every game and
just by the look that we saw on the
camera there
um emphatically pushes his chair back
and gets away from the board and Lavon
he's going to struggle here because I
think Parham has the upper hand
he most certainly does and we've talked
a lot about the Practical value of the
exchange stack on C3 well I think he's
better from an objective standpoint when
the eval bar shows an advantage for the
side that's down material you know you
are in big trouble because we know how
greedy computers are how skeptically
they treat various sacrifices Rook takes
C3 has worked to absolute perfection
let's take a a somewhat closer look at
that position because we've got a lot
going on here lebanaronian's task is
enviable indeed a pawn has somehow
wormed its way to C3 Robert I didn't
imagine that happening that night on H4
as stayed entrenched pressuring and
lording over the entire King side and
lebanaroni and he just hasn't managed to
get his engine started on any side of
the board his pieces are disjointed he
does have a nice Bishop on A4 but what
is it really doing the 997 is well
protected it has a direct Pathway to D3
and God forbid you give up your dark
scored Bishop look at those massive dark
square holes on the king side that is
the last thing that you need if you're
LeBron Ronin I don't see a move for him
it's his move he's hesitating I just
don't see a way for him to to untangle
and he just keeps arm keeps improving
and increasing the vice-like grip that
he has on White's position it looks like
he brought his Knight back to F1 based
on how I saw his hand move and so he's
trying to reroute the Knight to E3 you
can move a black knight could go to G6
and into F4 so it's not like only one
side has that option can we go back
several turns because I also was
confused how a black pawn landed on C3
and it was levon's doing he went C3
himself in this position which is a move
he might very well regret because the
evil bar not only dipped it made black
simply take that pawn on C3 protect it
and now you have a very Advanced Pawn
here the bishop on F2 gets some scope
that's the good news the bad news is
there's a passer and it's just going to
be remaining there for the Long Haul
Levon made a couple of one move threads
which Parham easily parried I don't know
exactly what it is that Lavon overlooked
was it a concrete blunder was it a Mis
evaluation
I don't know it's impossible to say but
Parham reinforced the sea Pawn he
brought his Knight back trying to smoke
that Bishop out of B6 Lavon refuses to
go without a fight but then he has to
drop back Parham reinforces his Pawn one
more time now C3 is incredibly well
protected you're at no risk of losing
that pawn in the near future and after
Knight F1 Knight G6
obon can continue to make one move
threats but you're going to run out of
gas pretty quickly here after Knight E3
I don't know exactly where Black's Queen
is going to go is going to move forward
to D3 is it going to slide back to C7 I
think you called it the idea of Knight
G6 to F4 the other Knight could also
come in and then both Knights are going
to be aiming at that deadly D3 square if
a knight lands on D3 White's position
can just turn into dust pretty quickly
yeah wouldn't be surprised if this game
uh is ends in not too long in a win for
Parham I just don't feel like White's
position is easy to play Black has two
pawns and a knight for a rook those
Rooks are passive pieces uh the A5 Pawn
is a bit loose The Rook on C1 has to
stay in front of the C3 passer so unless
unless Levon can come up with some kind
of active play in the very near future
he is going to be in huge trouble I just
don't really see Parham letting this one
out of his grass if arm wins something
gets to 7 out of 13 a plus score it will
be parham's highest ever rating so we'll
leave param through this test because I
just saw at the corner of my eye
something happened in the Anish giri
game against and that game is very
important because if Anish wins and
especially if naughty brick loses that
would allow Anish to be the sole
champion of the tournament and if we
look at the top right the last one
played was Pawn up to F for a big Choice
by a niche that makes his King side feel
a little bit more Airy but he is also
claiming space of his own and maybe
going after the black king
Anish Gary says plague time is over I am
going after you F4 chases the bishop out
of E5 and the big question is what does
he have in mind after a report drops his
Bishop back to F6 that move is not
forced you have to give some thought to
a move like F5 but that move fails
concretely because you weaken the
seventh Rank and we'll have a check on
B7 so Richard is going to drop his
Bishop back is an each Gary going to try
to push his Pawn one square further is a
move like Rook F1 on the horizon or is
Anish Gary going to try to transform his
Advantage from positional to Tactical he
can trade it once on E6 forcing black
spawn to shift from the f file and that
night D5 is not its only prospect I was
going to say that it can move on to G4
something lands on G4 but it's not the
Knight it's a pawn and Anish Gary going
Full Tilt full steam ahead it's so very
clear that in his mind there is only one
outcome to this game he is saying I'm
gonna win or I'm gonna die trying
wow that is such a big decision because
now his King is a bit exposed uh that
could allow black to remain in the game
with some kind of series of checks later
on uh just keep that in your mind the
white king side is open and what is
black going to do here because G5 seems
like a pretty big threat because it's
attacking the bishop that's one thing
it's doing but it's also opening up the
diagonal against the black king So Queen
will slide in D4 eventually a knight
into G4 so with the combination of
Bishop takes E6 uh available I feel like
this is a really scary position for a
niche excuse me for and if Richard and
he's just playing well
if I may illustrate a line let's make a
random move for for Richard reporters we
bring up an analysis board G5 I mean you
can see the email bar shooting up there
I'm not entirely sure about the motor I
think you have to take on E6 first
because Queen takes E6 loses the game
you trade queens and then you just mop
up all of flex pawns after F takes C6
you called it G5 why is that dangerous
Bishop E7 looks solid for black no it's
not there's an x-ray against black
screen there's a check on D4 and no my
voice is going but you get the point
Queen takes E5 wins the rook and wins
the game because Black's Queen is
undefended a great example of not being
fixated on one particular structure you
have to be ready to transform your
advantage you have to be ready to make
concessions in order to gain other
things you can't make an omelet without
breaking some eggs and those words that
cliche is shorter than ever when you're
trying to convert a long-term positional
Advantage for that reason Robert Richard
report has to address the huge threat of
Bishop takes C6
Maybe by moving his King preemptively
back to G8 so that Queen D4 is not a
check Maybe by shifting his Pawn up to
H6 but I love the move G4 I think it's
gutsy I don't think it's overly
committal I don't think anishkiri is
doing anything crazy I think he's
putting Richard to port in a very tough
spot and by the way 12 more moves to
make for the Hungarian Grand Master and
14 minutes and change on the clock
well Richard now plays for the Romanian
Federation but he is from Hungary and
one thing that I think is important to
point out is this x-ray is not going
away so if you play H6 uh can we just
show this line that can't you take on E6
and after F takes E6 play H4 like can
you continue the attack because Bishop
takes H4 is unavailable to Black because
of Queen D4 check
that's a beautiful move H4 is lovely you
were using tactics to your advantage G5
is coming to a theater near you and
Robert I think you made a good point
earlier G5 isn't good just from a
tactical standpoint black could defend
against Queen D4 with a move like King
F7 but G5 is also good positionally
because you are carving out for your
knight a very nice post on G4 and if
black takes on G5 then F takes G5
decisively opens up the file G6 this
week that's out of the question Bishop
G7 could be met with Knight G4 white has
an abundance of options in a situation
like this this is exciting for Anish
giri especially in Richards reports time
pressure so oh my Lance was G4 a gutsy
call for a niche and I love every bit of
it
he needs to win this game and he is
going for it you can't say he's held
anything back he certainly has hasn't
held his kingside pawns back because
they're out on F4 and G4 and maybe a
third one will appear on H4 so uh Anish
he's trying his best he needs a Little
Help from his friend uh that friend is
Jordan Von forest and now that I look at
the rest of the games uh while Richard
decides how to deal with the threat of
G5 I think things are changing in the
front Forest game as well
this is unbelievable we have seen so
many twists and turns in this round you
couldn't script this better in Hollywood
notary superb's game looked like it was
heading directly for the type of end
game Notre back would want no risk
playing for two results essentially can
make a draw whenever you want to that is
gone that has gone completely it appears
at least according to the evil bar that
Jordan benforest has now taken over the
advantage let's unpack that a little bit
the last move was Knight F6 takes G8 I
should mention Robert we called it 94
happened it was met with Bishop C8 which
was executed immediately by Van Forest
sensing the turn of the tide Knight gf6
Rook drop back to h8 and suddenly after
The Rook recaptures the Knight Notre
back it's not the G5 Pawn that he has to
worry about it's the more important E5
Pawn that can't really be defended
what's going on here
wow so you can do everything back on G8
I guess you take with the D Rook just to
keep your what's up
sorry please go ahead no go ahead you
just you're freaked out what he said it
might be missing the Mark here I think
the reason you take with the dirok is
that so that if White's Knight moves
back to G4 you leave yourself the option
of getting back to H5 and mopping up
that G5 fawn oh wow so yeah take it with
the D Rook just makes perfect sense to
work on D is not doing anything
regardless as Knight F6 yeah Buddha Rook
back Knight G4 Rook H5 that looks very
promising for black and the G5 Pawn
collapses
you're winning here I mean you win G5
likely you're gonna win E5 oh my gosh
and okay obviously Notre back has
options here but if you're not playing
Knight F6 you have to move the Knight
am I missing something is he just losing
a pawn for little to no compensation
how does he defend that pawn that is the
question we need to answer so Knight F6
seems automatic I don't see another
Square for the night and after Knight F6
Rook d8
what else can be played here because
Knight G4 does not work we just saw that
oh is there something tactical like
rookie E1 can you defend the pawn if
Knight takes E5 there's Bishop takes B5
kind of thing but no the eval bar
doesn't like that either for some reason
I 95 Bishop takes oh five let's H3 oh my
gosh what a move
oh that is Ace can I say sexy that is a
sexy move right there H3 great spot by
you if GH3 then it's obvious forkovic on
F3 more impressively Rook takes E5 you
drive it down to H2 and the H pun
decides the game
oh my goodness so the bishop on B5 would
be hanging H3 gives you that pass or
can't be captured because the fork on F3
so how to that means you can't really
defend that pawn
I don't even understand why it's plus
one here only and not just winning for
black
wow
oh
that is pretty wild like it just looks
like White's position is falling apart
Jordan red Forest has indeed and quickly
taken on G8 with the correct Rook with a
d Rook Notre back has responded when
that F6 and if Jordan plays Rook d8 he
positions himself in the BET needless to
say the best chances that he's had all
end game long he is clearly better but
he has to spot some of these tactical
details how easy is it to miss H3 I mean
it takes nothing to miss HP and
neuterbeck is down to 12 minutes he's
got 13 more moves to make until the
first time controls this is very
disturbing for the tournament leader
wow I mean he has been looking so stable
where for nadir Beck he did not lose a
game yet he drew against Vincent kymer
in a tough ending but for the most part
it seemed like he's been the one in
control winning games uh drawing without
too much difficulty including
yesterday's game with the black pieces
against Wesley so and the day before
against Anish Gear with the black piece
so dearbeck's tournament is in his own
hands he's in first place he has earned
that lead he has won four games and if
he wins against Von forest in this
position he wins the tournament outright
and if he does not win then he needs a
little bit of help from Richard report
and some others especially if he loses
because that means Magnus Carlson can
catch up with the win over Arjun
aragaisy Wesley so can also win but his
position is never going to be winning so
that leaves Magnus Carlson with an
outside chance if no deerback is to lose
this game to vent Forest but am I to
understand this correctly that if Anish
Gary wins and Notre Beck loses Anish
giri claims clear first yes
oh my gosh and for the first time today
we are even talking about that scenario
listen Anish Gary is clearly better
Notre back at this point it's not up for
debate anymore it's clearly worse if
things continue to go according to the
trend that they've been following for
the last hour or so we could get one of
those improbable tournament finishes of
all time but right now this is pure
hypothetical nothing at all has been
decided Jordan is not winning he is
merely better but if he wins either of
the pawns uh that sit that are sitting
ducks on E5 and G5 he will inch one step
closer to playing ultimate spoiler of
word that you've been using a lot Robert
and for very good reason
yes that would be a true shame for Abdul
sitar of you know not every game could
go a player's way but considering the
tournament he has had it would seem
almost odd that he wouldn't end up in
first place but that's because Anish
giri has played a great tournament
himself the move Rook d8 was played by
Jordan so the E5 Pawn is targeted and it
doesn't really appear there's a good way
to defend it and let's not discount the
time
down to 12 minutes 20 seconds and
they've only made 27 moves so he has
about a minute per move that is not a
lot of time because this position is
complicated
and he got up from the board right there
I don't think that's a walk that he
takes because he's comfortable with his
position quite the contrary I think it's
nervous energy that he is trying to
expend he is taking a walk he's just
burning off some of that anxiety and
trying to freshen himself up in
preparation for the defensive task that
he is going to have to undertake in
order to pull out a draw from this
position and guarantee himself at least
a tie for first place this is honestly
an unbelievable turn of events no matter
how this game ends I honestly thought
notabeg really had that in the bag oh
boy have things have changed oh boy how
the chess gots out from rewarded Jordan
for coming to this game ready to fight
and ready to play for a win when it was
oh so easy for Jordan to play E4 E5 make
that quick draw and you know get your
deserved rest no after a seven hour game
he comes all guns blazing and if Jordan
in front Forest wins this game Anish
Gary can finally forgive him for what
you might ask the 2021 Tata steel
Masters in that event Jordan and Denise
tied for first place it went to tie
breaks they drew their rapid games then
it went to Armageddon where White had
more time but had to win a black had
less time but only needed to draw and
just what Anisha was about to win he
stumbled in time trouble and Jordan won
the game won the title and it was a
great day for Dutch fans who of course
celebrated Jordan's Victory but a really
sad day a Bittersweet day let's call it
that because while Anish was happy for
his friend that was such an opportunity
for him to make his Mark and he has a
great chess history behind him so many
accomplishments but I think there's been
one thing that has eluded him and Magnus
Carlsen loves to troll him about it it's
winning a super tournament he has won
some events but he hasn't won an event
with Magnus Carlson in the field and so
if Anish is able to win his game and
Jordan does him a favor and wins here
that would be a big day for Dutch chess
and for Anish giri to determine
ambassador and nothing would Silence the
Critics faster than winning a tournament
in this way with a ridiculous photo
finish where you come through clutch in
the last round and you get a little bit
of help from your compatriot what a
poetic finish that would be this will be
written about for years to come if these
this scenario actually comes to fruition
but let's not jump the gun here both
games are still ongoing nervous energy
is being expended time is being spent
precious Time by Notre becomes he tries
desperately to coordinate his defensive
forces he might have been relying on
rookie one from a distance he might have
just realized that H3 uh is the party
pooper and he has to reorient himself
mentally settle himself up prepare
himself for the defensive task ahead
this is one of the toughest spots that
the tournament leader has been an
alternative along
I didn't expect you to use that turn of
phrase but yes he is
what was that which startup phrase would
that be
uh none in particular just you know
something you said it was just a little
surprising now I'm like yeah worried
about you I'm just you know I don't know
what to say I feel like
I'm scared now
but which turn of phrase are you scared
about
no I'm scared of you but you said party
pooper
oh that's what I thought it was yeah
what else would it have been why why'd
this get so awkward all of a sudden
no I mean I just had to clarify you know
so that I can avoid such terminology in
the future
this conversation is going nowhere no
it's not but what is going somewhere is
Jordan's position in particular the H4
oh that right there was smooth it was
worth all of the awkwardness that
transition right there
oh well look at that H4 Pony it is
likely to go to H3 and some of these
variations uh but Jordan can take this
Pawn on E5 I wonder if there are other
ideas because Bishop takes B5 we've
examined it it fails there may be
another option that I'm just thinking
about Dania in the event of Knight takes
E5 there could be a positional play from
Notre back and if you take on E5 if we
can just show this white plays Bishop G4
and the point is the Knight is under
attack and if you take on G4 and the
White Knight takes
now you have dark Square domination the
bishop on C8 is a bystander the Knight
comes to E5 where it runs the G6 pawn
and the fork on C6 this Rook can slide
up to D4 at any moment and we can
continue with some Queen side play so
maybe notary back has some deep idea
here to give up material for a
positional clamp wow that is what my
coach would call or would classify a
mature move not only do you have to
refrain from Bishop takes B5 you have to
see H3 this Bears repeating if you take
on B5 and snag a pawn with a discovered
attack against the Knight black has the
brilliant H3 spotted by you instantly
either you get forked or you allow the
pawn forward to H2 or of course you lose
the bishop that is still hanging this is
very bad news for Notre back I really
like Bishop G4 now black does not have
to take the bishop but if you drop the
Knight back to F7 and go after the other
Pawn you run into a tactic of your own
two can play at that game and white will
come around and take that pawn on D5
using the pin on the e-file I'll tell
you what Robert even though white is
probably still worse after Bishop G4 I
will be very impressed if noderbeck
spotted this idea in time pressure H3
though by Jordan van Forest as he delays
the capture on E5 well I can understand
why he would do that because he doesn't
need to be forcing here uh H3 it keeps
the status quo in on the E5 and G5 pawns
and those pawns are weak now there is a
downside in this position is if a white
Rook can land on the seventh rank there
is big trouble for the black king that's
very far away but in the event the white
Rooks take control of the H file that
could be a bit scary so Jordan he's just
trying to open up the board no dearbeck
responds quickly with GTX H3 a reminder
he is down to nine and a half minutes
for 11 moves Dania not a lot of time for
him
not at all but I'm more curious about
Jordan's follow-up because if you take
on E5 your idea Bishop G4 it becomes a
lot stronger he takes back on H3 so he
says I'm Gonna Leave The Pawn on E5 for
later I'm gonna box it up and put it in
my fridge the problem is that white
could take it out of the fridge by
sliding the bishop up to D3 and creating
a threat of his own
what is Jordan's response going to be to
Bishop D3 if you play King F7 White's
Rook slides slides F2 and motorbike
subtly creates full-fledged counter play
along the f file am I missing something
here or was H3 a flat out mistake
oh tough one to evaluate I feel like
Bishop D3 the Black Brook will slide
over to h8 and so now he's Rook H1
because a series of TR if we take the
Rooks off the board black might just win
the game because White's pawns are so
weak uh so The Rook G3 also becomes a
threat going after the G5 Pawn the one
thing you don't want to do is Rush that
move because if you slide your Rook to
G3 too soon and then white takes over
the H file that's how the black king
does find itself In Harm's Way so uh I
think that what your audience is going
to do is pretty much slide his Rook over
to h8 next regardless and The Rook on d8
is not doing much of anything it's not
needed there
so let's have a look at this concrete
line which we're very likely to follow
Bishop D3 is so natural I don't know if
Notre back will be able to refrain from
this move if in fact your theory is
correct and Jordan responds with Rook D
to h8 can noderbeck snag this
all-important Pawn on G6 this gives him
insurance against losing one of his own
pawns because now he can suffer the loss
of one of his pawns without really
suffering a true material loss because
now he's up a pawn is Jordan going to
play Rook H1 in response he might but
then an orbit could calmly slide his oh
back to D1 saying I'm not giving up a
single inch of territory on the king
side
how does Jordan actually pick up the G5
Bond because White's plan is very clear
he's going to move his Bishop back and
the path for the Jeep on is going to be
clear this is a nice wave for Jordan to
actually lose the game pretty darn quick
unless he has a cataclysmic tactical
idea in mind
good point maybe The Rook would have to
go to G3 to go after the G5 Pawn instead
of going all the way up uh to H1 but
that's what black is going to need to do
is start taking those pawns G5 Falls and
E5 is weak I just feel like black has no
weaknesses left right all of Black's
pawns are safe and sound whereas White's
pawns have gone a little bit too far
they're overextended and that's not
great news for Abdus who is dropping
below seven minutes it's only only 29
moves played they need to get to move 40
to gain an additional 50 minutes the
position will remain complicated after
that and no Rebecca has not moved yet he
is no trying to figure out what to do
and by the way Donya the other game of
great importance between Anish giri and
Richard report is getting super tough
for report I feel like the position is
opening up over there and so Anish Geary
he is looking at his game he's looking
at this board and he has serious chances
right now he does indeed he has pushed
upon to F5 now obviously that is an
incredibly double-edged move because he
is opening up black skank but it comes
at the cost of the safety of his own
Monarch he believes that the combined
force of his pieces particularly that
Knight on D5 is going to outweigh
Black's heavy pieces because Black's
Bishop has zero attacking prospects the
D4 square is controlled that Rook on C4
looks menacing but Geary has calculated
and he believes that his attack is going
to outweigh any of Richard report's
attempts at counter play what do you
make of this what's likely to happen
first of all Robert I think anishikiri
has to start by recapturing the pawn
probably with his Pawn because I don't
think an end game looks all that
appealing to me at least
no he definitely doesn't want the end
game but I was thinking what happens if
Knight F4 you drop your knight back to
hit the queen on E6 and Knight H5 check
is available for that night that's the
good thing about having played F5 is the
G6 Pawn no longer covers that really
important checking square and the black
king feels like it's in pretty big
trouble
it does indeed and an important detail
is that after Knight F4 you cannot sneak
in the move F takes G4 let me just real
quickly capture this Pawn the counter
attacking the queen no because Knight
takes C6 is a check that's a crucial
Detail no black has to move his Queen I
don't think the exchange stock enough
for uh does does anything and white just
wins the game technically after that
where is the queen going to go these are
the types of decisions that you do not
want to make when you've got limited
minutes on the clock report isn't quite
in as bad of time pressure as Notre back
but his situation isn't much better 10
minutes for eight moves and a lot of
those eight moves are probably going to
be very committal decisions Queen t7
comes to mind to keep an eye on F5 this
move loose is on the spot why because
after Knight H5 check King G6 Robert
there's probably do you see something oh
oh my gosh hello
I just came over and it's mate what a
mating construction look at this
beautiful my gosh wait a second that
means that means that Richard's King can
never it has to go back no matter where
the queen goes the King has to go back
so put the queen back on E6 that let's
say queen E5 that well Queen if I might
run to Rook D5 but not yet because it's
not that Force hanging but 95 check the
king could still not go up to G6 because
that same tactic takes D6 so the King
has to go to the last rank but that's
very scary because it's a check on A8
for example oh my gosh this is looking
scary and look at she's about to move
his Knight oh he's seen it that's why he
played F5 it wasn't to weaken black
structure per se it was actually to
vacate the F4 Square for his Knight how
hard is it to find those retreating
night moves and what a beautiful
maneuver by Anish Gary this puts Richard
report in such a difficult spot and yet
again we repeat this almost every round
Robert yes the eval bar is displaying an
ambiguous evaluation it's saying that
report is doing a good job of Defending
but that tells about one percent of the
story because Richard report is about to
be faced with potentially the hardest
defensive task of this entire game
Knight F4 is on the board
and Richard down to 10 minutes and under
30 seconds remaining on his clock it's
only moved 33 and if you think about it
with a knight H5 check coming the king
having to go to the last rank that looks
really problematic for him because the
queen ah check will force the king up to
E7 putting the king and the Queen on the
same line looks scary and so I think
that Richard is in some trouble here
it's not an easy position for him to
play and this is really good news for
anishkira you couldn't ask for a better
situation with Jordan van Forrest duking
it out with no direct record that one
remaining complicated with chances for
Jordan to seize the edge and then this
one if the King goes up to G6 the night
try to check the game is over on the
spot so Richard report he cannot have a
blind spot to that Rook takes c66 tactic
because if he falls for it the game is
over and then Anish giri will likely end
up at worst in a tie for first and maybe
in clear first and we see a move has
been played I believe Richard he moved
his Queen up and that forces the niche
to go Knight H5 check I think the queen
went up to E5
good because Queen E4 actually would
have been a blunder
right okay so where is Richard gonna
move like this is a huge moment
everyone's holding their breath right in
the moment
let's see he needs to bring his King
back to the last rank
he has no choice here because we as we
saw King G6 runs into Rook takes D6
and how easy is that to miss much easier
to miss because the mating construction
is so unconventional how often do you
see a mate with the queen on F5 and a
knight on G5 a night on H5 the simple
mating patterns are going to be spotted
Within Me Oh My Gosh always
he's not riding the move down no he's
not right he can't believe it and he
shook his head that was a knot he's
confused and Richard reported as look at
him look at him he's Geary he's he can't
believe it
I can't believe
he just took a breath he is going to
find it he is looking he knows it's
there and it's completely winning for
white afterwards 66
look at look at Anish
he can't believe it Am I Dreaming have I
missed something is my queen hanging is
there a Checkmate the answer is no no no
and no he might have to pinch himself
and he is going to take his time here
he's going to savor this moment but Rook
takes D6 ends the game that was a
fantastic call by you you saw that from
a mile away and I cannot believe this
Robert I cannot believe what we are
seeing
you help me out by putting the queen on
D7 and the eval bar went Sky High and it
just goes to show that if the tactic
Works in one position maybe it works in
another and Rook takes D6 is going to be
played you could see it in his body
language he is like a tiger ready to
pounce and for Richard's report in
really bad mistake here he was
struggling his King was going to be in
danger no matter what but bringing the
king up to G6 that is playing with fire
and he's going to get burned and a niche
Geary he is going to take this Pawn on
D6 and when he does I don't see how
anything happens besides a win for white
we are going to see an immediate
handshake I think after Rook takes D6
Richard's report might try one more move
he might play F takes G4 and resign
after H takes G4 amazingly that capture
changes absolutely nothing white
maintains the pawn on G4 and as I just
said that mating pattern is hard to spot
but Richard report is going to be
kicking himself for making the decision
as quickly as he did he had nine minutes
on the clock not 30 seconds and
retrospect hence side it's 2020. Richard
reports tactical Vision in this game has
definitely been far from 2020 this is
going to be amazing anishikiri is going
to win this game and that is going to
put the heat a lot of Scoville units on
Notre backup de sotorov
oh my gosh and I can understand why he
didn't want to bring his King to the
last rank I think he just completely
missed Rook takes D6 and Dania I think
if we check and I'm going to check right
here Rook takes D6 is the only move that
is good for white every other move it
says it's level I mean there are some
bad moves for white but the next best
moves are a level game so Richard did
not want to bring his King to the last
rank because the queen would have slid
all the way to a check let's just show
something very quickly that if the king
went to f8 instead that the queen goes
to Aid with check it takes an A7 with
check like that doesn't look very good
for black in fact it is still better for
white so I get it that Richard brought
his King up to G6 he did not want to
allow the queen to come in with check
the white king is still safe and sound
because the Knight only tribe covers G3
but King G6 is a terrible mistake and I
think the person who is even more upset
than Richard
because if Rook takes D6 is very late
and it's about to happen that's it he's
scary he sees it Richard
in one of the most consequential moments
of his chess career this is the
tournament that he has never won this is
the tournament he's come oh so close to
winning so many times and if Jordan
benforest is able to convert what now is
a Surefire Advantage Anish giri will
have clear first place this will be
ridiculous but Anish understands the
gravity of the moment he knows the
importance of making the correct call
here and what sense of responsibility
what discipline by Anish to take his
time to force himself to check the move
again and again and again we know what
the eval Bar says Anish giri knows no
such thing it's a question of when he's
going to take on D6 and not weather
wow so Rook 86 is played he will have a
winning Advantage Richard report he
knows that it's there you know he sees
it after and he's goes to grab it and
there it is Rook takes D6 is on the
board you can't take the Rook because
Queen takes F5 is not just check it is
mate and that means that Richard reports
King is going to be hunted he is lost in
this position yeah he gave he's bringing
his King up the board and I guess maybe
there is some opportunity for white to
go wrong if Rook takes F6 oh looks like
a free piece maybe that gives black some
hope to even take the pawn on G2 don't
shovel dirt on him just yet Anish Gary
has 19 minutes to figure this out the
winning move here is Rook back to D5
creating an Unstoppable made threat
against F5 note that Queenie one check
King G2 is a complete dead end but Rook
takes F6 here would indeed be a grave
error that would greatly complicate the
winning task after F takes you four but
listen this is easy to see it's clear
that after F takes G4 white has no
effective check apparently white is
still winning with some sort of
intricate computer play you have to give
a check on H4 with a pawn but throw that
out of the window Anisha is going to
avoid that like the plague he is going
to find the winning move Rook to D5 and
wherever the queen goes the problem
isn't only Queen takes out five
Checkmate it's also just Rook takes F5
and then you pick up the bishop either
with check or accompanying it with a
queen trade either way block is going to
end up down a piece
yeah just a couple checks Queenie one
check King G2 no more checks more black
whereas the white king is safe the black
king is just going to be checkmated so
uh while Anish Geary he Ponders his move
he has Rook D5 let's remind everybody
that going into the round Rebecca
abdusitarov was in the lead by a half
Point ahead of Geary so abdusitarov he
could win the tournament with a win of
his own even if Anish wins that is
looking unlikely which means that with
the win here Anish gear will guarantee
himself at minimum a tiebreak match
against Abdus atarov but if it becomes
the Double Dutch dream and Jordan van
Forest takes down the Uzbek superstar
that Anish giri will find himself alone
at the top of the standings first place
a dream come true for Geary in the Dutch
town of vikon Zay and so you see Anish
grabbing his Rook it makes the move Rook
D5 he's done it he did he's going to win
this game and he's not hesitating he
knows the game is in the bag did he get
lucky in this game absolutely but do you
manufacture your own luck in chess yes
Anish giri he brought every ounce of
energy his remaining energy whatever he
had left in the tank after that Marathon
session against the Jordan van Forest he
brought it to the board with him today
he played a great opening he made a nice
astute choice to get that positional
advantage that positional Crunch and he
followed it up with some daring tactical
play he got Richard into time pressure
and of course he benefits from let's be
real a very uncure right there so
blunder we see this almost never at the
highest echelons of Chess a one move
tactical blunder and Richard report is
going to accept the inevitable he
delivers a spike check on E1 and I think
Robert that he is going to resign after
the king slides up to G2
and I think just for the tournament he
has to play it out a little bit I mean
you can't just resign you need to just
play some moves even if you know you're
lost because for Abdus atarov I feel
like that's the fair thing to do and
unfortunately Rich report he had a great
second half he won three games and
suddenly he makes a one move blunder in
a difficult position I think I need to
make that loud and clear it wasn't like
he just hung a queen when he was fine no
his King was in danger white was in the
driver's seat and it was a mistake an
uncharacteristic one but for Anish Geary
he is a five-time runner-up in Viking
Zay he wants to remove everyone talking
about being runner-up he wants to win
this game win this tournament and
because he's missed it by that much in
the past it would be a kind of a
rightful
win for him in this tournament because
he did defeat Magnus Carlsen earlier on
but in order for him to win this
tournament we need to take a look at
nordbeck abdusitarov against Jordan Bond
Forest uh as our Chad is saying
sometimes Richard makes one move
blunders it happens uh this happens to
everybody it's not just Richard but as
we look at Abdul sitarov on the screen
here Dania and we look at his position
in the top left I'd love about Forest
game I think that G5 and E5 pawns are
permanent weaknesses so I would much
prefer to have Jordan's position in that
end game Jordan made that very
interesting call to throw in the move H3
and open up the H file the eval bar
disapproved of it initially but you
convinced me that its practical value
was tremendous it puts Notre back in
such a difficult spot it forces him into
an open-ended position why is that
important well it's because he's in
severe time pressure you want to give
your opponent a lot of rope when they're
in time first you want to force them
into making decisions Anish Gary did
that against report it's a totally
different types of type of position with
the Queens off the board in notrex game
but it's the same general principle and
now Notre back is saddled with two
long-term weaknesses first of all he has
to make it to move 40 and even if he
does who's to say that those extra 50
minutes are going to Grant him the time
that he needs to pull off a a draw in
that game this is I'm speechless right
now this is unbelievable and this just
continues to unfold in One Direction and
One Direction only
and you know what that direction is
well we have the game between Geary and
recording should I I'll stick to the
Geary game then yeah I feel like just
because uh that other game it looks like
it'll continue for a bit we will keep
our eyes on it uh but the Kings on G5
and the evaluation bar is through the
roof and then each Geary he is not
rushing his decisions he wants to win
this game he is completely winning why
should he make moves quickly game
regardless in fact is this not just just
like Checkmate about to happen Rook
takes F5 check uh just to show that if
the king runs back to G6 you may have
some hopes some dreams of saving the day
Rook F6 check is another brutal shot if
you take the Rook the queen takes back
the King has to go to H7 Queen G7 is
checking me the Knight has been a heroic
piece all game Dania remember how strong
it was on D5 but with a timely flick of
a pawn from F4 to F5 the F4 score is
vacated the Knight hopped back then
forward to H5 it ventured over towards
the enemy King and it did the job for a
new Geary he is about to take the pawn
on F5 with his rook and if you can't
move back with the King donut the King
has to move forward but come on a king
on H4 no way
well it's kind of sitting there King H4
the simplest way to win is what else but
another night move Knight H5 drops back
to G3 yet another devastating retreating
night move Anish giri has had a couple
of these he went back to F4 and then
forward to H5 hither and thither he has
gone and Knight to G3 sets up
essentially an Unstoppable threat Rook
H5 is the threat black can close off the
fifth rank with Bishop G5 but here all
white has to do is vacate a different
mating Square F5 and of course who else
but the Knight to deliver the mating
honors Rook to D5 is the most clinical
move because this also prevents the
queen check on day two not that that
check would have been dangerous but this
closes all of the defensive doors and
guess what Robert the prettiest win
comes after Rook F4 when white delivers
a queen sacrifice on top of everything
else it's a simple one but a queen
sacrifice indeed after Bishop takes F4
yeah The Rook steals the Thunder but
Anish Gary doesn't care with what PC
delivers the Checkmate all he cares
about is that it's a 1 on the tournament
cross stable in one way or the other I
think he is going to bring his Knight
back to G3 he's also going to reach time
control and Richard report is not going
to suffer here for much longer
yeah I don't even know if we will reach
the time control I feel like we're one
move away from a resignation and while
that Rook was going to steal the Queen's
thunder in that variation I think
anishikiru is happy to steal no dear
abuse ataros Thunder because it has been
all Notre back in this tournament he
beat Magnus Carlson early after seven
rounds I think he had five and a half
points he was just uh you know showing a
tour to force and now in the last round
Anish giri Looking ready to catch up and
that relies on Nordic not winning his
game and if nobody loses then it's a
niche curious tournament so Gary's win
is clear he can play Knight G3 he can
probably play like eight different moves
and be completely winning because
there's a king on H4 a button Knight G3
looks like the simplest variation just
try to replace the Knight on H5 with the
Rook wow and then you see the chat as a
Dutch chess fan this is an amazing day
this is just an amazing moment this is
why the payoff in these types of
tournaments is so so worth it now every
round has had its own character its own
personality but yes the rounds have been
long the time control is generous but
who if you don't feel like this is worth
it that fifth moment is worth all that
we have waited for then I'm sorry but
you're not a chess fan I feel like
everybody whoever you are rooting for
everybody is holding their breath and
just appreciating the drama and the fire
that we are seeing on the chessboard
just to make one more concrete point the
reason I think Knight G3 is the most
precise is because in response to Queen
D2 check this is actually kind of a
funny line after Knight G3 I don't have
to make the moves on the board it's a
simple line uh to visualize Queen D2
check the Knight moves back to E2
another retreating night move and white
has the double-made threat of Rook H5 as
well as a queen Checkmate on G3 or F2
this Knight has performed unbelievable
Feats it has just done acrobatics on all
sides of the board it has served White
positionally it has served right
tactically it has served quite
defensively and it's going to most
likely deliver the final move of the
game
and you see Richard report I mean he's
pretty much resigned as soon as Anish
makes his move he is extending his hand
and giving up and for Richard it is
disappointing because he did have a
really nice last bunch of rounds he beat
dingley Wren that was a really good game
and he has played well in the second
half his move G5 against Arjun Eric icy
in round nine with the black pieces that
was such fascinating display of
knowledge and just a way to be boa
constrictor Queen G3 check has been
played instead of Knight today same
exact thing the clock has stopped Anish
giri wins and that means he moves up on
in the standings he finishes his event
with eight and a half points out of 13
games he gains more rating he is having
a phenomenal performance but now Dania
even though his work is done he might
still have more chess to play if
abdusitarov holds on makes a draw
against Jordan run for us we will get
tie breaks we will indeed Anish giri is
now going to watch with baited breath as
Jordan men Forest attempts to convert
his endgame Advantage into a full point
giving Anish giri the victory in the
tournament we review the live standings
and ishqiri has completed the tournament
with a score of eight and a half
historically a score of nine has been
necessary in most cases to win the
tournament outright this might be an
exception if Notre back is stopped at
the Gates of Heaven here by Jordan van
Forest who has won this tournament in
2021 and now has another chance to put
his fingerprints all over the final
standings this is the magic of a
tournament like Titus steal those in the
bottom half of the tournament standings
can very much impact the situation at
the top they can and they have and they
will and Jordan that Forest very well
might
and we need to turn right into that game
because Jordan Fun Forest can do his
compatriot proud he can earn him the
title by taking down Abdul zatar of and
we are into an end game where black is
significantly better those pawns stuck
on dark squares for white on E5 and G5
the E5 Pawn is already in sight of the
Knight on C6 and if that Knight drops
back to d8 into F7 maybe black will just
win that pawn on G5 very directly it is
moved 37 uh black has a few moves to
make the time Patrol but it's white who
has the worst position and is in time
trouble Dania this could get out of hand
before we reach the time control
it can but Jordan Jordan has to resist
the temptation to to do something
drastic to play moves that objectively
ruin his position but set superficial
traps he has to stick to objectivity
because Notre back has shown the ability
to defend with iron clad resilience and
in cold-blooded fashion so yes he has
four minutes yes you want to pose
practical problems to White before the
time control but by and large you want
to keep the pawn structure as it is you
want to try to get your knight to F7 I'm
looking at moves like Rook H4 moves that
accentuate the pressure without
fundamentally changing the nature of the
position what do you think about that
idea Rook H4 looks like a nice useful
move just advancing your Rook uh keeping
at night on F6 stuck in place I really
like the idea of bringing the Knight to
F7 as well uh there's just nothing wrong
with it it's near your king it's a
compact position and how is white gonna
deal with the threat of Knight takes G5
look at this Knight on F6 by the way it
looks like a stallion it's protected by
two pawns it can't be kicked out of
there but also can't move so that means
it's a bystander to the rest of the
action and Knight d8 to F7 hits both E5
and G5 you only have one Rook if the
Rook slides the G file you lose E5 if
your Rook stays in the e-file you lose
G5 so you're going to lose upon I think
pretty directly in the event of Knight
d8 F7
then I don't have six it's like a king
stuck in its Palace during a revolution
chaos is going on around it it looks
night nice it looks night it's
surrounded by its loyal guards and yet
it cannot impact the game or its
surroundings in any appreciable way that
Knight on F6 shows us that we have to
look past appearances in chess the night
it looks beautiful by the positional
rules of Chess it seems to be the
strongest piece on the board but if
Black's Knight reaches F7 then you
cannot even compare these two knights
they are two completely different pieces
and how crazy is it I'm jumping the gun
here a little bit that in each giri's
Knight wins him the game and if Jordan
successfully gets his Knight around to
F7 then his stallion as you called it
will very likely win him his game
oh my gosh and
um this is would be tragic for
nordireback Abdus Atara because he's
been leading the tournament from the
start he got off to a hot start by
beating Richard report in the first
round with the black pieces so for Notre
back he won in rounds one he won two
more games in rounds four and five no in
round five he beat Magnus Carlson he
then beat Arjun Eric icy with the black
piece as well so he's had three wins of
his first seven games with the black
pieces another win with white that was a
five and a half out of seven start but
you could see he had four wins overall
heading into today's game they happened
in the first seven rounds in the back
half of the tournament he was held to a
draw in every single game now there's no
shame in that look at the list of
opposition aronian kymer dingley Ren
Anish giri Wesley so these are
superstars The Who's Who of the top
level of Chess and Jordan Von Forest the
lowest rated player in the tournament
coming in and Nordic had the white
pieces and that might be the first
person to hand him a defeat now Abdus
atarb is such an easy player to root for
he gives it his all he is always
fighting he said he doesn't get
emotional but this is a big moment for
him it would be the biggest individual
tournament success of his career in
classical chess he won the world rapid
Championship he won the Olympiad gold
for his team for his country and had a
great performance there but to beat
Magnus Carlson to win an event ahead of
him and to hold off a surging and he's
Geary that would be a really really
amazing finish but right now Donya I
think I'm worried about his position he
E5 G5 pawns both so weak
now it's important to clarify that if
Notre back is able to hold the draw
we're not even talking about the
scenario anymore in which norterbeck
wins obviously anything is possible this
is just what haven't we seen just in the
last hour but if motorbike holds the
draw then he doesn't win the tournament
outright he will go into a tiebreaker
against anishikiri so he will have to
find some more gas in the tank but that
is way into the future he is not
thinking about that he is not thinking
about Geary or anything except how to
defend and hold a draw in this position
Robert but I'm with you I think his
chances they aren't huge at the same
time let's not forget his game against
Vincent kymer arguably that end game was
even worse objectively it was lost
everybody was shoveling dirt on him and
Notre back calmly found some incredible
study-like ideas he defended that end
game for 40 moves and ultimately pulled
out
an incredible improbable draw so he has
a track record of Defending bad end
games he's done it in previous
tournaments as well he has to hunker
down he has to stay composed he has to
avoid scolding himself for getting into
this position in the first place you do
all of that after the tournament you do
all of that back at home with your coach
and your laptop right now you need to
focus on the task at hand you need to
roll up your sleeves and you need to
avoid all further blunders that right
now Jordan he's literally rolled up his
sleeves he's got nine minutes and he
also has a couple of important moves to
make Knight d8 though Robert the more I
look at it the more you say it the more
I like it yeah it looks very promising
for Jordan and just want to give a quick
shout out to the over 60 000 people
spending their Sunday watching the Tata
steel Masters across twitch and YouTube
right now in each Geary in the lead he
has eight and a half points and he has
concluded his tournament after 13 Rounds
your back Abdus answered the final round
with a half point lead if he wins this
game the tournament Championship is his
if he draws the game we will get tie
breaks later and if he loses anishikiri
the Dutch Legend will become Champion
the second Dutch Champion since 2021
when Jordan Von Forest the man you see
on the screen in front of you he won the
tournament so I think Donna we will see
Knight d8 we will see Knight to F7 the
E5 and G5 pounds are weak so the
question becomes how does white save the
position I think a timely C2 to C3 will
help out the problem is you cannot
easily play the move C3 without a rook
landing on H2 with check you need to
start creating a pass Pawn for yourself
that is what white has going for him a
three on two Advantage all the way on
the Queens side so you play C3 you try
to trade then play B4 try to create a
pass Pawn to distract Black's pieces but
you can't do that with Rooks on the
board yeah Jordan has arranged as Queen
side Pawns in ideal fashion slowing down
as much as possible White's process of
creating queen-sided counter play which
as you're mentioning isn't gonna even
get off the ground if you allow a check
on H2 so as we're talking about the meta
narratives here and about the importance
of staying calm you can stay calm all
you want but you still need a concrete
defense against the threat of Knight F7
and Knight takes G5 and at this point as
Jordan has spent now I think well over
10 minutes on this move I'm curious what
it is exactly that he's afraid of after
Knight d8 is it some sort of Peace
sacrifice on D5 this is an idea that
I've been eyeing for a while Robert
after Knight d8 white could try the
devious Bishop F3 and Jordan is about to
play a move I don't want to get us too
far into the weeds but just really
quickly I think this is crucial to an
understanding of the position if we
could bring up an analysis board Knight
to d8 Bishop to F3 and if you
nonchalantly Waltz your knight over to
F7 I think Bishop takes D5 generates
drawing counter play because after Ed
Knight takes D5 suddenly Black's King is
at a loss for squares King E6 walks into
a fork of White's own that Bishop on A6
is picked off if you go elsewhere then
White's Pawn advances to E6 and even
without any further calculation there is
no way that Jordan is going to opt for a
position like this now you could ask
where can he deviate well obviously it's
after Bishop F3 he can respond with a
prophylactic move Bishop B7 but there's
an old friend Robert who can come
knocking at Jordan's door and that is C3
now this move is possible evil bar hates
it though but I thought because
there's BC and D4 how easy is this to
miss yeah very clearly very easy because
you're a brilliant technician and in the
moment it didn't catch your eye but that
is something that Jordan run for us will
see and I think the reason why he's
thinking right now is because he could
play instead of Knight to d8 uh if he
chooses to uh keep the Knight on C6 he
can play the move Rook H2 to start in
the live board so if we just return to
that uh sorry I mean back in the wrong
position he can play Rook H2 and he
frees whites pieces and threatened
Knight to D4 next as well so at Bishop
D3 the policy 2 is pinned so he's
thinking do I go active here or do I
just go right ahead and win these pawns
on G5 or E5 and he did just play Knight
d8 he Retreats tonight
and he has made the decision to maneuver
his Knight over to F7 and listen Robert
I've taken a page out of your book I'm
more than happy to admit my mistakes
because when you make mistakes you reach
a better understanding of the position
we already saw Richard report commit one
losing blunder how easy is it for
another blunder to occur in this game
especially with mutual time pressure
either side could miss a tactic but I
still think that motorbikes should start
his defensive effort with Bishop F3 and
after black slides the bishop back to B7
in that position maybe there is a way to
prepare C3 maybe you could drop the
bishop one more Square down to E2 but I
think any successful defensive path here
for Notre back will have to be
associated with the formation of active
counter play on The Queen side and the
only way that you can do that is by
finding a way to push this Pawn through
to C3
yeah and you look at the clock right now
in your back abuse attack down to three
minutes and 40 seconds he has three
moves to make a minute per move is not
easy given how complicated this position
looks black is threatening to go Knight
F7 and win a pawn you may say so what
it's just one Pawn no that's not just
any pawn because once you win the G5
Pawn you go back to F7 and you're gonna
pick off the E5 Pawn next so this
position could end up being lost for
white in say five moves so that is why
abusive charge needs to find a correct
continuation at this moment he needs to
find a break for himself with C3 and
then eventually B4 because if he doesn't
get that black is gonna pick off the
pawns and just win this game without
serious Challenge from White I could not
have phrased it better he is running out
of time literally and figuratively with
two minutes on the clock he has to find
a source of counter playing he has to do
it on the very next move as you're
saying Knight F7 could simply end the
game if white starts crumbling at the
seams on the king side you cannot afford
to lose both of these pawns unless you
figure out a way to create some sort of
cataclysmic counter play on the other
side of the board I really feel that
Bishop F3 is mandatory for white let's
see if notibed comes up with it as I'm
talking seconds precious golden seconds
continue to evaporate off the tournament
leaders clock he is down to two minutes
Robert and a move has still not been
made
wow he needs to make a move ASAP Bishop
F3 with the sacrifice on D5 I think
that's a difficult move to play but I
don't see anything else C3 as we
mentioned Rook H2 check that move is
slammed on the board the king is forced
away from the protection of the Pawn on
C3 so for no you're back if he's gonna
play C3 he needs to cover his second
rank maybe there's an argument for
Bishop E2 but I think that you swap
Bishops very quickly put your knight F7
and black just first to the punch you
are winning the G5 Pawn you'll bring
your knight back you'll try to go up to
the E5 Pawn
oh no this is really bad news for
upduces so I feel for him honestly I'm
watching him we're commenting on the
game and I don't root for anybody but
I'm sitting here being like I just don't
want to see him throw away tournament
Victory on the last day after the
Magnificent tournament he's had it's
just kind of heartbreak it is it is no
matter who you're rooting for no matter
where you are from and yes Notre back
has displayed composure and
cold-bloodedness and well-roundedness in
this tournament far beyond his years
composure that has only acquired
sometimes by age 40. as he slides the
bishop back to E2 and I would not peg
this loss if in fact he loses on a loss
of composure Jordan is just playing like
a beast in this end game now Robert
Bishop E2 what do you make of this is
this another mistake can no can Jordan
just take and go Knight F7 here uh it's
what he's going to do but I I wasn't
expecting the evaluation part to drop
this much uh black has to take on E2
because you move your Bishop away then
white goes Bishop D3 and targets the G6
Pawn that is not what you want you need
to act quickly you need to be precise if
you're Jordan you swap Bishops and that
is what he just hasn't done nobody back
quickly the former World rapid Champion
he is showing off his speech skills he
quickly takes back and now the Knight F7
Knight F7 goes right after G5 and done
yet I'm not seeing it here for Abdus
atarb I think his pawns are being picked
off one by one they do and I think the
reason he traded Bishops is indeed I
sound like a broken record but I don't
see a single other source of counter
play I think he is going to play C3 and
that is going to be his 40th move the
problem is that after the pawns are
swapped he still hasn't created a pass
Pawn he wants to play B4 but more but
the problem is that that King on C3 is a
Sitting Duck and it can be targeted by a
well-timed rook check on H3 that Rook
it's been on H4 it's been all over the
age file it's back to home base right
now and it could make one more Sally to
H3 in order to knock the King off of C3
delaying B4 by a couple more moves and
Jordan will obviously take those moves
to eliminate both of those funds there's
no question now that Jordan's position
is objectively winning whether it's
completely winning that can be debated
but once he makes move 40 Robert those
50 minutes could not arrive at a better
time for Jordan Ben for us because he
can make sure with every move that he is
eliminating notrex counter play that he
is double checking all of his options
and Jordan he needs these 50 minutes a
lot more than notorbeck does at this
point and he will get them
yeah because the position is objectively
it looks like teetering on the edge of a
win for black so with extra time Jordan
can calculate and we want to remind
everybody that Jordan did falter a day
ago against Anish gear but that's a very
different type of position it was sharp
there were tactics everywhere
checkmating threats for both sides and
then we got to an end game that ended up
being level so this is a very different
type of position we see the Knight about
to hop over to F7 Jordan he is not
making the move just yet but he knows
that he has the advantage as he looks
over at his clock he has just four
minutes remaining but it's about to beat
move 40 and the good news for black is
his 40th move likely Knight takes G5 he
gets to make a move steal a pawn get the
extra time and continue to put Nordic
abusatar of under pressure and Notre
Jordan's time management in this game in
particular in the last stretch has been
Exquisite I just have to commend him on
the restraint that he has showed he has
left himself with exactly the amount of
time you want to have to play the final
move four minutes it's better than
having one minute it's just enough to
make a well-informed decision if a
curveball is thrown at you the problem
is that I don't see a single curveball
that Notre big can throw he can only
defend one of these pawns at the same
time and Robert to bring us back to a
point that we made previously what heals
White's defensive chances in this game
is just that Knight on F6 it has no
prospects it is imprisoned and moreover
it simply cannot contribute in the
defensive effort in any appreciable way
to the contrary it's actually blocking
the f file stopping white from creating
counter play on the king side there's C3
it's the only thing Notre by can do and
Jordan's gonna play P takes E3 he has no
choice and that will be move 40. and
that's instructive because you can't
allow white to take on B4 because it is
a pawn trade it's one for one that
sounds good but you give white the
outermost past Pawn black because you're
gonna have to focus your attention
stopping a pass Pawn you don't do not
want to be an a pawn unless you're
getting something for it so he takes on
C3 he'll take on G5 and I'm only
noticing for the first time Dania that
the players Jordan in a white shirt with
the black pieces nobody back with a
black shirt with the white pieces wow
things have been reversed things have
been up in the air but for Abdus this is
also a switch based on the performance
he's had throughout the event he has
been dominant he beat Magnus Carlson he
beat Richard report in the first game uh
he has been looking just super powerful
every single round he's barely been in
trouble uh he beat Parham that was such
a masterful display of restraint and
then he gets to this last round with the
lead and Jordan run Forrest from the
very opening when he made move seven
Pawn to H5 he was showing that he is
willing to fight he is not going to just
let this game be a simple draw or
anything of the sort he wanted to fight
and credit to Jordan van Forrest and
Nordic Stills chances we don't want to
say this game is over and a big reason
why is his Pawn is going to become a
passer on the queen side is going to be
an a pawn that pawn is very far away
from the rest of the action so how does
nerdybeck draw a game like this he if
many of the pawns get traded and he has
to give up his Knight for the remaining
pawns a rook and a knight versus a rook
that is not winning material advantage
so that is a dream it is far from
reality but if somehow abduce attraction
give up his Knight and get rid of all
the pawns then he would have some
chances to draw Jordan knows better he
will not allow that
and every time we get into a situation
where the evil bar throws an
overwhelming assessment minus three
minus four minus five I always like to
point out that you can have many
different types of minus four positions
you can have a tactical -4 position such
as the one that Jordan had in the
previous round against nishkiri how does
that differ from an end game like this
from this minus well differs in one
crucial way in that game against Anish
giri Jordan had to find an only move in
order to preserve the advantage the
moment he missed that move the advantage
halved you lost its Lion's Share and
with another mistake the game
immediately equalized in this end game
he has a a much wider birth he can
commit an inaccuracy and he will still
probably be winning but more importantly
the path to Victory is so much more
clear there is a trail that is nicely
laid out with brick there are arrows
pointing him in the right direction and
some of those arrows include bringing
the Knight back to F7 he's got no other
choice that will indeed threaten to take
the other quantity five and the other
arrow is that the move B4 is always
going to be met with Rook to H3 check
the issue isn't so much the evaluation
itself as the Simplicity the relative
Simplicity of the winning process for
your invent Forest that said Robert
anything is possible we are experienced
commentators we have seen it all and I'm
not just saying it we really have we've
experienced it all and given how crazy
the turnarounds today have been let's
not call anything done let's not shovel
dirt on anybody let's sit back and enjoy
the show as long as it lasts
well right now we will enjoy a brief
break the players have reached the next
time control that means North America
has time to think try to find a way out
of this so while he does that Donnie and
I will take a short breather stretch our
legs come back and we will cover the
final action here in round 13 of the
Tata steel Chess Masters we'll be right
back
[Music]
do you wish playing a chess game with a
friend was as easy as sending them a
text well good news now it is with
chess.com's new iMessage app you can
start and play a game directly in
iMessage your friend doesn't even need a
chess.com account it's just tap and play
head over to go.chess.com iMessage or
use the command iMessage in chat to
learn more
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
s
for this cozy coastal town the holiday
season isn't over
in fact the most wonderful time of the
year has really just begun there we go
the tournament leader holds Wesley so to
a drug he has impressed all of us
once again vikon Zay starts the new year
as the center of the chess Universe this
year as host of the 85th taught to steal
chess tournament
a magnet for the best players in the
game some recognize the Masters field of
2023 as its strongest in recent memory
of course it helps when eight-time Tata
steel chess champion Magnus Carlson is
back Magnus is going baseball if Magnus
plays like this the rest of the way who
knows what can happen the world's number
one looks to further cement his legacy
in this event and the game's history
chasing Magnus will be amongst the best
in chess several have been crowned
Champion here before some have even
shocked the world in doing so
and don't leave out those poised to
capture their first Tata title what a
fight Geary how to give it his all
because he was on the verge of losing
and he managed to survive
although winter Tata steel chess is also
known as the place new stars come to
bloom Magnus one here is a teenager this
year's event has its fair share of young
players on the rise each hoping to
follow in Carlson's footsteps he
continues to lead this event and he is
just a teenager
the Dutch refer to Tata steel as The
Wimbledon of chess for 85 years in
running this tournament continues to be
steeped in Prestige and Legacy and does
so again in this welcoming Little Dutch
town by the sea
mine brynden it's the 85th edition of
the Tata steel chess tournament let's
make chess history together
after 13 Rounds it all comes down to the
board on the screen Jordan Von Forest he
controls both his opponent's Destiny and
that of Anish giri because Anish giri
who entered the round in second place a
half Point behind their dear back Abdus
atarov he was able to win his game over
Richard's report it was a finish that
was aided by a huge oversight a blunder
by Richard's report but still and each
Gary played an excellent game in an
excellent tournament and now he finds
himself a half Point ahead of abdusitar
as a dusatar of tries to find a miracle
draw here Dania I mean we see it on the
leaderboard it's clear no you're back he
entered the round ahead now he's behind
he needs a draw
he needs a draw and a draw will Propel
him not to a tournament Victory but to a
tiebreaker to a rapid tiebreaker against
Anish giri but at this point he might
have been disappointed if he told him
before the round that you would get a
tiebreaker now he would ask for nothing
more it would be the ultimate Miracle
one of the craziest miracles of his
career if he achieves this draw and gets
himself into the tiebreaker Anish Gary
along with the entire Chess World along
with tens of thousands of Chess fans
over 60 000 of you watching Jordan van
Forest attempt to convert this position
and put his fingerprints his
fingerprints indelibly on the outcome of
the tournament Anish Gary is going to
give Jordan a very big hug if you can
convert this end game and he's going to
send two bottles of Dom Perignon
straight to Jordan event Forest hotel
room the bill is gonna be on me Anish
giri will say
and you see Jordan van Forest entered
the round you know currently live
results he's in 12th Place and with a
win he'd jump up into a tie for ninth so
it would be a great finish for him uh
parhamaksudu by the way still playing
against levada Ronin our generic I see
facing off against Magnus Carlson but
all eyes are on nordierbeck Abdul
sitarov the teenager from Uzbekistan who
has won the world rapid championship in
2021. he won the Olympiad gold medal for
his country of Uzbekistan in the 2022
Olympiad in Chennai India he wins this
tournament if somehow he wins this game
that is not likely to happen it is
almost impossible at this point so if he
draws the game he gets onto a Ty break
it's a niche Anish giri watching Jordan
vent for us came closely is rooting for
his friend his compatriot like he's
never rooted for him before and he hopes
that Abdus tarv loses it's not great to
root against somebody I know he that and
he's here has a ton of respect for
abusotaro but right now he wants nothing
more in order back to lose this game to
Jordan Von Forest
and as we delve into this end game uh as
we ask ourselves the question of whether
uh Notre bag does in fact have Miracle
drawing chances I'll just close off our
discussion of this incredible young man
by saying that he's had a very unique
career trajectory yesterday I studied
his uh rating progress and I found a
very interesting trajectory indeed a
story of Peaks and valleys a story of
constantly overcoming plateaus and
adversity notrex started off with a
rating of 1930 in 2011. he was stuck on
1900 for three years until 2014 after
which he finally crossed to 2000 he
climbed all the way to 2465 within a
year then he drops all the way back down
a hundred points to the 2300s where he
stayed for another year then he
laboriously climbed back to 2400 made
his way over the hump to 2500 back he
went over 2600 he got stuck there for
another three years and only recently in
September of 2022
about five months or so ago Notre
becomes a tour of climbed that barrier
the barrier that so many struggle with
over the hump to 27-13 he went and he
has solidified himself among super Grand
Masters I think it is safe to say
whether he draws or loses this game
Robert that he is there to stay he is
going to be a member of the 2700 club
for long and his career is only on the
upswing
yes it is he's had a great turn no
matter what the final result is and
Jordan run Forrest does have time on his
clock once he makes his move and the
time will be added to 50 minutes that
you get after reaching move 40. so of
course he has not lost on time he's
still calculating at the board over
there uh but with Rook H3 check on tap
Donya you kick the king away you take
this Pawn on B4 why is your not just
winning a second pawn and with it okay
could just be a pretty clean victory
well let's bring up an analysis board
and uh take this move apart Rook H3
check is almost certainly going to
happen obviously Jordan has the time to
double triple quadruple quadruple check
uh whichever move he wants to play the
king is almost certainly going to drop
back to B2 and you're saying that after
a takes before this Pawn is going
exactly nowhere because it can be easily
tailed by blackstroke let me try
something
let me try
hey yeah the move Works C2
okay so you're trying to try to go for
Rook C7 check
and then what is the question so let's
say I leave you to figure that out yeah
I figured you're doing that um let's say
I get greedy I'm gonna go Rook A3 just
trying to win your Pawn I'm like you
haven't had your hands a little bit you
haven't had enough you've taken B4 G5
you want more okay I'll give a check on
C7
okay so I can run to f8 or to deal it's
going to d8 it seems like I can run away
more easily from that side
okay
now I'm actually going to figure out
what it is that I wanted to do when I
gave the check on C7 I didn't exactly
know there's a check on D7 it leads
nowhere I could go after the G6 Pawn but
that's way too cumbersome you're gonna
take A4 and go after E5 perhaps white
should try Rook to A7 because this pawn
and A4 is really the only
Pawn I think that could deliver any sort
of Miracle safe but eval bar dropping
down even further apparently White had
some way to to muddy the waters Robert
and and this is like totally inhuman
apparently the best move here is Rook B7
and after Rook 64 just to play the
anti-climactic king B3
yeah but I'm sure when the engine gains
depth it will say that black is winning
I mean you see the evob bar is pretty
heavily in Black's favor anyway uh but I
get why the black king is stuck and if
the white king takes on B4 and makes a
Mad Dash into the position King cc5 King
D6 there could be an attack against the
king they're not too many pawns
remaining and I said this a while back
that if white is able to sacrifice the
Knight for the remaining pawns rook and
Knight versus Rook is not a winning end
game so we see Jordan's time has been
added to his clock he has over 51
minutes uh this is a great position for
him yeah he's gonna take this one I
believe and we have been
scoring the placement of that Knight on
F6 we have been highlighting every
deficiency the one virtue of the knights
placement apart from uh allowing these
Rook checks which could potentially if
the king joins the attack allows some
sort of counter play against Black's
King that Knight is guarding the G4
square and while in seemingly
insignificant black is not going to win
this game by accumulating extra pawns
black is going to win this game by
promoting one of his extra pawns to a
queen and that g-pawn is actually going
to be quite hard to push the d-pawn is
close to White's King but the G4 square
is guarded by White Knight so even after
Jordan gains two or even three extra
pawns he is going to have to keep
White's peace tandem at Bay and he is
going to have to figure out which of his
past pawns he wants to push and how he
wants to break through the sort of last
magino line of defense that uh Notre
Beckham desotorov is going to try to
build Rook H3 Chuck is on the board
I think ultimately that Jordan should
not be overly concerned about the A4
Pawn because we're likely to see King B2
politics before I believe that he can
just go after the E5 pawn and once he
grabs that like when the Knight wraps
around F3 into E5 then I can hop around
with checks let's not forget that if
black gets to keep that B4 Pawn it's a
passer that's quite far Advanced so you
shouldn't just be afraid of your
opponent's past a pawn the newly created
Pawn you should also think well I have a
passport on my own do I really have to
be scared of your opponent A4 I don't
think the answer is yes
agreed completely and to transform your
point into a concrete remark in the line
we were just analyzing I don't have to
make the moves again but I'll just point
out abstractly that after the king drops
back and black takes on B4 white plays
uh a move like A5 you're right the black
does not have to automatically go Rook
to A3 and get behind the pawn at all
costs that pawn is a long way to go
until promotion blacken also as you were
indicating activate his own Knight and
the B4 Pawn is also a passer it actually
happens to be Black's most far Advanced
passer so black could try to do the
white skin what I was trying to do to
yours except something tells me Jordan
is going to be just a tad more
successful he could try to get this
Knight around let's say to D4 and then
deliver a rook check to B3 I'm throwing
it all out a lot of moves here but I'm
essentially trying to co-sign your point
that Jordan needs to take his time and
if in fact notabeck creates a past a
pawn Jordan should not immediately rush
to eliminate it with Rook to A3 he
should put some thought into some other
candidate moves yeah I think he's going
to bring his Knight up to F3 get that E5
Pawn that just frees up his pieces
because the Knight on G5 it's so upon
there now let's bring it to help the
rest of the board and yeah I feel like
you're he's going to use all of his
forces and what a game this has been
from him seriously impressive chess uh
from Jordan Von Forest uh who many
people would say what does he have to
play for he's out of the running for
first he takes every game seriously he
fights he tries his best and other
players are doing the same because this
is the matchup for the tournament
victory of dusitarov if he was able to
win this game he would have taken first
but there are still two other games in
progress and it goes to show that these
top players they give it they're all
they're still fighting Magnus Carlson
he's still in the playing Hall in fact
he's right there behind abusitarv I
think and he is playing against Arjun
eragisi so if we zoom out from this game
for just a moment we will see that we
still have two other games going Parham
maksuda by the way
clean pawns against the Von aronian it's
a credit to the Iranian star he is going
to reach his highest ever rating he's
going to finish with a plus score he is
winning against the vonaronian and
Magnus Carlson the bottom left over
there he has won his peace back for
those two pawns and he still has a pass
Pawn so Dunya Magnus working his King's
Indian magic this looks like a great
position for him it does indeed I think
we should take a closer look and we
promise to keep you abreast of the
developments in our main game but given
that move 40 has been made
it's safe to say that the pace is going
to slow down a little bit so I think we
just have a couple minutes here to go
around the horn world champions game is
also important it may not dictate the
first place but Magnus Carlson's
comeback has been incredibly impressive
and a win in the final round will really
cap off what has been an amazing second
half of the tournament for Magnus
Carlson not without its own
disappointments not without draws with
the white pieces and very disappointing
result in the last round but his ability
to just like win on Demand with black is
it's Unique it's incredible apparently
you're in bed Forest took a page out of
his book but can Magnus Carlson complete
the effort so my question to you Robert
how winning is this material is actually
equal believe it or not white has a four
on three on the queen side that could
not matter less as white is not even
close to creating a past Pawn but how
decisive is this Pawn on G4
it's not just the pawn though it's also
the the problem for the white king
Black's king after the move Knight F7
here looks pretty safe to my eyes and on
the other side of the board I feel like
that white King on B1 is In Harm's Way
and for black you can eventually bring
your queen up to H4 maybe even now Queen
H4 looks pretty good you're just
supporting your Pawn the King on B1 is
in trouble the E4 pawns a bit loose the
bishop on F6 is the best minor piece on
the board the bishop on F3 is maybe just
as good helping the G four pawns start
advancing no I think that Magnus has an
overwhelming advantage and the eval bar
doesn't tell the story of just how much
better it is for him easier to play and
the world champions time management is
talked about very infrequently and
that's a shame because time management
in general is a great skill it's an
underrated skill I mentioned evaluation
of positions that is another skill that
Magnus himself uh mentioned in a recent
podcast he believes uh he has mastered
this skill to a much greater extent than
some of his super GM colleagues his time
management is almost always Stellar he
has left himself with almost an hour to
figure out the subtleties of this
position and that is standard Fair
Magnus Carlson rarely finds himself in a
situation where he's got to Blitz out
six complicated Moves In order to make
time control but the Magnus approach in
this position I think is in fact to
first and foremost drop the Knight back
to F7 controlling a nice stronghold on
E5 and on the following move
like you said the queen comes down to H4
black can simply push the pawn down to
G2 or alternatively go after White's
King with let's say a queen infiltration
to F2 can Arjun whip up anything
resembling counter play on The Queen
side I feel like the only way for him to
even try would be C5 but what does that
even threaten once the Knight sits on F7
Robert you're not even threatening to
capture D6
and you're opening up your own King
right so you know Knight F7 C5 B takes
C5 we swap pawns that black queen may
just end up on B8 and deliver a
Checkmate in the near future I just feel
like the position is falling apart so
quickly for Arjun and if he tries to
gallop with his Knight forward to B5
look at the bishop on F6 especially when
the Knight goes back to F7 and Magnus
just played the move if you go Knight B5
to go after C7 the queen slides all the
way over to A8 threatening Queen A1 and
yeah it is misdirection right you
thought the crew is going to H4 now it
slides to eight and how are you stopping
Queen A1 check Knight C3 back I don't
think so you just give me that pawn yeah
Queen A1 is going to be devastating well
as Yasser likes to say and yes sir
paraphrasing his old friend Nikolai
minnov at least I'll die with a full
stomach the Knight has captured a Pawn
on C7 at least you'll die with a threat
on the board of 98 but the Checkmate is
going to come after the check on A2 and
then mate I need to know beautiful mate
with the Bishops crisscrossing all of
the key diagonals and controlling the
important squares this is like the first
game in which the winning side's Knight
isn't directly involved in the winning
process Jordan's Knight anisha's night
Magnus is Knight on F7 ain't too shabby
either as it controls the crucial E5
Square so that's out of the question for
Arjun Knight B5 is futile it's
counterproductive if he doesn't play
that I can't even find a way for him to
tread water he's almost in zubong in a
weird kind of way moving the queen from
the first drink allows a check on H1
moving the Knight allows Queen A8 moving
one of the pawns weakens his King side
moving the bishop allows the pawn
forward what does he even do here
I have no idea
and I don't understand it was a minus
one one point yeah I feel like
practically this is just yes nothing yes
what do you even do there's no threat
that Knight on F7 is such a great
defender it covers the E5 Square If you
ever think of pushing E5 it covers H6 if
the queen moves away from H shade so
you're never gonna get a check there and
G5 is an important score to cover in
case the bishop leaves there's no Queen
coming up into the uh enemy territory so
I just feel like black is everything
nice and Compact and for Arjun here even
this move is hard to play
yeah there's just not much to say here I
mean it's it's a simple position Magnus
Carlson has had a spotty track record of
converting advantages but you cannot
compare the technical task in front of
him here with uh that of his game
against prognananda in the previous
round there were a lot more pieces on
the board the position was a lot more
double edged there were so many things
different about that game but Arjun
given his due he has played the top
engine move Knight to B5 the idea
actually is to meet Queen A8 with Queen
A3 it is so hard to convince yourself
that a queen trade doesn't lose on the
spot but apparently it's the only way to
keep drawing chances alive
that must lose though right if we trade
Queens I mean I think it's a very
forcing variation should I swap Queen
yeah just boom boom see Queen three if
you take the queen
and Bishop E5 even comes to mind as a
way to just try to push your Pawn
how is this not plus 17
000. it's probably on the you know the
depth isn't you know high enough where
it probably is winning for black uh but
it you know it's just gonna take a while
to get there you know it just seems like
a it's too easy for black that's also
the biggest problem
if I were to play Devil's Advocate there
is the Obscure concept of sacking the
bishop for G4 and then if you could
guarantee that you win C7 black isn't
left with all that many pawns obviously
if I could eliminate all of flex Queen
side pawns Knight versus knight and
Bishop is a dead draw but that is
obviously a total counterfacture that is
a very unlikely reality
I agree I mean even without delving
deeper into this end game
Arjun will have to convince himself that
this is his best chance and if he does
that kudos to him but his work just
begins in this end game
no it's I just don't believe in the
position so Arjun will have to find
something uh miraculous in order to
survive this game against Magnus Carlson
and we saw the interview with Magnus
earlier in the show where he discussed
the fact that he he's playing for first
he's always motivated Huff to find some
internal motivation to play this final
round I would not have guessed that he
wasn't playing for first place based on
this game uh from the very early stages
he decided to pick up the gauntlet to
play into the king's Indian to go for an
attack and now he's in a position with
great chances for him so we'll leave
Magnus and Arjun here I believe Magnus
will play Queen eight looks really
strong for him but if we zoom out of
this one for a second I think that
another player who has the black pieces
the three games we have left all of the
players of black pieces are doing well
Hara maksulu is just dominating he is up
two pawns there's not even much to
really speak about because it's two
clean extra pawns for the player from
Iran I don't see any hope for Lavon
aronian there and so I think that at
Parham we can safely say we'll go on to
win this game something would have to go
very wrong for him the plan for him is
so depressingly simple he just pushes
his connected pastors you don't want to
do it indiscriminately you want to make
sure to limit the counter play afforded
by White's tandem he goes for a very
precise move Knight G6 to E7 nitrate I
think would result in immediate
resignation obviously his King on G8 is
in no threat of getting Perpetual it has
the H7 Square you can't even come up
with a hypothetical Perpetual
construction Lavon could refrain from
the nitrate he probably will play a move
like Knight C7 I think Barham is getting
his Knight around into the center and
this is one of those games Robert where
resignation could come now it could come
10 moves from now but the result is
really not in question
no it's not so if something gets
interesting there we'll bring our
attention back to the game uh but of
course all eyes are on abdusitara
against Jordan Von Forest it seems like
your idea with the Rook coming to C2 has
been played uh by Notre back and if we
bring up that board I just want to show
one mistake that can be made here
because there's something that chess
players are taught they said when you're
out
is it Rook C3 yes go ahead yes right
when you're up material trade pieces so
Rook C3 says I'm up two pawns so let me
trade off the Rooks but after Rook takes
C3 and pawn takes C3 the king of course
will take back and now white has this
outside pass Pawn so unless black can
very quickly go ahead and grab the pawn
it's gonna take a long journey and in
the meantime white is going to go after
Black's pawns G6 and E6 are potential
targets so still maybe some chances to
win this game for black but objectively
you see the evaluation it shows that
white would have a draw with best play
and I'll just tack onto your point by
saying that Knight E4 in this position
hey I'm forcing a pawn end game up a
pawn after 94 D4 yes technically black
is up upon but you can see the Eva bar
inverting their white of course is
winning after the prosaic King D4 and
this is a classic winning plan black has
to expend countless Tempe to stop the a
pawn with this King and in the time that
he does so white will simply sop up all
of Black's isolated Pawns in the center
first D4 then G6 and finally E6 so
Jordan will not play Rook C3 but that is
a very instructive line a trade of Rooks
is good in some circumstances but in
this case his Rook is actually more
active than its counterpart I think the
main decision he has to make is between
the move that we started our analysis
with as I go back to the live board here
for a second and that is Rook H3 to A3 I
would argue that that is the most
natural move there is also as I
mentioned later the possibility of
jumping into F3 with the Knight and this
is what I'd like to briefly point out
after Knight F3 A5 things may appear a
little bit dangerous for black but if
you calculate one move further I don't
think there in fact I think you can just
take on E5 Robert I think you can also
play Knight D4
um eval bar did not like that move
probably Knight 65. oh because you're
going to C4 no this is just game over I
I didn't see the C4 Square this is this
this ends the game the Knight has to
move it has nowhere to move it's trapped
and even if it wasn't C4 within the game
it's just lost on so many levels here
yeah the B4 Pawn is a past Pawn it's not
just uh you know an extra pawn it is
very good work uh Jordan is playing
Geary shopping on his bed right now
I'm guessing Gary stayed in the turmoil
he's ready to buy Jordan a very nice
dinner uh they are friends they both are
from the Netherlands and so uh you know
this would be a huge victory for Anish
Geary he's not playing but Jordan could
do him the ultimate solid by beating
Abdus atarav and now the pawns are
collapsing Donna so let's see what white
can do how can you keep hope in this
position after Knight F3 maybe Knight G4
we said pushing a pawn doesn't quite
work so bring the Knight back to G4 at
least for the time being it protects
your Pawn on E5 and then the A5 Pawn can
push on the next turn
so Knight G4 is definitely an attempt I
have one more Bizarro ridiculous attempt
um which I'll offer after we deal with
Knight G4 I suppose that black snipe
will travel to D4 in this position and
the problem is that once you leave F6
the check on C7 is now entirely
innocuous after King D there's no
follow-up check
so is there anything here to muddy the
waters for white
no
right answer
just being honest yeah
the thing about this right you need to
get the actually let's show this this is
very instructive Rook C7 check
uh King f8 I'm gonna go the other way
for a second okay run away and then the
Knight goes into F6 oh
you know what I'm setting up and The
Rook goes to A3
so I'm gonna go get your apod yes
Rook on D7
and you say oh no my Pawn after Rook
takes A4 this is immediately a draw the
Knight H7 check Knight back to F6 this
is the perfect construction for white
the configuration of the piece is the
geometry is such that the King goes to
G8 of course you go back don't go to the
corner because you go to King h8 Rook H7
is check and mate the Knight covers G8
can't escape so you go to the other
direction with King E8 and then Knight
F6 check the Knight checks the king and
protects the Rook The Rook keeps control
of the d8 and E7 squares the King has to
go back to f8 and then we get a
repetition it's a little bit of a wheel
so that's one configuration that's just
probably useful to know for some of you
people I've had that in my games in the
past it's got akomsky uh that has
happened before so
yeah it's uh just something to keep in
mind how many hearts has that drawing
mechanism broken many many hearts
especially in Blitz and bullet when
these types of mechanisms are so easy to
miss and what makes uh that drawing idea
you just showed particularly powerful is
that it does not depend on any pawns you
could hypothetically set that up down
eight pawns and that's essentially what
Notre back is going to be down in this
position unfortunately Jordan is not
going to go to f8 he is going to go the
other way it's going to go to d8
attacking The Rook that is going to give
him the tempo that he needs to get his
Rook onto an ideal square and as I said
earlier I think you might refrain
entirely from pursuing the pawn on A4 if
we go down this line perhaps one final
time and then we will let Jordan do the
rest of the work after Rook C7 check
um sorry after Knight D4 she's gonna
play Rook C7 King d8 doesn't really
matter where the Rook goes let's say The
Rook goes over to B7 I think there are a
million ways to win this game and as I
look at it I'm I'm going to contradict
myself Robert I think the simplest in
human terms is to deliver a chakorowski
on B3 if you go to the C file then
what's going to await is probably
another check on see-through or maybe
the Knight will dial back and dive its
way into C4 if you go to the a file You
Are awaited by another check followed by
Rook takes A4 pre-move B3 deliver the
check on A2 and just easily promote the
pawn and you're playing with a huge
security blanket because even if tragedy
strikes and you lose the B Pawn you are
still essentially completely winning
with two extra pawns waiting for you in
case of heartbreak so just two or three
moves away is Jordan benforest from
really clinching without any Shadow of
Doubt the victory in this game
wow what an upset with the black pieces
no no direct producer looked Unstoppable
and if Jordan front Forest can conclude
this game in his favor that's what it's
looking like at the moment that means
that Anish giri you see the middle line
here Anish Gary clinches the tournament
with an Abdus atar of loss and that is
looking more and more likely by the move
even by abusot's facial expression
norderbeck is looking away usually he
stares through his opponent's soul I
think he can hardly bear to look at this
board and I do feel for him he played
such an amazing event he beat Magnus
Carlson he was looking like he was in
the best shape of anyone in the
tournament but it's easy to forget that
Anish giri throughout this event has
shown tremendous preparation uh he had
some spoiled opportunities himself there
were a few games where it felt like
Anish was in huge trouble one of those
games happened to be yesterday against
Jordan Von Forest where he was able to
survive with a draw so Anish giri also
deserves a lot of credit no matter who
ends up the tournament champion both of
those two players deserve to be at the
top
they do indeed and I'll repeat another
thing that I was saying a lot at the
start of this tournament which is that
anybody in this tournament is capable of
beating anybody else let's set form
aside let's set results aside and
raiding aside there's a reason that each
and every one of these players is
invited to Tata steel just the fact that
Jordan has one Tata steel before should
already be an indication beyond a shadow
of doubt that he is capable of beating
anyone on the planet he's beaten
virtually everyone on the planet at the
top of the rating list and he is just
going to tack on to his list of
achievements where they win in this game
yes Jordan has had a bit of a cold spell
in the last year year and a half he
hasn't had the kinds of spectacular
performances that he had in 2021 he's
dropped under 2 700 but put all of that
aside that is water under the bridge
that is just a bunch of noise because we
know that Jordan is capable in any
individual game of playing at a high
2700 level there is no coincidence that
Magnus Carlson selected specifically him
them to help him out in his opening
preparation for his world championship
match Magnus Carlson doesn't eeny meeny
miny mo and point his finger at just
about anyone Jordan is a creative
resilient tactically gifted player who
is capable of explosive performances in
tournaments but also as he has shown
today in individual games
and for Jordan this is going to be a
very big victory for him because he
started this tournament on Shaky Ground
it looked like he was going to suffer a
losing record and he will finish on even
with a win with a sub 500 record but
considering he was the lowest rated
player in the field that still is a
perfectly good result he headed into
today's game gaining one rating point
when he beats Nordic abusotarov that
adds another say six rating points it
means that he gets to go from number 50
something in the world to number 40 in
the world something around there so I
think that for Jordan Von Forest to be
able to bounce back from three
consecutive losses with the black pieces
in this tournament he lost around three
against five minute caruana he blundered
upon let's not forget that he blunted
upon in round one as well against Wesley
so he drew that game then he lost the
game to paramak sudlu then he lost to
pragnananda so he was actually dropping
pieces unfortunately for him
uncharacteristically throughout the
event and to be able to right the ship
better late than never it's been an
impressive second half for Jordan
it has and and to take this discussion
to kind of a meta level
um our job as as commentators I think
not to put words in your mouth is really
to accentuate the positive right to
focus on to celebrate the achievements
of each of these players to highlight
the incredible individual performances
and you know the praise when it's
repeated over and over again it might
seem saccharine it might seem uh
unauthentic and there is such a thing as
over hyping someone or making a mountain
out of a molehill uh or pretending that
a game decided by a massive blunder owes
all of the credit to the Victor and I
don't think we've done any of that in
reports game anishagiri played a
fantastic game but he was helped Along
by a massive decisive blunder by Richard
report true but in this specific
instance Robert I think Jordan van
Forest has just played a fantastic game
yes there were a lot of mistakes in this
end game by notorbeck but the way that
Jordan navigated the complexities
starting from around move 20 and ending
right up about now as he swings his
Knight to the correct square has really
been just a tour to force something
that's going to be analyzed repeated
something that Jordan is definitely
going to tell his grandkids about the
time that I beat in order to break up
just a tour of
in tata steel 2023 to completely
reshuffle the tournament standings
and it's kind of odd to give credit to
one move for what has been a long game
but if you don't mind done to putting
the position back on screen before he
made the move H4 it's been all about the
H Pawn for him he started on move seven
with that move H5 he's like I am going
to fight today and in this position uh
with H5 first yeah this was a big Choice
by him creating new territory in the
opening HIV was just a move that says
all right you're on your own and it just
was a fascinating choice but then later
uh when he made the move H4 he decided
that he was going to break free his Rook
on age shade uh the evaluation bar
slightly in White's favor but such a
crazy tactical Affair he was able to
cause nerdy back some problems he in
fact pushed up onto H3 later to get his
Rook active so it was all about Harry
the H Pawn wow Jordan use it's a great
effect I think he drew a beautiful
through line there it's such a nice way
such a refreshing way to conceptualize
and understand all of the twists and
turns that we saw in this game and we
saw a lot of them you could point to a
lot of other auxiliary factors but the
progress of that age Bond it's been
pushed three times at three very
appropriate moments and the final push
of that H1 opened up the entire King
side it is exactly what allowed Jordan
to have the Machinery to get to
motorbike's pawns on G5 and E5 Notre big
thought that those pawns would win in
the game when he positioned that Knight
on e4 ultimately they are most likely
what's going to end up doing him in and
they are following precisely the line
that we had analyzed they check on B3
and I think a check on A3 is forthcoming
and have we given up hope on another
brick yes
yes we have because that kid went to A2
it had gone to C1 in this position we
were talking earlier you don't want to
trade Rooks because it could be
dangerous uh but in that particular
position the king went to C1 uh you're
all good it came with the C1 then Rook
C3 check looks good enough you force the
Rooks off the board black has two full
extra pawns the king is close enough to
the a pawn so the reason it wasn't good
earlier was because the white King was
scooping up that pawn here you got to
keep it that means just a completely
winning end game for black it is indeed
and to the younger members of the chat
to players watching and hoping to gain
inspiration hoping to occupy the chairs
that Jordan and Forest and Northern sit
on right now it's great to have lofty
Ambitions but I always point out that
even the best players in the world they
always take their time notice that
Jordan hasn't made a single move really
in under a minute minute and a half even
if the move is painfully obvious as Rook
A3 check is they always double check
they always make sure that there isn't
anything better anything more decisive
they blunder check they never get too
arrogant because no matter what your
rating is you are never too good for
double checking a move Jordan fully
understands the gravity of the situation
and guess what Robert I don't think
we're okay three Checkers for us I think
there are other winning moves Rook G3
you could slide your king to D7
preemptively and carve out the C3 Square
for yourself Jordan just making sure
that he finishes this game as surgically
as he started it
yeah he just does not want to give his
opponent any semblance of hope he has
not giving him the slightest bit of Hope
because after the king went to A2 he can
in fact bring his Rook over to A3 and
take this Pawn on A4 if he wants it now
if there were a black Pawn on F7 then
you have to be careful because the
Knight can go back into F6 but here
Dania the King has the Escape Square to
F7 whereas if a pawn run F7 that would
actually be Checkmate that's something
great point
another mating construction the other
one was a drawing mechanism this was a
Checkmate construction that you need to
keep in mind you're always one step away
from getting checkmated that's a
beautiful concept they're put upon on F7
I actually can put it there for you
Knight to F6 uh if it were white to move
would create the insurmountable the
Unstoppable threat of Checkmate on E8 we
mentioned the drawing mechanism with
Knight F6 H7 how many games have been
subtly decided by an end game mate right
all of those things Jordan has to keep
in mind he does indeed deliver a check
on A3 and once again taking his time
slowly meticulously methodically doing
what at this point is the easy work to
convert the advantage into the full
point
yes he's going to take this Pawn on A4
but he is calculating that it is okay to
do so the last thing you want is to
allow an endless barrage of checks to
get your king in some trouble but Rook
takes a force see it on the board and
there he's played it the camera a couple
seconds behind there but he has captured
this Pawn A4 the next move is B3
followed by Rook A2 check it's just too
simple
yeah the machine just drives the tank
just runs right over here black is now
three pawns up and the final Knight
Salvo by notorbeck he brings the Knight
back to F6 in desperation but
desperation it is because this move
doesn't even come with a threat I think
the simplest for black is just to play
B3
straightforward and B3 go for it with
the threat of Rook A2 check I mean
there's just nothing that white has
Knight F6 rookie a check the king slides
F7 that's one single check it's not made
but if that pawn were on F7 that would
be an Unstoppable Checkmate threat
thankfully for Jordan it is not there he
wouldn't have fallen for this and for
Jordan Fun Forest what a end performance
here he almost took down Anish giri he
played the ultimate role of spoiler
because by drawing a niche he kept
abdusitar in the lead but now he takes
down the leader of the event and you can
see it on abusatara's face and he's
leaning in but there's nothing here the
king can always run away to F7 and I do
think that he is going to resign in the
near future and that will leave Anish
giri with his first super tournament
Victory and he can breathe a huge sigh
of relief he will win in front of his
hometown crowd the Dutch number one will
be a champion in Viking Zay at long last
and what better way to Silence the
Critics to silence the trolls Twitter
responses can only get you so far the
best device is a tournament Victory and
the best tournament to win is the 13
round the most prestigious super
tournament held annually Tada steal it's
held now for the 85th year it's a nice
round number and Anish giri will enter
that incredibly exclusive Club of
players who have won this gargantuan
this Herculean tournament who have
withstood these 13 Rounds and maintained
their form from beginning to end and
that is exactly what anishagiri did let
me tell you though Robert he is still
holding his breath he hasn't opened that
champagne bottle yet he hasn't tucked
into his filet mignon or whatever he
will get for his celebratory dinner he
is still pegged either to the board if
he's in the playing skull or to his
computer screen if he's back relaxing in
his hotel room he will not so celebrate
he will not jump on his bed he will not
pop the champagne until this game is
over and the score sheets are signed but
let me tell you the score sheets are
about to be signed
yes they are because that's the new B3
screwed into that square The Rook will
be on A2 next that pawn is a passer it
can hardly be stopped and white just has
no threats all you can do is give a
single check if that and we see Jordan
and we see no dear back on screen that
what you always say Donya when you drink
that water you know that that player is
happy and he's it's true all of that
water yes
he's taking it you know a sip and
another and he is going to have that
sweet taste of victory in his mouth
after this game and you know it's going
to be one of those wins that you feel
badly about because for abusotarev
if he ended as a champion you'd be like
that's fitting for this event but he's
young he will be back this is not going
to be his last time in Vikings day as
not in the Masters tournament uh he has
more events coming up he's won the
Olympiad gold he's one of the world
rapid you could count the accolades here
we know how good Abdul satara is and
it's going to sting it's going to feel
unfortunate uh but we know that he will
be back he'll continue his ascent and he
is just maybe one of the top few players
in the Chess World that everyone has
their eyes on right now and I know this
sounds very reductionist it sounds like
I'm minimizing the pain the pain is the
real the pain will persist for several
weeks the flight back home uh to to
Uzbekistan is is not going to be a
pleasant one
another book is just going to have these
moments on repeat what if I had just
made one move differently what if I you
know hadn't allowed Jordan's h-man to
squeeze its way to H3 what if I didn't
play Queen G3 and kept the Queens on the
board all of the what ifs are going to
accumulate and they're going to keep
circulating like you know like a washing
machine dryer like that cycle is just
going to keep going and going and going
we've all experienced that type of
feeling when one thing we could have
done differently could have led to a
much happier conclusion but he will get
past this and in the grand scheme of
things understanding that time heals all
wow there it is Notre Beck resigns the
game he will get through this
wow and with 70 000 plus people watching
on Twitch and YouTube they see the
resignation that means that Niche Geary
wins this tournament and you can see the
look on Abdus atara's face it is a tough
one for him but if he came into the
event if you asked him you are going to
finish in second place you are going to
beat Magnus Carlson and win three other
games he would say sign me up
unfortunately he had the lead if he had
lost in round one and storm back he'd be
feeling great about his tournament he'll
feel badly about this for a little while
but when all is said and done when we
look back on the 2023 Titusville chess
tournament you have to say that
norderbeck Abdus atarov was an absolute
Beast he was a beast there's no other
word for it he has defeated Magnus
Carlson he has defeated the world number
two he has so much to hang his hat on
and be proud of and there's Smiles
exchanged so gracious by both players
right there let's not neglect that
moment could have easily stormed out of
the playing Hall what pain he must be
feeling on the inside and yet
maintaining his professionalism
congratulating Jordan on a well-deserved
win and I'm sure that he will
congratulate Anish giri as well what a
performance what an end to the
tournament and there Robert we have it a
smiling face anishagiri and that smile
will be on his face for many days to
come
he was a deserving Champion he won that
final game against Richard report that
one was a true fight where Richard was
uncomfortable and ultimately blundered
and you see people talking about
aniskiri silencing the critics the
haters and he won this event and it's
not about the internet right now it's
about his play in this tournament
because as we look at the leaderboard
with one game still in progress or two
games I should say Levon Roni is about
to lose the power muksulu but Anish giri
officially wins the 2023 Tata steel
Chess Masters he wins in rounds 13
against Richard report Rebecca busitar
he stumbles in the final hurdle and that
hurdle is Jordan Von Forest what an
absolutely unbelievable finale and if we
trace the Arc of an ishqiri's career
where does that false reputation come
from the reputation that the security
doesn't win Super tournaments all he
does is make quick draws against the top
players well it comes from the 2016
candidates tournament where Anish giri
played 14 games and he made 14 draws and
ever since then Anish has struggled to
shake that reputation he's been the butt
of some Twitter jokes and guess what I
think now it's time to officially move
on it's time to officially acknowledge
Anish 2.0 and Anish giri who breaks to
the table sharp opening preparation
Exquisite tactical play and who comes to
every tournament with only one desire in
mind to claim first place even if Magnus
Carlson is participating this must feel
amazing for Anish giri and what better
way to celebrate his victory Robert than
to remind everybody particularly those
who are just waking up and joining us
how anishagiri won that sparkling final
game against Richard report take it away
it was a positional Advantage we see
that white has great control of the
light squares of the dark the light
Square Bishops ever get traded the dark
squared Bishop is helpless against a
knight that will jump right back into D5
but here Dania that move F4 what a
choice from Anish giri he kicks that
Bishop back to F6 and he said one Pawn
push is not enough he throws the next
Pawn off the board with G4 and as we saw
this game continue here after the next
few moves Donya it was just getting
scarier and scarier for the black king
and unfortunately for Richard report
after this next turn here Rook C4
quickly Queen to E6 F5 was an absolute
shot it opens up the black king and
after G takes F5 which is an acceptable
move Knight F4 hits the queen aims for
H5 and this after Queen E5 Step One is
correct
step two was not King G6 was a fatal
error it was indeed this position
signified Richard report's last chance
to change the outcome of the tournament
he had to play The Fearless King to f8 a
move we cannot really blame him for
issuing because you have to allow eight
what seems to be a devastating check on
A8 to add insult to injury a capture it
with check on A7 but if you carry this
line forward after King f8 it transpires
that white actually doesn't have a good
way to coordinate his pieces let's not
forget that Anish Gary has also
introduced major weaknesses to his King
position by pushing his pawns the engine
does assign a small Advantage for white
after a move like Rook F1 it's hard to
say how the game would have ended here
Anish giri still might very well have
won in Richard reports time pressure but
that did not happen it is not meant to
be instead report walked the king
forward to G6 allowing a brilliant
tactic that Anish spotted immediately we
could see it and all over his face he
actually didn't write the move King G6
down uh until a couple minutes had
passed so disbelieving was he that
Richard report blundered the incredible
Rook takes D6 a classic deflection
sacrifice if you take the Rook you get
checkmated on F5 and that was all she
wrote Robert a couple of uh attempts to
keep the game going but Anish Gary was
not about to let the cat out of the bag
another accurate move with the Rook D5
and what a way to finish the game Queen
to G3 check forcing the Queen's trade is
he about to convert a technical end game
no he is not you're shaking your head
I'm shaking your head Richard report
extended his hand because after Queen
takes two three Knight takes two three
you're gonna get checkmated on one of
two squares either H5 or if you cover
that square The Rook is going to move
just about anywhere even as simple as
Rook takes B5 and Knight F5 is simply
Unstoppable you have to give up your
rook and uh well with an extra exchange
and three pawns I think Anish Gary would
have converted it into a win
I believe that would have been the case
and even if Richard Port had not made
that blunder it was going to be
difficult it was just a tense position a
lot of tactics there so in Niche Geary
he played a game without fear he threw
his pawns forward he earned himself a
victory not just in round 13 but in the
Tata steel Masters and now there still
are games going in this final round that
is how determined the players are they
don't want to just go home they fight to
the very end and in the game in the
Middle harham maksuda with the black
pieces he is about to win promoting his
Pawn against Lavon aronian and then we
have Magnus Carlson with the black
pieces in the bottom left against Arjun
aragaisi we will dive into that one more
deeply but first we will take a break
when we return we will just look at the
final games here at the Tata steel Chess
Masters or uh oh actually maxulu he
might already be about to win so maybe
we'll stay here in the Palm way up to A2
and give her the commercial kill the
commercial exactly
yeah well the pawn has appeared on A2 it
is rifling forward with Predator natural
speed and I'm gonna flip that game on
because we are watching lebonaroni and
take his last breaths here he has
managed to create exactly zero counter
play against Black's King that Luft
Square on H7 is all that black needs to
dodge White's futile attempt at
Perpetual check levonaronian continues
his Agony no more it's a handshake and
it is a win for Parham aksula and the
first loss Robert for levonne aronian in
this tournament that is an absolute back
breaker yeah now that is unfortunate for
him he was playing a good event he drew
that first game against Magnus Carlsen
where he showed great defense he ended
up almost winning against Argent Eric
icy wasn't meant to be in that one in a
tricky end game and he did score a
victory over Vincent kymer but the rest
of the games were drawn he ends the
tournament with the loss but Parham he
finishes with the flourish
and you've pointed this out several
times arhan was a last second
replacement where young should stop
Judah who couldn't make it so Not only
was his performance impressive the lead
up to it is impressive as well he didn't
have the time to prepare that the other
participants had he had to book a ticket
straight to Amsterdam he had to make
preparations about a week in advance and
not only did he do that with Grace he
managed to turn this tournament around I
think he's actually going to gain rating
and he's going to come away with a
couple of sparkling victories yes a few
painful losses as well particularly the
one against kukesh that is going to
sting but that the bitterness the pain
of that game is going to be diluted by
the sweetness that he must be feeling
now as he defeats levonaroni and with
the black pieces to cap off a fantastic
tournament performance yeah he gains
about 10 rating points so Parham maxulu
at his career high rating so an
excellent event for the last second
replacement he won his final three games
haramax Zulu beat prognanda he beat
everybody guy see he beats aronian so
what a finish it's a turkey if you're
going bowling before the player from
Iran it was just an excellent display of
aggressive tactical chess so we are
going to head towards a break we see our
six results are in the books we have our
generic guys he's still playing against
Magnus Carlson and well speaking of
Magnus Carlson when this tournament ends
his chess playing does not because we
have some excellent events coming up in
the very near future we are so excited
to announce the Champions chess tour
2023 with chess.com and played Magnum
officially coming together we're
bringing you a chess tour like no other
but the biggest prize pool the chess
world has ever seen two million dollars
it all kicks off with the air things
Masters play-ins on February 3rd with
your reigning CCT cgc Champs Magnus
Carlson and Wesley so locked into play
we will call all the action right here
at twitch.tv chess use the command CCT
in chat for more energy back up this
atara's results he had a great first
half the last game was the one that left
him in second place rather than first
but we'll see if Magnus Carlsen can join
him after this short break
do you wish playing a chess game with a
friend was as easy as sending them a
text
for a new way to learn chess meet Dr
Wolf the ideal chess coach and companion
play against Dr Wolf as he explains
everything step by step points out
strategic ideas and alerts you to your
mistakes
train with him and go over your past
mistakes until you master them
choose from over 35 lessons created for
all skill levels
no matter your level everyone could use
a coach download Learn chess with Dr
Wolf for Android or iOS devices today
[Music]
he's gonna win the tournament
this is going to be a turnaround
[Music]
three seconds
foreign
just a few games remain in the playing
Hall in the background is the Challenger
section in the front view is Magnus
Carlsen taking Arjun aragaisy and all
the way in the back are the many fans
who are staying till the end of this
tournament it is a true chess Festival
it's known as The Wimbledon of Chess and
they want to see Magnus Carlson play his
final game in Vikings Day in the year
2023 so Dania we know our winner of the
year it is Anish Geary at long last he
is a runner-up no more and as you see on
this graphic he has finally won the year
2023 with a score of eight and a half
out of 13. what a story third time's the
charm no sixth time is the Char Manish
giri was runner up in 2014. he had two
chances to win Tata Steel in a
tiebreaker against Magnus Carlson and
then what really stung in 2021 against
Jordan van forest and ichigiri was a
monster in that tournament as well
that's when he came to be known as
anishkiri 2.0 that really was the
watershed moment in his career when he
came armed to the teeth with great
opening preparation but it wasn't meant
to be he lost in a Time scramble and now
it took until 2023 this Gary's still
very young he's only 28 years old but
already so experienced so patient so
resilient and Robert what we just saw
today the scenario that unfolded before
our eyes is one that I honestly will
never forget we had mentioned this
outcome as a remote possibility as
something that we had to mention because
we do our job as commentators and let
people know what could happen I did not
think even for a second that 20 sense of
this was going to happen much less than
Anish giri was going to win outright
when he was trailing by half a point
going into the last round it's even hard
to conceptualize mathematically this is
possible and it actually happened
the white pieces and he was playing the
lowest rated player in the field someone
who had struggled throughout the event
but Jordan van Forest he showed his
championship fortitude his pedigree he
has won this event before and I just
want to say for Anish giri this is more
than just a tournament that he has won
this is a tournament in front of the
Dutch people all of the newspapers in
the country they pay attention to this
event it's the 85th Edition and so I
think more than just winning rating
points and winning a chess tournament
this could be a huge spark for his chess
career the amount of attention that will
be on him I hope he's on the talk shows
I hope that the Dutch public they really
celebrate this Victory because it was
hard fought it was well earned and it
was a last minute scramble he had to
beat Richard's report and then he needed
his compatriot and friend Jordan Von
Forrest to take down the leader with
Rebecca so he is a runner-up no more he
is a champion and he has earned this
championship and just an amazing side
effect is that both the number one and
number two players in this tournament
the winner on each Geary and it's hard
to say this but the runner-up not
Rebecca abducator of both of them have
defeated the number one and number two
rated players in the world ding of
course is now in the live ratings number
three but at the time of the game he was
number two I'll do some research I am
definitely a chess history and chess
stats nerd but I think that you can
probably count on one hand the amount of
times that that has happened in a chess
tournament this actually might be the
first time that it's ever happened both
Notre back and Geary deserve the
ultimate Kudos but Anish he was the one
with just a little bit more gas left in
the tank and a little bit of more steel
around those nerves on the final day of
action on this amazing Sunday
as we bring up the game between Argent
aragaisy and Magnus Carlsen the final
one in the 2023 Masters I was shaking my
head just because Maxine vashir legrov
made the number one and two rated
players in the world in a syncful cup
past so it is a rare occurrence the
reason why is because Magnus Carlson has
been the number one rated player for
over a decade for 12 years I believe and
he doesn't lose very often so yeah and
he's lost about three games in that time
right in order to beat number one and
number two you need to beat Magnus and
he just rarely loses but in this game I
mean he is definitely not going to lose
and you see the evaluation bar it is all
the way down Arjun aragasse has had a
bad tournament there is no uh beating
around it he has lost to this point 18
plus rating points if he loses this game
he may even just be at 2700 if not
dropping a little bit below so he wants
to get out of Vikings a as quickly as
possible but he would prefer to end on a
result that's not a loss but look at
this position Donya if you count the
material black is up a pawn and it's a
past G Pawn White's King not the safest
blacks King hard to see how it gets
attacked you would need to go Queen A3
Queen A7 check it takes a couple turns
and Black's Queen is ready to slide down
to H1 if that Queen leaves the first
rank this just seems like a position
that is getting out of hand or maybe
it's already lost for Arjun
yeah it's out of hand for Arjun it's
definitely in magnus's hands he is an
end game Virtua so he was by now I think
it is safe to say the Undisputed best
end game player of all time I think he
would win this game with three minutes
left on his clock he has managed his
time exquisitely in this game he still
has 26 minutes to navigate his way
through the the final couple of hurdles
I think the simplest is indeed to play
the move G3 you can trade Queens you can
win without trading Queens just by
driving the pawn down to G2 and finally
Arjun has paved the way for the move C5
and still that move has been on the
horizon and on the docket Robert forever
it's like something that you see but you
can never reach it you keep walking and
walking and you never seem to find the
opportunity to play that move and even
still after the knights have been taken
off the board if we just look at one
more line after G3 Arjun might very well
try C5 but it ain't gonna cut it because
I can take one pair of Pawn off the
board the problem is that as long as the
king is on the queen side and let's not
forget it seems like it was an eternity
ago no this was this very same game
arjun's King used to be on the king side
he evacuated it for safety reasons
because Magnus was gearing up for a
massive attack on the king side well how
sardonic how unfortunate it is that
Arjun will end up getting victimized on
the side of the board that he ran in
order to evacuate from an attack the
simple Queen to H4 creates decisive
threats against White's gang yes black
allows the move C6 but in comes the
queen bang after Queen B2 bang and black
delivers the decisive check white either
loses the light scored bishop or after
the capture he loses the Dark Sword
bishop and black follows up by making
another queen what a game for Magnus and
it's not over yet Robert but you just
feel that sense of control you just know
that he knows how to land the plane here
yeah and you probably won't even give
Arjun this much play because the
position we have on screen is winning
for black it's clearly winning uh but
I'm wondering if at the start he will do
something that just leaves Arjun with no
options uh and it just feels like the
Magnus thing to do we've seen it so many
times over the years where he plays
these moves that just handcuff his
opponent and they can't do much of
anything so uh in the live position down
here I'm wondering you know G3 looks
very strong why not just push your Pawn
to the other side I'm just wondering if
there's something else that Magnus would
consider here that doesn't give Arjun
even a breakthrough with the C5 is there
anything concrete you're thinking about
I'd like to bring my queen to A8 but
there's a Pawn on E5 and the Queen the
queen has gone back and forth by the way
yeah it was the queen was an h8 then it
went to A8 and now it's back to h8 and
I'm thinking about going back to A8 I
know it just sounds like a lot of eight
and it's kind of like a figure eight but
E4 I think is a way to open up the queen
and the bishop that way next move can be
Queen to eight yeah LaGuardia to JFK
back to LaGuardia and finally it ends
its Journey on A8 I think that's a
lovely idea E4 and queen A1 you always
need to think about mating ideas no
matter how many pieces are left on the
border how few pieces in this case are
left on the board I agree Queen A8 you
close your eyes and you essentially
pre-move the movie four even if white
plays Queen C2 to prevent it that
actually makes E4 even stronger because
it deprives the king of its final
evacuation square and this is just flat
out Checkmate wherever you turn Robert
the lines are extremely one-sided black
has an abundance of options Magnus
always emphasizes Precision he always
emphasizes the elimination of his
opponents counter play so he's going to
take his time here but I've given up
hope on Arjun
yeah this game it looks like it's
completely out of hand and if Magnus
Carlson wins this game that means he
would have won four out of his final
seven rounds that is incredible in any
other tournament in any other year
Magnus probably would have end up in
first place but the problem was he
dropped the rounds to Anish Geary and to
Notre back abdusitarv uh he first lost
in Geary in round four he had the white
pieces I seen the black piece against
him and then with the white pieces in a
rebound game he lost that one as well to
the Uzbek sensation so for Magnus he
ends the tournament with an absolute
bang four wins three draws of the final
seven games that's phenomenal but he
just lost those two games to Gary and
abusotarev and that's the only thing
keeping it back from another first place
finish and it just goes to show how
dominant he's been that we are saying
what a terrible term he's had he's gonna
end up in a tie for second place and as
I just noted he beat many strong players
along the way I was going to say the
exact same thing in a slightly different
way I know that half the chat cringes
when I make any sort of sports reference
so I promise I won't belabor the point
but when we see dominant athletes and
one could debate whether Magnus Carlson
could be called an athlete you know what
I mean a sportsman someone who dominates
their fields the expectations for them
as you're saying become so Sky High that
essentially anytime they don't win a
tournament in Ultra convincing fashion
we call their performance a failure well
the fact that we're that we even do that
in and of itself signifies the extent of
their dominance it's not even the
tournaments that Magnus Carlson wins
that show us how dominant he is and how
long he's been dominant for it's the
tournament that he doesn't win it's the
big deal that we make of a performance
where he scores plus two plus three and
stays out of first place by half a point
the fact that we have these expectations
means that Magnus Carlsen is
undisputedly the greatest player alive
right now perhaps the greatest player in
the history of Chess but this tournament
belongs to an ishigiri and this moment
in the sun belongs squarely to the Dutch
Grand Master
it does and he beat Magnus Carlson that
is what separates the two of them uh it
was it's going to be a half Point ahead
for Anish giri he beat Magnus Carlsen
and that was a really nice game from
Geary so and he started well he finishes
well and that's why he is going not
going to he has already won this event
he's clinched it but for Magnus Carlson
right this final game I we heard his
interview he seemed a bit down but then
if he looks back on the tournament the
last bunch of games and he plays E4
opening up his bishop and queen he wants
queen eight down to A1 with checkmating
threats uh but if he looks back at the
finish here
it was great four wins in the final
seven rounds that is exceptional that's
a performance ready through the roof
that gains him rating which is very hard
for him to do and he has been just so
dominant in years back that we we expect
him to win and when he doesn't win it's
like oh what's what's Madness up to
what's wrong with him and it seemed like
something was wrong when he dropped
rounds four and five and then since then
it's just been uh he's crushing people
it's not even close the game against
Fabiano caruano when he's black yeah I
was thinking of that too he blew him off
the board it was not close at all his
win over Richard report the round before
that Richard got desperate in sacrifice
pieces but Magnus was playing well his
victory over Max sudlu another nice game
from Magnus so I just feel like the
Magnus we've seen in the second half of
the tournament he proves why he's the
best player in the world he just was not
in form in rounds four and five and
Anish Geary took him down and thus
earned tournament Victory later it
helped by that early win indeed he did
and really what separated Magnus from
tournament Victory even with those two
losses were those two white games
against Lucas and Prague and as I said
before I really think that those are the
games that actually sting the most not
the losses it's that draw especially
yesterday against pragnananda Magnus
missed a tactic we expected him to see
but as weird as it is to say this Magnus
is human he does have the occasional
human moment the occasional moment that
we have sort of on a daily basis that we
have every tournament Magnus has it once
in a blue moon and so when he has it we
make such a big deal of it but by and
large Magnus Carlson has demonstrated
yet again that he is the best player in
the world that even when he is in quote
unquote bad form he plays at the very
least four or five games that we can all
learn from and that if anybody else
played they would consider them to be
some of the best games of their career
Magnus Carlson a game like Fabiano
caruana or even a game like this one
against Arch and Eric icy a brilliant
positional display a textbook
illustration of all the Litany of ideas
available to Black and Kings Indian
structures from Magnus Carlson it's just
par for the course of course he wins the
final game of the black against the most
talented Indian Junior of course he does
it because he's Magnus Carlson that's
what he does
he wins games but uh your point is well
taken that that draw yesterday imagine
if he had won that game and then won
this one he would end up in a tie for
First with that's crazy so
after rounds four and five everyone
thought okay this is gone he's got no
chance but then he stormed back and he
almost made it happen but Magnus Carlson
he is definitely going to win this game
let's talk about the ways he can move
forward here so the bishop just took a
Pawn on B6 uh there is no follow-up for
white I think that black you know you
can think about trying to get your queen
in Queen A8 is met by Bishop A5 so
that's a good defensive resource that
origen has so maybe you can slither in
from the other side like Queen H2 and
then try to bring the queen around that
way it also could play G3 next so you're
helping your G Pawn you're bringing your
queen into the E2 square and you're just
hunting for checks which inevitably will
need to Checkmate not such a queen E5
getting your queen in front of the
bishop I didn't even think about that at
first oh my gosh everything is a threat
quid H2 is an excellent move I've heard
this type of move referred to as a setup
move in and of itself it doesn't carry a
threat but you could argue that it
carries a second order threat it is a
move that sets up decide of threats it
puts the kibosh on all of White's
remaining counter play and by the time
white finishes putting his pants on on
the queen side by the pawn but by the
time the pawn even reaches C6 the king
is going to be mated Seven Ways to
Sunday and I can finally use that
expression on a Sunday so it makes a
little bit more sense Queen H2 is on the
board Magnus Carlson does not miss moves
like this at all he missed one of those
moves against the prognan that that was
his allotment for the year
and look at this queen to E5 is a threat
and that lines the bishop and the queen
up on the same diagonal going over to A1
there are no moves to stop Queen E5
maybe it's not going to be the best move
afters but G3 is available to you
um
it turns out the black's just gonna win
by Checkmate but you know there's this
little thingy over on G4
and for white what's the current move C5
just locks your Bishop away from the
rest of the game that doesn't seem very
helpful the D5 Pawn will also be loose
so
uh allow me uh
do you make a remark sorry to interrupt
you it'll be worth it I promise that
just this remark alone tells us
everything we need to know I did commit
the grave sin of turning on our silicon
fiend the top move is Bishop B6 to d8
and no there's no devious idea you
literally give the bishop away then the
bishop returns to F6 and black delivers
Checkmate
is that do I need to say anything else
no that is how you know the position is
incredibly lost and Incredibly sad when
your best move is Bishop d8 just giving
away a free piece to distract the bishop
for one turn so that must mean that
there is a Checkmate on the horizon a
queen E5 looks like it's just going to
crush uh White's position
um
yeah I got nothing for you Donna I guess
Arjun could throw in a check on E6 but
even that move harms his defensive
chances as if he has any because once
the bishop moves away from F5 blackheads
he had another mating idea pushing out
the Jeep on but the e-pawn and not to
promote it but to vacate the E4 Square
for his light squared Bishop so every
single one of Black's Pieces perhaps
except the king could in some way
contribute to the mating mechanism
Magnus will choose his pick our generic
I see there he knows the outcome of the
game he is searching searching hard for
last ditch attempts he does not want to
lose the last game of the tournament it
really is a heartbreaking performance
for Arjun he will come away without a
single win not how he envisioned his
first Tata steel but the key words there
Robert is first how to steal definitely
not his last well his first time still
Masters I should say because he rampaged
The Challengers last year and all he
needs is a little bit more experience
and as I said about Vincent he too will
come back stronger he will analyze the
games
and you will come back with a vengeance
next year and you see it for most of the
teenagers in this field they have
dominated the circus right when they
play The Challengers tournament we saw
Arjun Eric icy Crush that field and then
they play in some open events and they
win those titles but it's a lot
different when you're playing in a
closed round robin with 13 players who
are amongst the world's best and that's
with all due respect to the Grandmasters
out there have been beating along the
way but they're beating sometimes
Grandmasters like me versus Grand
Masters like Anish giri and Magnus
Carlson and Fabiano caruana and dingley
ren you get the point so it's a great
lesson for them it's probably their
first classical event playing this level
of opposition and we saw Arjuna geisie
in the world rapid and Blitz he had such
a great performance I think his opponent
average in the uh rapid was something
like 27 20 and he scored like eight and
a half of the 13 points something like
that maybe was eight out of 13. either
way it was a massive score against great
opponents we know he has what it takes
but this in his first foray into the top
section yeah just it was a tough go of
it for him and we definitely feel for
him Magus Carlson is not going to be
sympathetic it will be our generator
guy's fifth loss of this event to go
along with eight draws and yeah he'll
get back to the drawing board he will
improve and he will find more success in
another event
and I will tide up our discussion of
Arjun by making a point that I made
after we finished commentating uh
tournament a couple of months ago which
is that chess fans I think fall into the
Trap of just assuming that the result of
each tournament is in some way
predetermined or it was meant to be and
it had to be this way from the very
beginning not so and I think arjun's
performance is a case in a point
lest we forget Arjun did not lose the
game until I think round four or round
five he had a brilliant save with the
black pieces in time pressure against
Anish Gary in fact he saved several bad
positions in a row in the early going of
the tournament and we just thought that
if he manages to get out of the opening
in a slightly better position then he
will be able to turn the tournament
around and score some victories he had a
better position against other bank Abdus
atarov so one of the most scintillating
things about Chess as Magnus shifts his
Queen even closer to whites King
completing the vice-like grip and
setting up 8 000 Checkmate threats
things could have turned out differently
Robert and things really do in Elite
chess come down to one move one move
differently against Notre Beck one move
differently by Magnus Carlson against
prognananda and we could have been
looking at an entirely different cross
stable singing a completely different
tune singing the Praises of completely
different players that takes nothing
away from Anish guri's performance it
just shows that everything comes down to
the details they do indeed and our
generic I see he handed the U.S team
some suffering in this past Olympia that
he beat Leonard Dominguez in the final
round and linear was having a great
tournament so I was there firsthand to
watch arjun's Excellence he also won the
Abu Dhabi Festival the Masters
Tournament that was amazing he went I
think seven or seven and a half of the
nine and he just was dominating an
impressive field to beat Wong Hao I
remember that game so I feel like you
know he's on the cusp of something and
he's shown that he is a 2700 plus player
it's just so difficult to play this
level of opposition 13 Rounds against
players where you lose a game in a Swiss
tournament you get a lighter pairing you
lose the game here and your next
opponent is Magnus Carlson that's just
pain adding on top you know setting
insult to injury almost so I feel for
the guy he's so strong he's so likable
he is an absolute Legend he's not a huge
sponsorship deal uh in India and he is
about probably one move away from
resigning in this one and and Magnus
Carlson is going to take this final game
here at the tattoo steel Chess Masters
he is indeed there are many ways many uh
every load road leads to Oslo here and
uh the queen I think is going to slide
back to D3 with a devastating check
in the event that white screen blocks I
think the queen will slide to its final
destination on A3 if the king moves away
that Bishop from F3 could jump into D1
literally if you lift a piece and drop
it on a square the likelihood is Robert
that that move will indeed lead to
Checkmate and Magnus is not going to
Heap Arjun aragaisy struggling too much
longer a check on D3 has been delivered
and resignation will happen any second
now
and with that win Magis Carlson will go
into a share of second place there are
no tie breaker matches for second place
he will tie it with your back Abdus tarf
who beat him head to head so for Magnus
a good end to what has been an event to
forget and look at that it's a handshake
it's a victory and I do feel for our
generic guys such a good player uh such
an excellent person he's won the junior
speed Chess Championship ahead of nihal
sarin and the players they're talking
about this game the tournament is over
it's been a long time and yet they still
want to talk about Chess
and I just have to commence you know the
sort of state of Chess in India there's
a huge chess boom Going On we've
obviously named the big names so many
times from nihal sarin to the two
competitors in this tournament gukesh
and Eric icy but also just the class
with which they handle themselves it's
not just the moves they make on the
board I have noticed that after every
one of his losses our Genera guys he has
remained at the Port calmly discussing
his mistakes with his opponents and I
know that may seem like a small thing
but that right there I think is the
Hallmark of a future Champion Arjun
handles himself like a professional he
cares about the truth he cares about
improving and he understands that these
20 points he loses in this tournament
yes very painful yes he's going to come
back to this hotel room and he ain't
gonna be happy tonight but he's going to
move on from this he's going to learn
from his mistakes and this is not his
last game far from his last game against
the world champion and I believe Fabiano
caruana said on the c-squared podcast
when talking about these teenagers the
kind of Next Generation who has the
chance to reach 2800 I believe that
Fabiano singled out Arjun eragisi he
said that he sees it in him that he is
capable in all facets of the game he's
great at quick chess he's great of
course in classical chess and just the
way he is able to put a Stranglehold on
certain positions but then also open up
with devastating tactics Arjun Aaron
geisey is a beast he just was in a
tournament full of bigger beasts at the
moment so it's just a next tournament it
could be completely different abusotarev
and Arjuna could switch places uh but it
just wasn't his event this time around
we look forward to seeing him back in
the tournaments but we do have to talk
about what happened besides this game
Magnus Carlson scores a victory with the
black pieces so did Jordan Von Forrest
in an upset and Anish giri is thrilled
because with his win over Rich report
anise Geary is the champion
you would be forgiven if you just joined
us if you just woke up if you're on the
west coast it's still 8 40 in the
morning the sun is still just coming up
hopefully you Rouse yourself early if
you didn't you will want to watch the
replay because this was one of the most
epic rounds I have ever seen in any
tournament in my entire chess
commentating career you would be
forgiven for assuming that there is a
typo that no not Rebecca De sotorov
should have the one Jordan man Forest
should have the zero it is not a typo
Jordan van Forest delivers he is the
king maker he is the ultimate spoiler he
changes the final standing Anish giri is
going to buy him a whole case of Dom
Perignon or whatever Jordan van Forest
desires and Anish giri wins the
tournament with a monster score of eight
and a half out of 13 and let's not
pretend Robert that that win was
coincidental was he helped yes he
absolutely was did he deserve this win
yes he absolutely did among his wins
Magnus Carlson dingley Wren and in the
last round a sparkling brilliant
you mean Richard report
Ed
yeah my friend hey yeah but Jordan was
his friend and Richard report we see he
leads the bottom half of the tournament
six and a half of 13. he was doing so
well in the last bunch of rounds and
then today he blunders in one move in a
tough position so we you know understand
how that happened and for the rest of
the field Jordan Von Forest jumps up to
a tie for Ninth Place with prognanda
prognanda improves on his performance
from last year I believe he scored five
and a half a year ago this year six
points he showed at the start of the
tournament that he can play for first
place and then it kind of went downhill
from there a bit that's the nature of
this tournament the biggest uh player on
the stage who struggled with dingley Ren
five and a half out of 13. and that is
not what we're used to seeing from the
world championship Challenger and well
we have to congratulate Anish giri I
mean he really had the performance of a
lifetime uh you know it's just such a
great feat for him he did catch up with
Fiona main feelings are related to the
game I found out that I ruined a very
big Advantage so I'm slightly annoyed
with that I thought it was a better game
than it was
because I think I told you in previous
interview doesn't work as Bishop G7 is
there so
yeah I cannot say it's the best day but
of course it's the best result I've had
so far obviously I think it's as Jordan
said also when he won like it's um hard
to have a better result other than the
win the World Championship
but of course as I already was saying
before like this doesn't change very
much in terms of what I have to do
looking forward and I have a lot of
challenges this year
and uh yeah it stays the same there's a
lot a lot to accomplish and uh already
and here and there I felt there's a lot
of work to be done uh for me and um even
though I Rose in the rankings very much
I felt that uh
I've been given a little bit of a um
like an advanced payment you know for
and I still have to do a lot of work
because I I haven't played classical
chess for so long and I saw here
remembers you know what it takes to to
play class coach as well and uh yeah I'm
into work
you heard it from Anish Geary that was
this the best day it would have been
better if he was even more precise than
the Precision he showed to take down
Richard report that's such a chess
player answered Dania that when you win
the game that leads you to the
tournament victory of your life you're
still a little bit upset that you didn't
play perfectly
and let me tell you Anish Gary is
euphoric I think those feelings of
Happiness of unbridled Euphoria they're
bubbling up inside of him but he's still
just getting his eyes adjusted to the
final Tournament standings he has just
won that game he still needs to just
pinch himself and remind himself that
yes this is reality I think later today
when the tension will have fully
subsided when the players will be seated
together at a table for the closing
ceremony it will Dawn on anishki what he
has just done and what that is is a
tournament victory in the second most
important event after the world
championship this is an incredible
accomplishment it is one that he will
cherish for many years but as Anish giri
is the first to admit he hopes to use it
not as the culmination of his career
obviously he isn't even 30 years old but
as a springboard to even greater
achievements and hopefully one day the
world championship
I know any scary quite well and I know
that his thoughts are that he wants to
be the best player in the world he
doesn't just want to win a tournament
here a tournament there he wants to be
the best and that is the drive you need
to succeed and to become a champion like
he became today in tata steel So Daniel
it's been an amazing event we saw some
players come back from the dead so to
speak like parhamak Sulu with a three in
a row finishing the top half of the
field he was a last second in the T so
of course the story lines were about
anishikiri I already pick up dusitor of
Magnus Carlson the big three if you will
but what are your final thoughts about
the tournament at Large
well I'm speechless I feel like in these
moments when a tournament of this
magnitude of this gravitas when it comes
to an end words really fail to capture
the essence of the moment because the
essence of the moment is ineffable it's
so deep it cannot be captured in just a
couple of sentences but what I will say
first and foremost is that it has been a
great honor a pleasure a privilege to
cover this event I'd like to shout out
my previous co-commentator Yvonne
kahuska but of course Robert we covered
the last three days there really isn't
anybody I could possibly think of who I
would rather Buckle in to the seat and
watch the games with I think you're
amazing and uh you know it has been just
such a treat to have courtside seats to
the action in this Marathon event it
wasn't always easy to wake up it was
still dark outside when our alarms went
off sometimes we stumbled in various
states of undress with teeth unbrushed
to the computer but at the end of the
day there would be nowhere I would
rather be than in front of the computer
watching the these games as the
tournament unfolded and as we hit an
epic finale what a performance by
nishkiri how many story lines and
narratives did we see in this tournament
countless wherever you look you will see
amazing games you will see memories and
you will see performances that will will
be remembered for many years to come
they certainly will and the feeling is
mutual their partner and I just want to
say that you know on behalf of all the
players in this field from first place
finisher Anish Geary all the way down to
the teenagers who struggled some of them
who showed better chess in the second
half this would not be possible without
their play their great chess they are
trying their best they're giving it
their all and they're also performing
works of art for us as we see them play
some beautiful games so I want to thank
the players first and foremost I did
thank you partner I want to thank the
chat for always being there for watching
these games even when they start very
early in America's time zones and of
course our producers all the
commentators mentioned Ivanka hoska also
Tanya sachdev she had the call with me
earlier in the event and of course just
everybody who plays chess so thank you
so much if you haven't had enough chess
a rebroadcast of this final round will
take place at 10 A.M Pacific time I know
it's early for plenty of people and
Sunday yeah you're doing other things
but we will have a rebroadcast at 10 A.M
Pacific time so tune in for that if you
missed the start of the round but we
will say goodbye to what has been a
great tournament in the Dutch town of
Viking Zay this is the Wimbledon of
Chess it was the 85th Edition and Denise
Geary is your Champion until next time
this has been Robert Hess and Daniel
neranditski with chess.com
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign